order a lot
foreign
the public order emergency commission is
now in session like
good morning bonjour
another beautiful day in Ottawa
okay we have a
let me guess another witness we do okay
good morning commissioner it's Frank O
for the commission and our next witness
is superintendent Dana early from the
opp
foreign
superintendent early will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm
foreign
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Dana early Dana is
d-a-n-a early is e-a-r-l-e-y
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God I do so
swear thank you
foreign
good morning superintendent early good
morning it's good to see you again thank
you you as well
um so you attended an interview with me
and my commissioned colleagues back on
the 9th of September yes I did and a in
a summary of that interview was prepared
afterwards I understand that you
recently had an opportunity to review
that summary and there's some
corrections you like to make yes so if
we can bring up that document it's WTS
six zeros 22.
if we go to page 13
. so I understand there are two
Corrections you like to make on this
page and the first correction is at the
first paragraph am I right
uh no it's actually just the third
paragraph in regards to decision making
just wanted to make it clear that
ultimate decisions in regards to the
operation plan were mine
okay so uh the third paragraph that
starts with following this call right
yes
um so tell us uh What uh exactly you
want changed
uh there is a sentence there uh that
indicates the Direction came to the
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner
Harkins that is incorrect the decision
to move forward was mine okay so that
sentence that starts with she informed
them that the change in Direction came
from commissioner karik and Deputy
Commissioner Harkins should be deleted
right that's correct and understand that
the first sentence
that reads currently following this call
at 706 PM superintendent early advised
her command table that they should
proceed you want that revised as advise
her command table that she had decided
that they would proceed am I right
that's correct
um so I thought there was another change
you wanted to make to the first
paragraph no no okay thanks all right so
is there any other Corrections you'd
like to make
um no okay so we'll have those
corrections made and this will be
entered into evidence
now um you're a superintendent with the
Ontario Provincial Police that's correct
and how many years have you served with
the opp uh 28 years now did you start
your policing career with the opp I did
yes and back in January when the freedom
Convoy events began you were a strategic
Commander for the west region yes that's
correct what areas were covered by the
west region
west region is basically Collingwood all
the way down to Windsor all the
municipalities in that area that do not
have their own Police Service is a
responsibility of West Region OPP and
how many superintendents were there for
that region there's three
superintendents who are the other two at
the time is superintendent Frankie
Campisi and superintendent Lisa darling
okay and do all three of you report to a
chief superintendent yes that's correct
who was that in January it is Chief
superintendent Dwight fibb okay and as a
superintendent of the west region what
were your responsibilities back in
January of this year
um as part of my responsibilities I
support four of the 13th detachments
that we have in west region and also I
support the Operational Support uh
inspector and take on the role excuse me
take on the role of strategic Commander
okay and at that time were you based in
London that's correct
and um
I understand that um on the on the 9th
of February you assumed a new role when
uh Deputy Commissioner Harkins appointed
you as the critical incident commander
in Windsor that's correct I received a
call from Deputy commission commissioner
Harkins on the night of February 9th
and we heard from deputy chief Crowley
yesterday from The Windsor Police
Service that you established a joint or
unified command with the Windsor Police
Service that oversaw the successful
resolution of the blockade in Windsor
that's correct so we'll come to those
events a bit later but I want to start
by asking you about your training and
experience that qualified you to take on
those roles in January and February
um let's begin with your background with
the incident command system what kind of
training have you received
um I have been a crisis negotiator for
13 years of my career and crisis
negotiators are used quite often in
incidents so I had experience that way
um I am an Incident Commander as well as
of 2012 and then in 2017 I was trained
to become a critical incident Commander
and in terms of the courses that you had
to attend before you assume those roles
tell us about that too
the critical incident Commander is a
four-week course where you receive
training in regards to
larger incidents how to manage them
communication the execution the options
you hear several different presentations
from your subject matter experts which
include our Emergency Response Team
could I ask you to go a little slower
for the interpreters please sure
my apologies
uh subject matter experts that would
include crisis negotiators are Emergency
Response Team our tactical Rescue Unit
our canine units all options that would
be used in a critical incident
and which institution offer that course
it's through the opp
and what year did you complete
2017. were there different levels of
training for an Incident Commander or
critical incident Commander uh the
critical incident Commander with the opp
is somewhat the highest at this point
okay aggressive training and I
understand you met some colleagues uh
that you worked with ultimately when you
were deployed to Windsor in February yes
that's correct I took the critical
incident command course with um now
interim Chief Jason Bellaire of Windsor
Police
and uh now you also took on some
leadership training
um
more recently uh tell us about that too
um I was fortunate enough to complete
the Canadian police College executive
leadership and policing course which is
a year course and I also finished the
rotman leadership course uh just in the
fall of 2021 and you met another
colleague who was to work in the Windsor
Incident Command right that's correct
who was that inspector Carl DeGraff and
I completed the rotman course together
okay
um
and
isn't it true that you not only attended
those courses and you had experience as
an incident commander and critical
instant Commander you also taught
courses in that regard uh yes I have uh
debriefed different calls on the
internet command course as well as the
critical incident command course
now there are two Frameworks that we've
heard a little about that as I
understand from our interview uh kind of
guided you when you approach the
situation in Windsor one was the opp
framework for police preparedness for
indigenous critical instance
for those of us who are not familiar
with that framework can you tell us give
us a quick overview of what that is
about
um it it stresses the importance of
communication and a tiered response uh
almost like a stepladder I that you
explore different options uh amongst
during the incident to see what option
would be best to safely resolve it an
important part of that policy is the
fact that as I said I said communication
and also the introduction of our
provincial liaison team that's part a
key part of the framework as well okay
we'll come to talk a little more about
that and the other framework is the cacp
or Canadian Association of chief of
police national framework and you
mentioned in the in our interview that
that was consistent with the opp
critical policy tell us more about that
that's correct it's it certainly
highlights communication and the
different tiered responses depending on
the situation
so were you familiar with both
Frameworks when you took on the the role
of critical incident commander in
February yes
all right let's turn now to
um before we get to your role as the
critical incident commander in February
I want to start uh with your role as the
Strategic Commander
um as for the west region in January
so that was when you were still working
out of London Ontario
um and what you you talked to us a
little bit about your responsibilities
as the Strategic Commander but uh what
specifically uh were your involvement uh
with respect to the freedom Convoy or
the protest traveling through the West
we had um at the time we had numerous
slow rules and protests happening
throughout our different municipalities
I had oversight on the events worked
with the Operational Support inspector
and each Detachment Commander to ensure
that we had the proper resources to
effectively look after the protests or
slow roles that were going through our
municipalities
now when commissioner karik testified at
the hearing he told us about a blockade
on Highway 402 on around February the
6th were you familiar with that incident
yes I was involved in that incident tell
us about your involvement
on February 6 which was a Sunday we
became aware that the protesters had
blocked the bridge the Blue Water Bridge
in Lambton County as a result our
provincial liaison team as well as our
front line members were deployed to the
area
provincial liaison team were able to
develop a rapport in a relationship with
the protesters and ultimately there was
a number of different trucks that
weren't able to cross the border at that
time and one of them ultimately was a
friend of one of the protesters and one
of the truck drivers I believe it was
livestock he had something he was
traveling with something that needed to
be in a certain area by a certain time
PLT liaised with the truck driver that
was stuck and with the protesters and
were able to work out the opening of The
Bridge
so that was a success the bridge did
reopen we also learned around that time
that that group or similar to that group
of protesters were planning on doing a
slow roll on Highway 402 that week
so we liaised with the organizers of the
slow Rule and to try to find out as much
information as possible so that we could
have the proper resources in place so
first with respect to the incident on
the Blue Water Bridge how long did it
take to resolve that event
I'd have to make reference to my note
but I know it was maybe two hours most
two to three hours so it was really
short yes
um and and was Highway 4 to the highway
that led to Sarnia the the Blue Water
Bridge that's correct and would that be
within the opp jurisdiction the police
Highway 402 is correct okay
um
now um You you spoke about other Slow
Roll events um and we heard a little bit
about that yesterday from uh deputy
chief Crowley what other protests or
slow roles were happening in the west
region around that time
if memory serves me we almost had a slow
role in each municipality but ones that
I can recall specifically would be Essex
County
Norfolk County Brant County South Bruce
County
Huron County
so there was quite a few
and as the Strategic Commander at that
time responsible for for these events
what steps did you take to monitor the
situation or to prepare for any further
escalation of the events
each event
was specifically assigned to the
Detachment Commander he or she would
then sign it in assign an Incident
Commander to have oversight of the
specific event happening in their area
they would also work with our provincial
liaison team to find out as much
information from the protesters and we
would ensure from a regional level that
they had the supports that they needed
now were you a recipient of the opp
Hendon reports
uh yes and did you read them regularly
um yes but I focused on the areas that
were involving our municipalities
so um turning now turning out our
attention now to Windsor we heard
yesterday that um there was a Hendon
report on February the 4th uh that's
that view specifically with the
potential blockade so if I could take
you to that report
um the document number is OPP 50825
if we go to page six please
foreign
we go down
so you see the second bullet
um
says commercial truck drivers and
supporters May conduct slow roles on
roadways near the Ambassador Bridge over
the next three days and may attempt to
block the bridge on February the 7th so
this seems to be compared to the earlier
reports this seems to be more specific
warning particular to the bridge and
with a date do you remember if you
received this report or Reddit at around
that time I don't recall okay
um and um
do you know what actions if any were
taken by the OPP to mitigate that risk
to uh February 7th um when I became
aware
through
um superintendent Crowley now interim
deputy chief
that the bridge had been blocked I
received an email from him I then had a
conversation with him asking him what he
needed and at that time he was looking
for information in regards to what was
available
I said basically whatever you needed I
think I know the the one you're
referring to did you say the February
the seventh seventh but before we get to
that I think there was another email
earlier that you were copied on so if I
could take you to that earlier email I
believe it's dated February the 4th and
the document number is WPS 501880.
so for for contacts I believe this is an
email from Chief superintendent sip okay
to uh deputy chief Crowley and you were
copied on that
so you see the headings uh Windsor slow
roll Slash Bridge protest so you weren't
um the direct recipient but you were
copied on this yes and uh so in this
email
um
Chief zip talked about
the prospect so if we go to the second
line he said should Intel be received or
action by demonstrators taken to shut
down the Ambassador Bridge don't
hesitate to reach out for joint
assistance
um and then you were copied because you
were overseeing the Emergency Response
Team for for the region first of all
what were your responsibilities as
uh
to uh for for oversight over the
Emergency Response Team what's the
Emergency Response Team
um so as part of the Strategic Commander
that's one of the teams that I support
so it's an oversight in regards to do
they have the proper resources training
up to date I work with their team lead
in regards to making sure that they have
what they need so in this email it seems
like the opp was taking a kind of wait
and see approach is that fair
uh we were waiting to see what Windsor
actually required
um so in this email
um
deputy chief Crowley was obviously being
given my name because of my role as
strategic Commander
and Beyond waiting for a further request
from Windsor was there anything that in
your view the the opp could do
proactively to mitigate the risk at this
point before the blockade materialized
not that I'm aware of okay well let's go
then to uh February the 7th
um
now you mentioned an email uh from
deputy chief Crowley yes I believe that
email is actually dated February the 8th
if we're thinking about the same email
so I'll call up that document WPS
five zeros or six zeros WPS six zeros
three seven four
now uh is this the email you had in mind
or was there another one
if there was one prior and we had a
conversation as well okay
um so uh tell us about that earlier
Exchange
uh it was basically confirming that the
bridge had been blocked and that
um he was looking for an awareness of
resources available we then had a
conversation I wanted to confirm if he
was asking for resources or if he was
just trying to figure out options at
that time so I learned that he was
trying to figure out options of what was
available
and it was at that time that we had
decided to um send together jointly we
decided to send provincial liaison team
members to Windsor to see if they could
assist mm-hmm so is this email a
follow-up to that earlier exchange it is
and uh so when he was asking you I know
your people are very spread out but my
ass at this point is if we were to need
Pou or PLT down here what would
availability be so it seems like he's
ascertaining the um the potential
availability of Opp resources absolutely
he's looking for options and you
mentioned earlier that you were sending
some PLT members uh to Windsor that's
correct uh was that before uh or after
this email uh that was immediately after
I believe they went down the like that
day because the emails at two o'clock in
the morning so I wouldn't have got it
until I woke up in the morning but um so
the sanding of the two pot members was a
response to this request that's correct
uh what about Pou he asked about Pou
here as well uh again he confirmed that
he was just looking for options so we
discussed options
um
so this is February the 8th um now we
heard yesterday
um
that Chief masuno from The Windsor
Police Service sent a letter on February
the 9th that following day to minister
Jones
um I won't
I don't think I need to call up that
document uh before reference yeah the
document ID is w i n four zeros 1648 and
in that letter uh Chief misuno requested
a minimum of 100 officers
um now was that request before or after
you were appointed as the critical
incident Commander to Windsor
I wasn't appointed until the night of
the ninth okay so probably before before
um and we saw also on February 9th a
document prepared by
um deputy chief Crowley before I take
you to that document I want to take you
first
um to uh something you said in your
interview about the relationship between
resource request and planning so we go
to your summary at page nine please
foreign
Council can I get the ID for that
document again yes it's um WTS
six zeros
22.
hey Mr clerk I'll be making frequent
references to this summary so uh it may
assist to have that document open
so if we go to page nine
foreign
so superintendent you see under the
heading relationship between resource
request and planning
um you told us that
when you took command on February the
9th Windsor Police Service did not know
the specific numbers and types of
officers it required and that the
underground situation on February 9th
dictated bringing in additional
Frontline and traffic officers to ensure
public and officer safety
OPP accordingly sent as many officers as
possible
after superintendent early arrived in
Windsor on the morning of February the
10th and began to develop a plan she was
able to develop more specific numbers
and types of resources required to
ensure that police had options to
respond to various contingencies
so I want to show you a document that
asked deputy chief Crowley prepared as
of the ninth and asked you if that
reflects the kind of lack of specific
types that you mentioned in the summary
and that document is
WPS 60610
so we heard from Deputy Crowley
yesterday that he prepared this uh on
the ninth when Windsor made the request
for 100 officers we scroll down a bit
so it talks about different shifts
and so on and then there's more about
the situation at that time
is this reflect your understanding of
the nature of the request that was sent
on the ninth
I'm not sure if I know what you're
asking but it it reflected what they
thought at the time they required so
when I arrived and we were able to
assess the entire situation together
um that's when we started to figure out
plans and options and then therefore the
resources to support those
so I guess what I'm wondering is how is
this kind of request in terms of what
was needed uh different from the kind of
request that you would have made to the
different Pou units across the province
for instance after you arrived and
started developing a plan
well this uh specific request that you
have posted here is for the front line
so Pou was in addition to that so I
don't know if we could compare the two
um but when the unified command was
created we had a mission and that was to
open the bridge to get the flow of
traffic back with officer and Public
Safety being Paramount and then that's
when we did started to develop the plans
which included a Pou option
okay if we go back to your interview
summary
to that page that we were on before
you see the last sentence of that
paragraph she explained that developing
an operational plan was essential to
ensure that the deployment of resources
would be impactful and resolve the
blockade why was it essential why was an
operational plan essential
well before you request resources or you
have officers attend you need to be able
to articulate to them the expectations
of the role why they're coming and the
tasks that they are be will be given and
without a plan and a mission as to what
you want to achieve that would be very
hard to do
okay
so um so these are the initial steps
before you became the uh the critical
incident Commander so let's turn our
attention now to February the 9th uh
when you got a call from Deputy
Commissioner Harkins appointing you as
the critical incident commander tell us
about that initial call
uh Deputy Commissioner Harkins called me
he asked if I could attend Windsor to
assist that my role would be the cicc of
the event and that
um it was uh of it was an urgent
situation so that I would receive the
resources that I needed
um I he also alerted me that I had a
teleconference that I needed to join
within minutes
um so the phone call was very quick
so there was an urgency that he
impressed on you and just to understand
the nature of the role of a critical
incident Commander
um we've heard evidence before
um about the different tiers of command
there's the Strategic command there is
the operational command and there is the
Tactical command now you were operating
as a strategic Commander before this
appointment yes uh and what is the role
of a critical incident Commander is it
operating at a strategic or operational
level it's at an operational level and
uh specifically assigned to an incident
so what was the objective of your
appointment as the critical incident
Commander oh for short I'll just call it
the operational Commander
the
do uh restore the flow of traffic
to and from the bridge and into Canada
and the US
um by respect with respecting the
Charter of Rights and keeping public and
officer safety Paramount
now I understand that you went to
Windsor the next day that's correct but
on the ninth you were still in London
yes uh what time did you get that call
from uh Deputy Harkins uh it was
approximately
7 30 quarter to eight and then I was on
teleconferences until well into the
early morning so you got the call in the
evening and you started uh
to make some other calls yes tell us
about those other calls the initial
calls that you made
um there was a call to my chief of West
Region to provide him updates and he was
well aware because the Deputy
Commissioner had contacted him
I I also had teleconferences with the
POU Hub and the different team leaders
of the POU teams what are the POU hubs
uh they were hubs created
um that consisted of different Pou teams
from different services that were being
deployed throughout the province to
assist with protests and when you said
services are these OPP detachments or
are these Municipal Services as well OPP
and municipal
how many Pou units are there across
Ontario can you say oh
um
I can't sorry I can tell you who was on
the calls or who I dealt with but it
included obviously our team it included
Hamilton at the time and Waterloo and
ultimately London assisted as well and
RCMP
so um you reach out to the POU unit in
these uh municipalities that evening
yes so the Deputy Commissioner had
advised me that the teleconfidence was
already set it was already scheduled and
that I would be joining them and they
would learn that I was going to be the
cic and unified command and heading to
Windsor what did you find out from the
teleconference about the availability of
these Pou teams we discussed numbers and
what was available we discussed uh
relative like to the incident you know
in regards to when could they attend uh
who was available to assist with
planning so that those were the basis of
the conversations
was there a request to deploy those
units uh on that evening yes uh what did
you ask for
um I asked for the planners so each team
identified basically a team leader a
planner so I asked for the planners to
join me in Windsor the next day
now at this stage you didn't have a plan
yet right correct
um so if we go back to what we talked
about earlier about the need for plan to
inform the asking of resources what did
you ask for and what could reasonably be
expected at this stage
I needed them to become very familiar
with the incident and all the details of
the incident and then create a plan what
about numbers
uh well I needed to know what would be
available uh but again it wasn't until
they had a plan that they would say that
this plan requires this many officers
okay so um you talked about how you
spoke to the chief I believe that's
Chief sip that's correct you spoke to
you had you engaged in these
teleconferences about the PLU
availability who else did you call
I believe it was two teleconferences
well it was with the chief and two other
teleconferences with again with Pou hubs
what about uh did you make contact with
Windsor Police Service at all I did I
spoke with uh deputy chief Crowley and
tell us about that conversation
um he provided an oversight and the
situation and and situational awareness
for me in regards to what they were
dealing with at the moment we talked
about logistics obviously when I would
be arriving um I gave him an overview of
the teleconferences I had been on in
regards to Pou
mm-hmm now um
if I could take you to another OPP
document it's OPP four zeros4540
I understand that that night uh the last
thing you did that night at 11 59 PM you
sent an email to your superiors
summarizing the situation in Windsor as
you've gathered so I'm taking you to
that email if we could go if we go to
page 14 please
uh go down
so um February 9th
I think I was wrong on the time is at
23.58 so two minutes before midnight
um you sent an email to Harkins and
DeMarco who's Demarco
that is Deputy Commissioner Demarco
okay uh how many Deputy Commissioners
are there are three and there's a
provincial Commander as well okay so you
sent an email to these two deputies and
you summarize uh the situation as you
found them in Windsor we scroll down
further
there are many bullet points I I want
you to help us unpack the situation a
bit based on these points what did you
learn uh what's the situation on the
ground in Windsor
I learned obviously about the numbers
what they were dealing with in regards
to attendance as well as Vehicles the
types of vehicles I also learned the
area that they had um got blocked the
length of it the where it is located in
the city
I also learned about an arrest that was
made so there was a person who had
jumped the curb and into the crowd
that person obviously was charged and
arrested with dangerous drive and
um that the crowd became very agitated
when the arrest occurred
and they actually took the opportunity
to expand the area that they had been in
I learned two from deputy chief Crowley
that it the crowd itself was somewhat or
unorganized and disjointed uh hard to
kind of figure out exactly what they
wanted or to
um communicate or negotiate with them
and at that time as well he explained
that there had been a number of
Transport trucks and vehicles on the
bridge but they had all been removed at
that point
so I made the decision that I asked
staff sergeant Jamie Smith of S6 OPP so
he would be the closest Incident
Commander to attend the command post for
the evening I also asked that our
situational reports be implemented so
it's basically a template we introduced
those to the command post and I asked
for those to be provided to me every two
hours until my arrival and then they
continued while we were there so that's
what you did that first night that's
correct
um if we go back to your summary I want
to take you to page three
because you talked you spoke to us about
um about this email and then at the end
of that paragraph
uh you said
superintendent early nonetheless believe
that a policing solution to the
demonstration was possible
what did you mean by that the policing
solution in your mind
um I still believed and I was hopeful
that negotiations could occur and that
we could develop a rapport in a
relationship with the protesters through
our provincial liaison teams was that an
approach informed by the two Frameworks
that you told us about that's correct
now um
before we go to the next day
um earlier that day before you got the
call from Deputy Harkins
um
I think you told us in the interview
that you watched a morning press
conference where the mayor the mayor of
Windsor mayor dilkins requested
resources without specifying the numbers
do you remember that uh yeah I don't
remember specifically watching it but I
do know that a request was submitted
right so um and during our interview you
shared your perspectives on making
public announcements of this nature tell
us about uh your view on on this
uh in regards to specific numbers
requested at incidents no about making
public announcements I I think we've
heard some evidence that normally uh the
request for resources go from one Chief
to another uh from Chief to Chief yes
and is is not typical that public
announcements by politicians uh were
made
and you you shared your perspective on
this kind of Public Announcement so I'm
just hoping that you could Enlighten us
okay
um it's been my experience that when any
Municipal service requires our
assistance no matter what the incident
um the request needs to go from their
Chief to our commissioner the
commissioner's command team then reviews
the request and deploys the uh requested
resources
so to hear it come from a politician was
different from my experience
and after you became the critical
incident Commander did you take any
steps to
um
change the approach or any kind of media
strategy that that you that you adopted
um I
I respect the fact that any
um Council or Mar they can have their
own press conferences and release
information but I urge to Windsor Police
Service to work with the mayor's office
to make sure that our messages are
consistent
and was any further public announcements
made for resources after you assumed the
role of critical incident Commander not
that I'm aware of
now in this case the the announcement on
the ninth did not specify a particular
number how many officers were needed
um do you have any view on whether those
numbers should be made publicly uh in a
request
in my opinion I do not believe that they
should be made publicly why not
it jeopardizes uh perhaps the public and
police officer safety uh by letting the
public know the amount of officers that
are attending may lead to people
then bolstering their protests or
whatever that looks like if they know
the tactics or perhaps the amount of
officers that are attending an incident
okay
so let's go now to uh the next day
February 10th I understand that you had
an early morning call with Deputy
Harkins right correct and Deputy DeMarco
and and Deputy Demarco
um so tell us what was said uh in that
morning call
um they wanted to make sure that I had a
I had started implementing a team
putting a team in place and obviously I
had told them that I was on the road I
was heading to Windsor and they
indicated that whatever resources I
needed they would be provided
was anything said about Windsor being a
priority yes tell us about that yes
um they stressed to me that Windsor was
my priority and I needed to focus solely
on Windsor and that it was a priority
for the province did they explain why
Windsor was a priority no
um now if I could take you to page two
of the summary
so if we go to the third paragraph
near the middle of the paragraph do you
see the sentence that starts with during
a February 10th 8 30 a.m call
yes so it says Deputy Commissioners
Harkins and DeMarco again advise
superintendent early that Windsor was
the priority and that it was urgent to
resolve the blockade superintendent
early understood that the resolution was
urgent because the bridge closure was
having massive economic impacts
including job layoffs on Windsor Ontario
and Canada that a crowd of protesters at
the blockade was increasing in size and
that the public and officer safety risks
were escalating now you understood that
to be the case was that where did that
understanding come from
um it was part of the the conversation
but in regards to the increase in size
the economic impacts the risk to public
and officer safety that was from my
awareness from the teleconferences I had
been on and discussions with deputy
chief Crowley mm-hmm
so you had this call uh at 8 30 and I
believe at by 9 00 a.m you had your
mission statement written yes so we go
to the summary at page five
um
we accepted your mission statement I
believe from your notes thank you and it
reads the opp and our policing Partners
will keep the peace enforce legislation
establish and maintain the safe flow of
traffic and respecting individuals
Charter rights to Peaceful assembly and
freedom of speech with public and
officer safety being Paramount why was
the mission statement or the drafting of
a mission statement such a priority for
you
it is the well it's the goal of any team
member no matter what uniform you're
wearing your rank your role in in
regards to the team that is our goal
during the incident
and did this version of uh the statement
uh
continue to be the mission uh as events
unfolded yes so I understand that a plan
was finalized uh by the end of the day
on the 11th and the plan was implemented
on the 12th
um was this the same statement that
appeared in that ultimate plan yes how
did you come up with this plan how did
you draft it
uh based on the situation right that's
where your mission comes from and what
your goal is what you're trying to
resolve that's how your mission
statements come through and obviously as
a cic in the training that we receive we
mission statements and the importance of
them are discussed
and there are references to respecting
individuals Charter rights how did you
intend to do that absolutely well by
um obviously giving them the right
peaceful assembly and to honor their
freedom of speech we tried to do that
through Communications with our
provincial Liaisons team
so that was 9 A.M what time did you
arrive in Windsor
oh I think it was approximately 10 I had
to stop and pick up my scribe as well so
I think it was around 10 10 30. I can't
I'd have to refer to my notes and what
was the Scribe supposed to do when
you're the uh the critical incident
Commander so the Scribe is a very
important role
um she took all of my notes for me
so she captured the majority of
conversations and timings people's phone
numbers
why not so the the different volumes of
notes that we receive in disclosure
those were the scribes notes not your
notes that's correct okay
um so you went to Windsor and you met
with the command team from the Windsor
Police Service yes uh tell us about that
meeting what kind of reception did you
receive uh very welcoming um
because of the relationships I knew as I
said deputy chief at the time deputy
chief Blair as well as Inspector DeGraff
they then introduced me to other members
of their command post
obviously it was referred to as the EOC
here as well so I met everybody they
were very welcoming they appreciated the
support and the assistance and the
resources that the opp was providing
and they also welcomed the experience
that our organization has in regards to
Major prolonged events
was any decision made at that initial
meeting about how the WPS and the opp
would be working together certainly it
was right off the start it was a unified
command they ultimately respected that I
would have final say on a lot of the
plans because of the amount of resources
that we were bringing and that included
but everything before it was decided was
always referred to by both myself and
the cic from WPS
so um yesterday we heard from Deputy
Crowley I think he described
um the relationship as
I'm trying to look for his description
he described the integration as seamless
and he talked about how the opp and WPS
commands would at times be stepping
forward and back what you hear when he
testified
um I watched it you watched it um do you
agree with that description it was
seamless and we supported each other it
was a remarkable team effort and in your
interview with us at page three of your
summary uh you refer to this High degree
of trust and confidence tell us more
about that
as I mentioned
um Windsor Police respected the
experience and the skill set that the
opp was bringing to the table due to the
numerous events we've experienced as an
organization in regards to critical
incidents and protracted critical
incidents in particular and so with that
that's where the trust and the respect
came through but at the same time we
weren't able to do what we did if it
wasn't for the local knowledge and the
networks and the Partnerships that
Windsor Police already had in existence
now I think
Deputy Crowley referred to this command
structure as unified command and in your
interview with us you refer to it as
joint command are they the same thing
pretty much yes we've heard other terms
uh in Ottawa integrated command uh like
what's your understanding if there are
any differences between integrated joint
or Unified
uh really I think to explain ours
unified would
articulate it best okay
um
and in terms of the expertise that the
opp was bringing I think yesterday
Deputy Crowley refers specifically to
maybe planning and that specifically the
POU planning
um can you elaborate on that
yeah so when I arrived in Windsor I
requested subject matter expert in
regards to PLU planning inspector Jason
Noonan I contacted him and I requested
he attend to offer his expertise in
regards to a plan
sorry name again inspector Jason yoonan
okay
um well that's uh let's talk about the
the command team then because after you
arrive in Windsor I guess one of the
first things you did uh was to assemble
a command table yes
um and during our interview you said
that you wanted broad representation at
the command table
um and subject matter experts in all the
essential areas uh to ensure that those
areas are covered what are the major
areas that you you had to cover
uh those areas consisted of traffic
uh a crime
provincial Liaisons teams
media
and a logistics and resources in
addition to that we also were able to
set up a staging area so there was a
team that was in charge of the staging
area as well what about intelligence
absolutely yes intelligence as well and
how was Intelligence represented at this
command table they deployed a team
leader to sit in the Emergency
Operations Center with us and a team
member as well so they were constantly
feeding us any intel that they were
getting and I'd like to mention too all
those subject matter experts that I just
listed off there it wasn't just OPP but
Windsor had the same representation so
for example an Intel we had OPP Intel as
well as Windsor Intel in the command
post with us so you had subject matter
experts from both OPP and Windsor Police
Service represented at the table correct
and they included intelligence I think
you mentioned PLT yes
um Pou you mentioned inspector Union uh
who was responsible for Logistics
inspector Wendy burrow as from Opp as
well as Inspector Jen Crosby from
Windsor Police Service what about other
agencies such as the cbsa yes so cbsa
was included in the command post they
had a representative there a team leader
as well as the Windsor a fire had
representation and Windsor emergency
services so paramedics why was it
important for for these other agencies
to be included at the command table
uh all of those
um part everybody who had a part of our
Command Post
um provided us with different options
right and options are very much needed
in an incident like this so it's it's
important to create an environment
that's inclusive and communication is
key so that everybody could provide
ideas to resolve the situation
effectively
because the situation itself was very
Dynamic and fluid we wanted to make sure
that everything was covered if you think
about fire or EMS that they were in the
loop just in case we needed their
assistance which at times we did
I understand you also set up a system
where you had alternates so that you can
go to sleep yes
um who was your alternate
uh superintendent Derek Needham and was
there a similar system for the Windsor
incident command yes and who are those
two so inspector Carl DeGraff worked
days with me and then at night it was uh
deputy chief Crowley why is it important
to have these alternates
uh to go and rest your head for a little
bit and obviously just to provide some
relief
okay so so far we talked about the team
at the operational level the command
table that we just talked about I want
to ask you now about the relationship
between the operational level
functioning and the Strategic leadership
so on the Windsor side who was the
Strategic Commander
I believe you would have to confirm with
them but I saw that the deputy chief
Belair right and with the chief of the
Windsor Police Service also be at the
Strategic uh leadership level yes what
about the opp who were the Strategic
leaders
I for West Region superintendent Campisi
looked after that role but also would
have also included our chief chief thip
and then the opp command as well
Commissioners and Deputy Commissioners
so commissioner karik and Deputy Harkins
um now during the interview you spoke to
us about the importance for the
Strategic leadership to give the
operational commanders autonomy yes tell
us more about that yes
is required is very important because
decisions need to be made in a very
timely manner when dealing with critical
incidents so that's really highlights
the importance they also know and can
trust in the not only the experience the
team has but the training and the
subject matter experts the skill set
that they bring so that they know that
those decisions being made are the best
options for the situation what's
happening help us understand why is
autonomy connected to timeliness of
decision making
uh you need to make sure that a decision
is made the failure to make decision can
almost be just as bad as making an
improper decision
so that's why the timeliness is very
important right and these situations
things are happening minute by minute
you need to be able to make decisions
based on your awareness
and the cic has the best situational
awareness to make those decisions
why was it the cic who had the best
situational awareness you are in the
midst of it you have all the Intel
coming in you are there you have all the
feedback from your subject matter expert
so that's why you have the utmost
situational awareness during your time
in Windsor as the critical incident
Commander did you enjoy the kind of
autonomy that you expected from the
Strategic strategic leadership I did and
I appreciated it
um how was your relationship with the
Windsor strategic leadership
the same they respected it from their
command in the in the command post as
well as mine
did you experience any interference at
all improper interference with your
decision making
as the operational Commander no
what about the city of city of Windsor
or the mayor's office did you experience
what was your relationship with those
entities uh very little uh Windsor
Police dealt with them and liaised with
with the city okay
um Okay so we've now covered uh the the
command team and uh and the relationship
with the Strategic leadership
um
I want to talk to you now about
um
about the plan we talked a bit about the
plan and I understand that
you came to Windsor on the 10th
but by the end of the day on the 11th
you had a plan finalized and ready for
action am I right that's correct
um
how did that come about
the remarkable team that I had
um so with the mission that was set out
that everybody was very much aware of
the expectations were clearly explained
to the officers in the subject matter
experts in regards to what was needed
and that's how plans came together
now let's talk about the different
elements of that overall plan
um during the interview you mentioned
many sub plans yes and you said those
are necessary as part of the contingency
planning yes uh and they involve
um
areas like traffic Towing mass arrest
prisoner transport and some of the other
areas that we talked about intelligence
uh pot Pou and so on
um I want to ask you specifically about
three of those areas okay and I would
start I want to start by asking you
about the PLT element okay
um
so through the PLT
um planning
I understand that you came to learn
something about the protesters group
about the leadership as well as about
potential counter protest yes so let's
talk first about uh your understanding
of the leadership what did you learn
through the PLT planning
during those two days
through PLT that the protesters
themselves were described as just
disjointed they had different goals
um I it was explained to me that the PLT
was really dealing with three different
groups within the protesters and that
was causing
um concern as well as it was a challenge
for our PLT to develop Rapport to really
get anywhere because the groups
themselves were not agreeing
um I also learned from PLT of counter
protests as well and the concern for
that
so they had had discussions with an
Associate or a member from the auto
Union and he expressed his displeasure
with the protest and in fact was sharing
with them that he was going to take
matter into his own hands if it was not
resolved I was very grateful for the
Rapport in the relationship that PLT was
able to develop with him and through
that we asked for time for his patience
um if I could take you to your summary
um
because I wanted to ask you about that
incident okay if we go to page 11.
so this is uh you
you
talked about this incident involving the
the president of the
um local Auto Workers Union chapter
um
you see in the middle of the paragraph
Yes cot informed superintendent early
that David Cassidy the president of the
local Auto Workers Union chapter unifor
Loco 444 claimed that he had spoken to
Ontario Premier abduct for it and that
he was willing to bring Auto Workers to
the blockade site to forcibly clear out
protesters by Monday February the 14th
if police had not cleared the blockade
by that date
what kind of danger does this post
um to your team as you were planning for
action
the weekend
[Music]
concerning as a cic and it was just
other options now that I had to consider
that not only the protesters perhaps
would not like the plan of action but we
may have counter protesters attending as
well that would create significant
issues for public in officer safety
so was this an example of how you
Incorporated PLT in planning for
contingencies yes let me ask you now
about the POU planning
um so you mentioned earlier that
inspector Union was in charge of that
aspect yes and I understand that on
uh was it the 10th or the 11th that you
had a number of meetings with him and he
advised you
um so let's go to your summary maybe
that okay I suppose page six of your
summary
so you see that at 4 21 PM you had a
meeting with inspector Union
and he advised you that a mass removal
of protesters would be neither safe nor
sustainable tell us more about that
discussion
so uh this is after he had arrived in
Windsor he obviously had a time to deal
to meet with all the other team leaders
from the PLU teams and as well take a
look at the situation itself
he understood because it was such a long
area the three to four kilometers that
they had occupied that it would
um not be safe as he stated in my
summary to clear the entire area all at
once so with that he provided options to
clearing out different sections of the
protest area
and did you agree with his assessment I
did was this an example of how you as
the operational Commander defer to your
subject matter experts yes
um the third area I want to to ask you
about in terms of planning uh is the
involvement of the intelligence experts
yes was it your objective to have your
operation be intelligence LED
yes I mean intelligence does need to be
considered in regards to what's uh what
we're finding on open source or wherever
the intelligence is coming from and it
was important to hear also from both
teams so from the opp intelligence as
well as Windsor intelligence because of
the different networks that both teams
had they were providing us with a better
situational awareness so in terms of the
tools available to your team as I
understand it uh in addition to open
source which you mentioned you also was
getting some help from the U.S Partners
yes uh tell us about that that was uh
mainly through Windsor Police Service
because of the relationship they had
with
um Intel or Intel through the states
and in terms of other resources
available to you I understand that there
was a drone that was made available yes
as well as pull cameras from the cbsa
that's correct
and even a helicopter on the day of the
operation yes tell us about that
again just to provide current and
up-to-date operational or sorry
situational awareness so that we could
have an idea of exactly what was going
on in this very Dynamic situation
we've also heard yesterday about the
presence of children yes
um during the blockade and how did
Intelligence inform your planning about
this aspect
obviously that was a concern of mine
that if we had to use the plan of action
that I wanted to the lowest amount of
children to be there intelligence was
able to provide me with uh areas that
they had detected where the children
were
hanging out or were present in the
protest they were also able to tell me
that because of their intelligence
because of their OverWatch that the
majority of the children went home at
night and very little of them stayed
overnight and so that led me to
um obviously looking at the option of
going first thing in the morning with
any plan of operation if needed
was that the plan to to have the action
begin early in the morning yes and what
considerations LED you to that decision
uh knowing from Intel that they had not
observed any children overnight and that
when children were present it was
usually not till later in the day what
about the size of the crowd absolutely
so the and certain times of night so the
crowd as in my summary and I know deputy
chief Crowley spoke to it it would get
more unruly at certain times of night
um and so we had to consider that and
numbers were higher at certain times at
night but as it got colder and the later
it got in the evening a lot of people
did return home so by
um considering an early morning
operation that again would decrease
hopefully decrease the number of
protesters that we were dealing with
so we've now talked about the different
elements or subplans within the overall
plan turning our attention now to the
overall plan if we go to your summary at
Page Six
all right and we go down that's right to
the section approval of plans the second
paragraph
so on February the 11th superintendent
early also approved an overall
operational plan
titled operations plan Freedom Convoy
Windsor Ambassador Bridge the plan
stated that it contemplated an
escalation
in police response that is a considered
and measured approach
and that events associated with
Ambassador Bridge blockade convoys shall
be addressed at the lowest competent
level in an effort to affect a peaceful
resolution so earlier you mentioned in
the context of discussing the Frameworks
I think you you talked about the
measured approach the the use of pot to
engage and all of that
I want to ask you specifically
um
to to explain uh about this concept of
addressing events at the lowest
competent level uh in the context of a
kind of ladder or escalation what does
that mean the lowest competent level
the less invasive the less
um
so lowest competent level would be the
prime example would be our provincial
liaison team
you know being able to discuss the
removal or of protesters for them to
leave on their own would be ideal
so that's what you would try first
absolutely and then if that that did not
meet with success then you escalate yes
what would be the next letter or The
Next Step Up the Ladder I think uh
jointly along with PLT we are also using
a media strategy to make sure that we
were educating everybody in regards to
that it was unlawful to be there
um that there was other options that
they could express their freedom of
speech so there was the media attached
at the same time as provincial liaison
teams were trying to develop rapport
with the protesters
and then if that didn't work
so next steps we looked for different
options in regards to enforcement I I do
know that I had conversations with
Windsor about their bylaws there was a
number of different parking bylaws in
that area so we learned that the
protesters would park on side streets
and then attend the protest they're
parking on side streets were illegal so
their bylaw enforcement was then
deployed to the area so a number of
different tickets were given out to the
vehicles as well as some were towed so
that's just another level to let
protesters know that they aren't to be
there
what's the next step up
so again all of these steps are not
independent all of these things are
continuing so even as cars are being
towed by bylaw we're still trying to
have negotiations and develop rapport
with the protesters through PLT we're
still using so uh media to get that
message out uh The Next Step would be
enforcement
so we heard yesterday that even during
the um the enforcement phase attempts
were still being made to allow some
protesters to continue to protest
perhaps on the sidewalk outside the
exclusion Zone can you tell us more
about that
um so the the set area or the
operational area was certainly explained
through our social our media strategy
through the PLT that people needed to
remove be removed from there or remove
themselves and then other options
throughout the city are really available
any public area we have to keep in mind
though that
um there are private businesses as well
and they wouldn't welcome protesters so
we had to make sure that we educated
them in regards to that okay so by the
end of the day on February 11th
um I understand you approve this plan
that's correct and uh were you satisfied
that you received all of the necessary
Resources by then to implement the plan
the next day yes
and the plan then was to implement the
action on the early morning on the 12th
correct
um so I want to take you now to some
specific events uh that unfolded on the
11th while you were making these plans
okay
um I understand that sometime in the
afternoon while you were working on your
plan things were happening on the ground
and specifically there was a kind of
perceived breakthrough with the PLT team
right yes yes
uh tell us what happened
uh one of the protesters had approached
our provincial liaison team and stated
that if they had received a letter from
the government indicating that the
government was willing to meet with them
that they would leave
so PLT brought this to my attention
immediately I then asked for assistance
through my command team to see if this
letter
could see if the government would agree
to this and to see if this letter could
be produced so in our interview you
describe this as a kind of breakthrough
because this was the first substantial
request that the PLT team received from
the protesters yes it was very helpful
um so um if we go to your summary at
page 12
so the second paragraph at 4 25 PM
that's when you spoke to commissioner
karik about this request correct and
then by 5 29 PM a draft letter was
already approved that's correct that's
remarkably quick within hours yes
um what happened during those hours
um quite a bit of back and forth in
regards to uh just clarity as to what Mr
neufeld was asking
um and then of course it was the
commissioner's command team who assisted
in in getting the letter so quickly but
it certainly demonstrated that we were
trying our best uh to
um
you know to get the protesters what they
were asking for you were still
optimistic about the lowest competent
level yes yes so uh at 5 30 you engage
uh you you took part in a teleconference
yes with some of these strategic
leadership and you learn
that so if we go down further the page
so near the middle of that paragraph
starting at 5 30. you see the reference
to superintendent
alakis informed call participants that
PLT would be providing a letter to the
Ottawa protesters that was similar to
the letter from the provincial
government
to the Windsor protesters right
correct so um now um
superintendent Acting Superintendent
Bowden has testified at this hearing a
week or so earlier yes and uh he told us
perhaps the best way to summarize this
evidence is if I take you to his summary
okay
um
can we go to WTS
five six zero three seven please
so this is the interview summary of
Inspector Bowden okay
if we go to page four
go down
so you see that on February the 11th the
same day you were dealing with this
breakthrough in Windsor on February 11
2022 inspector Bowden met virtually with
Mr Stewart and Mr Hutchinson again the
plan at that point was to offer a
meeting in exchange for demonstration
leaders demanding that the trucks exit
downtown
Ottawa and denounce any criminal
activity
inspector Bowden then brief acting
deputy chief Ferguson who was in
agreement with the plan later that day
inspector Bowden also exchanged emails
with OPP superintendent alakis about the
actions being taken in Windsor and what
kind of reaction that might create among
the demonstrators in Ottawa so things
were happening in Ottawa and you were
dealing with
rapidly developing situations in Windsor
yes so going back to your summary this
call at 5 30 when you were informed by
alaka superintendent alakis about this
development in Ottawa remember the
middle of the paragraph Yes did
uh so what the evidence given by
inspector Bowden does that Accord with
your understanding on the 11th at around
5 30. yes
and then if we go down the page
um a series of meetings starting at
around 6 17 P.M
continuing uh to about if we go to the
next page
continuing to about 706 PM a series of
meetings between you and your command
team as well as between you and your
strategic leadership yes at the opp took
place
uh can you take us through those series
of meetings yes
um after the call at approximately 5 30
with super that included superintendent
lakis
um I made the decision that perhaps we
need to delay what was happening in
Windsor because the influencer could
have in Ottawa
um I then had conversations with the
Strategic commanders Deputy Commissioner
Harkins and commissioner karik and
learned that well they reminded me that
I did not need to act in my strategic
Commander role that I needed to focus on
Windsor and it was during that
conversation that they said are you
ready to go is your plan ready and do
you have the resources well you know
will the plan itself emphasize public
and officer safety I said yes to that
and then I changed my mind and decided
to continue with my plan realizing that
I didn't know the intimate knowledge of
what was going on in Ottawa because my
focus had to be Windsor right so going
back to your initial concern when you
um when you were reconsidering
implementing the plan the next day
um what implications did you think
um the action in Windsor may have in
Ottawa what were those concerns
that it might agitate things there
um and at the same time I had to again
my focus had to be on Windsor so if we
didn't go forward with the plan and
prolonged uh that allowing the
protesters to continue what would that
mean for Windsor and that was my
priority
and then after you spoke to your command
team you had this discussions with the
Strategic leadership and that included
uh commissioner karik right correct and
Deputy Commissioner Harkins yes and in
that discussion
um that discussion between the Strategic
leadership and your role as a as an
operational Commander help us understand
uh what was the Strategic input and how
that affected your decision ultimately
as the operational Commander it was a
reminder that I I did not have all the a
good situational awareness of what was
happening in Ottawa they did and that my
focus needed to be on Windsor and I
could tell them without a doubt that the
plan was ready the officers were ready
we had enough resources we had tried the
stepped approach and we were not getting
anywhere
um of course I was hopeful about the
letter because at this time it had not
been delivered yet but
any cic will tell you that you have your
plan your resources ready
one of the best options would be not to
deploy it because protesters left on
their own so I was still hopeful because
the letter hadn't been delivered yet
right so by 706 PM what was your final
decision
that we would be if needed if the letter
was not successful that we would be
launching the next morning our
operational plan now this is the
paragraph that you made the correction
when we began correct today's
examination and the correction you made
uh was to the effect that it was your
decision yes as opposed to a decision
made by the Strategic leadership correct
why is that important to you because all
those decisions moving forward in
regards to Windsor and the planet though
were all my decisions
okay so after this decision was made at
8 pm if we go down the page
at 8 pm
the letter that was previously approved
was now signed by Minister Jones and it
was distributed uh to the protesters
what effect if any did it have that
distribution of the letter
very little
very little it was disappointing
and uh
and and tell us about the like what was
going on by then uh with the protesters
well because of the time of day we we
had seen this throughout the week
um that was kind of the the heavier
times for numbers of people
um uh some sort of somewhat I would
describe as a party atmosphere was
happening
um from usually eight o'clock on during
the evenings and this was no different
so the the party atmosphere had
certainly began
um and uh again it was just very
disappointing that um the letter had
little effect although I appreciated all
the efforts getting the letter that
wasn't what you were hoping for no so
now was it time to escalate up the
letter yes okay so that takes us to the
uh to the end of the day on the 11th uh
my colleague uh Mr commissioner my
colleague Mr Miss uh header Ali will
continue the examination with the events
the following day okay thank you
is this a good time for the morning
break and we can come back at uh in 15
minutes it would be
okay so we'll take the morning break
come back in 15 minutes
thank you thank you
thank you sir the commission is in
recess for 15 minutes
order a lot
the commission is reconvened the
commission on April okay go ahead
good morning superintendent early good
morning my name is
Council and I will be asking you some
questions this morning great thank you
I'm going to continue where my colleague
left off on February 11th
um a lot of things happened that day
um on that day the Ontario supreme court
of justice also granted in injunction
prohibiting a blockade on the Ambassador
Bridge can you explain
um briefly uh how you use this
injunction and if you found it helpful
in clearing the blockade
the injunction was another tool that
could be considered by myself and my
team we also made sure that the
injunction was included in the media
strategy so that everyone was aware that
it existed
and um so that's how it was used I saw
it as a tool
I'd like to pull up your notes please at
OPP for zeros 45 51.
foreign
if we go down to page nine
there is a note at 4 58 pm
that says protesters are getting ready
to leave now that injunction stands
Intel from crowd
what was the source of this intelligence
that was coming from some of the
officers from the front line as well as
perhaps the and I can't recall exactly
but it was being discussed amongst the
crowd
and so it says that protesters are
getting ready to leave did some leave
because of the injunction uh very little
if any at all I can't recall
on February 11th there was also a
province-wide emergency declared by
Premier Ford under the Emergency
Management and civil protection act
um how did that impact the blockade
uh again we used it as part of our media
strategy we made sure that people were
aware uh that what it meant to them if
you were protesting we actually um did
up information pamphlets for the crowd
that explained uh some of the
consequences of the act and had
provincial liaison teams distribute
those
but again some did leave as a result
others did not
did you find that one of these two tools
the emergency measures or the injunction
were was more or less useful than the
other that they work in conjunction can
you just explain a little more I would
say they worked in conjunction and as
I've mentioned several times the the
situation being so Dynamic that a lot of
options
um are useful and so I saw both of them
as tools as options for us
great um so we talked a little bit
earlier about our resources that were
necessary for the plan to be implemented
on the 12th yes
um one of the the things that the plan
required is uh to win capacity yes
correct
um so where did you obtain tow trucks
uh so Towing was included in our traffic
plan and knowing that we may have to
have a an operation an action of
operation and remove vehicles that
obviously had to be considered Windsor
Police Service has a contract with a
local towing company who made their tow
trucks available
and also because we weren't sure the
exact numbers of what would need to be
towed we had the option of tow trucks
come in from Detroit
so first for the local company that the
Windsor Police Service had a contract
with was there any issues with their
willingness to assist uh in the context
of the protests no there was not
and as for the tow trucks um that came
from uh Detroit
I'd like to pull up WPS five
zeros1090 please
this is an email from Chief minuzo to
deputy chief Belair
um that forwards an email from the
Michigan Government
um in there we see that the
Mish that Michigan doesn't have state
resources to offer but are willing to
put
the Windsor Police Service in touch with
private contractors and as you can see
um Chief minuzu says they have no
Machinery or tow trucks to offer please
let the team know there is no assistance
in tow trucks or Machinery from the US
were you made aware of the fact that the
state didn't have
tow trucks to offer not that specific
detail but I do know that
um the inspector in charge of the
traffic and towing plan had made
connections with
perhaps the contractors that they
mentioned
um to arrange for tow trucks to be on
standby
and when did you obtain the tow trucks
from Michigan they came I believe they
came the morning of the 12th
and I I understand that they weren't
used in the end correct when did they
leave
that day
um I understand that the blockade was
only cleared on the following day that's
correct uh why were the trucks sent back
to the U.S uh if the blockade wasn't
cleared yet
the um the area that we were able to
clear on 12th
um
was significant was more than we
anticipated and so the area that we
needed to continue to clear on the 13th
did not have a large amount of vehicles
so we were confident that the tow
company from Windsor would be able to
support what we needed
as for other resources that were
required I understand that you also
arranged for Road barriers to hold areas
that were cleared that's correct what
did you get to use as Road barriers what
kind of resources uh Windsor Police were
able to use their obviously the
connections with the city to use large
trucks and as well they had a certain
amount of cement berries that were
available to them and then we worked
through our partnership with MTO
to work with one of their contractors to
bring in more cement barriers
were there any issues in securing any of
these resources
uh no
so we also talked earlier about the
officers that you needed to carry out
the plan I understand there were
Frontline officers pous
Etc I understand that you also had RCMP
Pou officers correct
do you know how many RCMP officers were
deployed in Windsor
I'd have to refer to my notes but I
believe it was a Pou team consisting of
approximately 40 and then an additional
they send their emergency response teams
with their Pou so I think there was an
additional 10 there then we also had
assistance from the um RCMP officers
that assisted on the front line as well
do you know where the RCMP officers came
from
uh no I I did meet some of them and they
were from all over really
um I'd like to pull up
doj.ir.6011 please
at page 55
.250 if we scroll down a little bit
um there's a note that on February 10th
the winter Police Service contacted the
minister of Public Safety the icmp
assistant with respect to the Ambassador
Bridge
slow down a bit for the translators
please
that same day the RCMP deployed a tsg
that was deployed in Ottawa to Windsor I
understand that the tsg is a tactical
support group
to your knowledge is that the unit that
came to Windsor I'm not sure I couldn't
comment on that
oh we can pull that on Mr clerk thank
you
I understand that OPP also deployed a
PLT correct members to Windsor one of
the recommendations that you made in
your witness summary is that there
should be a PLT unit in the Windsor
Police Service and PLT training should
be provided to Windsor police officers
could you please expand on why you made
that recommendation
the effort and the achievements of our
provincial liaison team not only in
Windsor but any incident that they
attend is remarkable the community as
well as organization we have a
responsibility to to try to develop that
Rapport in incidents where we don't see
eye to eye just so that everybody can be
heard and the provincial liaison team
allows that to happen within our
different groups within our societies
and our communities so that's why I
would urge that any really Police
Service have some sort of team that
allows for that Rapport and that
communication piece
would you make a similar recommendation
regarding
um
Pou training that all Municipal forces
perhaps should have
that sort of training I think depending
on where the municipal service is and
any key infrastructures that may be
targeted that has to be consideration
and if in fact they can't have a team
perhaps they need to have some sort of
memorandum of understanding with another
service that could facilitate a Pou unit
for them if needed
so you mentioned earlier today to my
colleague that by the end of February 11
you had all the resources that you
needed correct in your plan
um and that you implemented it on the
morning of February 12th
um I understand that one of the reasons
that it started early in the morning
um is that there would be fewer
protesters and not no children were
likely to be present according to
intelligence correct
did you have a contingency plan in in
place in case there were indeed children
present yes we did so we had a vehicle
set aside that would transport children
from the scene we also worked with the
local Children's Aid Society for
assistance and as well Windsor kind of
spearheaded this but they had their
victim Response Unit in attendance to
support any children that may be present
and so while we're on the contingency
plan can you explain
um the importance of having those kinds
of plans in place and how you decide
what to prepare for as contingencies
so um as I've discussed before all you
need to have as many options as possible
especially in an incident like this and
so once you learn of or once you have
developed that situational awareness and
some of the challenges that you may be
faced with during the incident you need
to make sure that your options are
covered for each one so for example you
mentioned traffic well that includes
Towing as well and so did the PLU plan
knowing that children were present at
different times of the day during this
protest that was an obvious thing for me
to make sure that it was addressed
so uh
well in the morning of February 12th you
start implementing the plan correct
please explain how how the plan was
carried out
we had a very early morning briefing
which included every team member that
was going to be involved
so that would be all of our Pou
contingent as well as the front line
officers as well as the admin support
the plan was explained to everyone I
addressed everyone and thanked them for
their support and efforts
um it was shortly after that that we
then staged at the areas that were set
out in the plan
before the plan was to move forward PLT
was to again address the crowd and let
them know that
um with Pou standing behind them let
them know that Pou would be trying
attempting to clear the area and giving
them another opportunity to leave the
area on their own
another important part of the plan is
that we always left an area open so that
if somebody wanted to leave the
operational area while PLU was present
they could do so on their own
I'd like to pull up
com50926 please Mr Clerk
this is a map of Windsor and I will
maybe help explain the claiming by
phases that we briefly alluded to
earlier okay I have to explain
more visually how it happened yes
so you explained earlier today that the
plan was to clear the protesters in
phases
um because the area was perhaps too
large to do it all at once yes can you
explain a little further the what the
phases were and how they were carried
out
um it's a bit difficult to see the side
roads okay uh so
right in behind the McDonald's is
obviously where the the bridge is so we
wanted to go from the bridge to um the
intersection to the train tracks so
there's train tracks right in front of
the entrance to the bridge that was a
certain area
we then wanted to move from the the
tracks itself to the intersection at the
McDonald's there since that's a clear
point
um that would be another section and
then ultimately make our way down to
Tecumseh Road so that it was basically
um put into three different sections
those were determined by the POU plan
and the PLU team leaders in regards to
what would be most effective
and obviously I respected and and
trusted their subject matter expertise
and I understand that after each area
was cleared you would use the resources
that we discussed earlier to block
passage correct so we would use a
mixture of the larger trucks the cement
barriers and officers as well
then once the whole area was cleared
after the three phases were completed
that brought us to February 13th yes
and that's when the traffic plan came
into place that
is that right correct
can you explain a little more what the
traffic traffic plan or then uh in
itself entailed yes so the traffic plan
was to I as I said to my team that day
it's one thing to open the bridge it's
another thing to keep it open so the
traffic plan the traffic and towing plan
addressed maintaining the safe flow of
traffic to and from the United States so
the traffic plan Incorporated the cement
barriers that we discussed in blocking
all the
intersections and I won't say all but
most of the intersections down here on
church to ensure that we did not have
protesters coming from the side streets
onto the road again and taking it back
the infrastructure of Windsor is a huge
challenge when it comes to the entrance
of the bridge and that's why the need
for all the resources that were required
in regards to the cement barriers
this traffic plan also had marked areas
that intersections were
were attended by officers rather than
cement barriers for safety reasons for
EMS and fire to make sure that they
could get through and then also too we
incorporated two different areas for
pedestrian traffic as well
we're local residents able to cross
Huron church at any point in with their
personal vehicles yes uh no they weren't
at certain times but at the um towards
the end towards EC Row in that area they
were able to cross into the other side
of the city
again another big part of the traffic
plan was the media strategy so we made
sure that we communicated this to the
the community
um at every step of the way what it
looked like what the alternate routes
were to the different businesses to the
different areas the city we made sure
that all of those were set up as well
and Windsor Police had obviously a big
hand in that working with the Rhodes
Department
um this is I think what deputy chief
Crowley yesterday referred to as an area
of control yes and I think you referred
to it in your interview as an exclusions
loan yes
under which um Authority did you create
the exclusion Zone
we relied on um the criminal code uh
really for keeping people out of the
area
we had specific tasks for the officers
that were assigned to the traffic plan
to investigate anybody who may be appear
suspicious or who may stop in the
exclusion zone so it was clearly
communicated to the community Through
MTO signs through social media that if
you were going to be on heroin Church
you're going to the bridge
and I understand that there were RCMP
Frontline resources that arrived as you
mentioned a little earlier yes and I
also understand that there was a delay
in swearing them in yes if it ever
happened at all I don't think it did
happen
and uh why was it necessary to swear in
these officers
um or what would it have been useful
Well they um they would be able to
address anything under the criminal code
but anything under provincial or
Municipal legislation they would not be
able to address and since they were
being deployed to assist the front line
we needed them to make we needed them to
have those options so what we did
instead because of the delay is that we
made sure that they were partnered with
another Police Service so OPP or Windsor
that did have those abilities
and it's one of the recommendations that
you also made in your uh in your
interview that the process for granting
RCMP officers uh provincial and
municipal authorities be streamlined yes
what was the difficulty in getting them
sworn in
I don't think there is really clear
direction as to who had to do it when
did it have to be done could it be done
remotely did it have to be done with
them in person so there was a lot of
phone calls back and forth with myself
along with Windsor Police Service at a
time where really we should have just
been left alone to focus on the incident
itself
so that's what I mean by more
streamlined before our CMP officers
arrive to assist
and does it cause any delay that you had
to change your plan to pair RCMP
officers with OPP or Windsor Police
Service officers no we just look for a
different option because obviously we
needed them on the front line so that's
what we did instead
and so if we
go to the next day on February 14th the
emergencies Act was invoked by the
federal government yes
in your view did it have any impact on
the situation in Windsor
I well things were much different then
because the traffic was flowing and um
it's hard for to say if it had any
difference but I I do know that
um
again it was communicated through our
our media strategy that people were
aware of the additional act being
legislated and what it meant to them and
the definition that of certain things
obviously a bridge that fell with under
the ACT yet yesterday deputy chief
Crowley mentioned that it may have been
dissuesive to the protesters I had to
come back would you agree
um I agree again it was another tool
that we were able to use
was there
um a clear plan that you were aware of
that the protesters wanted to be
blockade the Ambassador Bridge after it
was
cleared on the 12th and the 13th uh yes
we continued to observe and receive in
intelligence that indicated I think it
was on the date of and I know what's in
my notes on the date of the 15th through
the 16th there was a Facebook posting
that was called take back the bridge
and it was um Associated to all the
things that had were then transpiring in
Ottawa and basically the posts were
saying you know everybody's all the
police are gone to Ottawa so let's take
back the bridge that's something that we
watched very closely
also Windsor Police had had a group of
protesters on a regular basis and I
think deputy chief Crowley spoke to that
that would meet during
um
the convoys on a regular basis so we
maintained kind of
Intelligence on you know what will that
group bring um but certainly there was
the fear that they would think that
numbers were being deployed to Ottawa
and then try to take advantage of that
and take back the bridge
I take your notes and I can put them up
that would be helpful also mentioned
that once the injunction is expired they
are looking to block it again yes was
that also a consideration that the
injunction was uh going to to expire yes
there was Intelligence that indicated
that that's what they were considering
so did you think that the renewal of the
junction on February 18th was helpful
um in preventing that uh well to to
those who um yeah we're going to try to
take it back after it expired yes
so as of February 20th I understand that
you adopted a demobilization plan
correct what is the demobilization plan
uh it was a plan to obviously demobilize
our resources uh not only for officers
but just kind of to give the incident
entirely to Windsor Police Service as
soon as they could kind of sustain it
themselves also keeping in mind and
respecting the fact of that they had
calls for service they had a city to
place as well so we did it in a staged
approach it also included demobilizing
certain areas of the traffic plan so on
a daily basis sometimes on a you know an
hourly basis we would monitor the
traffic flow along with the intelligence
along with the reports from our
provincial liaison team and what the
front line was seeing to see if there
was areas we could perhaps remove some
of the barriers so we evaluated that
constantly and opened intersections a
point at a time you can see in the
demobilization plan that we actually had
some dates set out for each intersection
to be considered some of those those
dates were were met other dates were
actually opened intersections earlier
than we anticipated maybe for the record
we could put it up that's wps600719
I believe at page four
perhaps go down a little bit
[Music]
is this what you were referring to
that's correct
so I see that the latest potential
reopening date is March 13th yes
why would it take
um about three weeks to clear
all the intersections
um we that was uh sort of kind of a
review of based on the information we
had when the plan was created those two
the last two intersections were the
heavier intersections in regards to
protests and those are the two that are
obviously closest to the bridge entrance
so that's why they were kind of put till
the end to see how the community as well
as the Intel and all of that what we're
receiving to see how the other
intersections were being cleared was it
being received well did we have any
other threat of a protest so that's why
it was kind of spanned along that that
amount of time
do you know when they were ultimately we
opened the last intersection
um I don't sorry I understand you
stopped being critical incident
commander in Windsor on February 23rd
that's correct how was the transition of
command from yourself to the Windsor
Police Service again it was it was
seamless and I we worked every day every
night side by side so really uh it was
seamless when we left we just wanted to
make sure that Windsor had the proper
amount of resources to be able to deal
with anything if it should occur and of
course
some of our officers remain there until
the end of the month into February
foreign
I'd like to take you back to another of
your recommendations before we end you
mentioned that the critical incident
command Commander should visit Frontline
officers and ask them what they need I
understand that that's something that
you did I did yes yes is this uncommon
um I think that every incident command
critical incident Commander attempts to
go on ground it's just because of again
the dynamic situation it's not always
easy to do so once I had an opportunity
I did make a point of visiting the
different checkpoints to check on the
wellness of our members and when I say
our members I mean any police officer
that was out there I also asked them for
their input if there's anything else
that we needed to get done or that we
could do better it was from one of those
visits that the interactive
um Post in regards to the traffic plan
and updating on a regular basis it came
from a Frontline officer saying you know
I'm dealing with a local resident who
wasn't sure where the crosswalks were so
could we post it and keep it up to date
so I took that right back to the command
post and made sure that that was done
right away so that a member of the
public at any time just could click on
the link and know where to cross the
road so it's those things
um as well and most importantly it's
it's uh it's a way to thank them for
their efforts considering that a lot of
them had been away from home for quite
some time and know that their efforts
were having an impact
and this is the last document that I'll
take you to today um if we could please
put up OPP four zeros four five five two
at page 26.
those are the Scribe notes
from February 13th
at 12 17 so we can scroll down a little
bit
um commissioner karik thanked you for
having performed to Perfection on both
stage
um
what for you made the Windsor operation
such a success
the team absolutely the team
it was a remarkable collaboration and
cooperation it didn't matter what
uniform you were wearing what rank you
were what role you had it was a
tremendous effort by a remarkable team
is there anything else that you would
like to say to the commission that we
haven't asked you this morning I don't
think so at this point Thank you those
are my questions for you superintendent
thank you very much thank you
okay thank you very much
thank you so I'd like to uh first call
on the government of Canada
if you have any questions
thank you uh commissioner
good morning superintendent good morning
my name is Andrea Gonzales and I'm one
of the lawyers representing the
government of Canada in this inquiry
um
I just want to begin by going back to
the information you've received I guess
it was late you had many late nights
late late night on February uh 9th
um as to the state of play in Windsor
when you were
um assigned the role of critical
incident Commander
um and uh
in response to questions from commission
Council you'll recall that he pulled up
the bullet point email that you sent to
the two deputies yes
um and uh one of the concerns that was
raised with you early on I gather
um was the Dynamics of the crowd that
was engaged in the protest activity
right yes
um under your direction PLT teams became
engaged
um early on trying to identify leaders
right yes uh but as you understood from
the PLT teams the protesters were
disjointed and disorganized I think were
your words right yes correct
um and uh in this kind of a situation
police don't know whether the group will
even listen to someone who puts
themselves forward as a leader right
that's correct especially in this
instance because we nobody was really
being identified as a leader
right and there was um I understand you
spoke about the three groups there was
some infighting among them yes
um and the demands of the group
um to the extent they were even known
were were problematic yes right I think
I saw in your notes um of February 10th
at OPP four zeros four five four three
uh that the protesters had no desire to
leave and wanted to remain until all
restrictions were lifted that was your
understanding yes
um
your bullet point note to the deputy
Chiefs also talked about the crowd uh
being agitated and that was true at
various times through the protest right
that's correct
um in your notes again February 10th I
saw that you described a Wilder crowd
arriving at night yes that's when the
drinking and the pot smoking would begin
yes yes and inspector Union described it
uh the crowd Dynamics as being violent
you remember that yes
um
we heard evidence from uh deputy chief
Crawley yesterday but I just want to
confirm you were also aware from the
briefings you received that there had
been threats to surround and storm
police station yes as well as the tunnel
The Tunnel right
officers were swarmed when they tried to
arrest the individual whose car jumped
the curb that's correct
uh there had been threats when attempts
were made to tow two vehicles prior to
your arrival yes
uh you heard about a possible protest at
the Windsor Airport
that I did not okay
um you heard about a smoke bomb that was
set off by demonstrators at one point
yes
um and a bit later on in the piece but
there was a bomb threat called in
um about a bomb that was behind the
police lines is that correct that's
correct
there had also been threats made to the
mayor his address was posted online you
knew about that yes I was aware and this
was all um you would uh accurately say
or you'd say was accurately described as
a volatile situation yes
there then you throw into the mix the
presence of children right correct one
of your biggest concerns throughout the
piece yes
um and I take it that the concern about
the presence of children was
um based on what officers were seeing
actually happening on the ground at the
protest site right that's correct not
just information being collected online
no we were we were witnessing it you
were witnessing it yesterday
um in questions to deputy chief Crawley
um one of the council for one of the
parties pulled up a situation report
that was dated oh 400 hours that
indicated no children were observed on
scene that was oh 400 hours on February
12th can you explain how that reconciles
if it does with the information you
received of children on site
so um it was always very apparent the
children on site were at certain times
in the day and that they were not
staying overnight so the um information
at zero four hundred the children were
not present did not surprise me because
information before revealed that the
children were going home at night and
not returning until uh sometimes 9 10
a.m okay
um you also spoke uh you testified in
response to questions from commission
Council about the
increased risk of counter protests yes
right
um and the
um president of the uh Auto Workers
Association who understandably they were
quite upset by the ongoing blockade of
the bridge
um do you recall uh the words that he
used when he indicated that they wanted
to come and counter protest
I believe and I think it was recorded in
my notes um
something indicating that they were
going to knock heads or use a vehicle to
push people into the river yeah that was
on February 11th OPP four zeros4550 page
21 he said that they intend to come on
Monday with 1 000 people to crackheads
or bring heavy equipment and push them
in the river
um
that's pretty concerning as the critical
incident Commander correct yes
and as time we're on local residents are
becoming more vocal
um in their opposition to the protest
um I understand you were briefed at one
point on counter protesters intending to
damage protest Vehicles yes all that
um
you spoke about the injunction
that was ordered by Chief Justice
morowitz of the Ontario superior court
on February 11th and I understand your
view is that although this was one of
the tools available it was not
particularly useful
I did not see a significant change in
the incident
um similarly the February 11th
provincial
Declaration of a state of emergency I
understand from your notes uh that a few
protesters may have left but it also
caused others to dig their heels in
right that's correct
and then the third piece that happens on
February
11th is the letter from the um solicitor
general to commissioner karique that was
distributed to protesters
um and I just want to confirm you
testified in response to commission
council's questions that you had been
made aware of a similar letter that
would be handed out to protesters in
Ottawa you recall that evidence yes
did you understand who that letter would
be coming from
the one in Ottawa yes no I do not I do
not know and that's because your focus
of course was Windsor was Windsor yes
um and that letter uh from the solicitor
general does ultimately get handed out
um two protesters at the blockade site
in Windsor yes
um and it had no effect either they
refused to leave right yes
disappointingly but
um that really proved to be the the
the end point to possible engagement it
had been tried and it had failed right
sorry we just needed yeah sorry thank
you
and there was a lot going on across the
province at the time
um that you were
dealing with the situation in Windsor a
lot of protest activity Fair yes
um we know that the winds are
police response involved units not only
from Opp and Windsor Police but you also
spoke about uh London Hamilton
Waterloo I think correct yeah
um perhaps some other Municipal Police
Services or does that cover it I believe
that covers it
um and you were told that Windsor was
your priority right yes
um but you were certainly well aware
that there were ongoing unexpected
demonstrations and blockades across the
province right yes I was aware
um
I saw through your notes this reference
to a ripple effect
am I understanding as superintendent
that you saw the convoys and the
blockades in the various locations as
being connected in the sense that they
couldn't be managed or approached in
isolation from a policing perspective
certainly all of them had to be
considered I think I'll go back to the
example of
the Facebook page that I mentioned to
take back the bridge it was obvious that
people were monitoring what police
activity was and then making plans
according to that
and you um were aware or certainly alive
to the concern that what happened at one
site
could well have impacts at others
correct right
um
now after the 11th
everything fair to say had been tried
and the time had come for the
um operational plan to be implemented
right yes
uh
and It ultimately succeeds
um in fully clearing that blockade on
Sunday the 13th right correct
um the the vehicles were towed one thing
I didn't hear come out in your evidence
in Chief but I saw in your notes
opp404544 at page 14.
um that bomb threats had been made to
the tow operator that was Am Pm towing
is that right yes Windsor Police Service
was dealing with that because it was
their jurisdiction but I was aware that
the towing company had received threats
uh both internally so on their phone and
also to that a number of people had
called continuously to this the business
and in so basically their phone service
wasn't available because people kept
tying up the lines
um And in regards to tow trucks when the
others were staged from the states we
also received information that people
were going to protesters were going to
go and block the area where we had them
staged so that we potentially were not
able to use them so I had to assign
additional officers to that area okay
um
it's fair for me to say that even after
the operation had successfully cleared
the blockade
you were deeply concerned
about maintaining that road clear right
yes
that was your single biggest concern in
fact was maintaining the hold somewhat
precarious hold on Huron Church Road yes
um and I saw in your notes perhaps we
could turn them up uh
opp40s four five five six at page uh
stamped page 16 but I think in the
electronic document it would be page 17.
um yep right there is good and I see
fourth line down now we have to maintain
it may have Groundhog Day could be
Groundhog Day have to be on high alert
what did you mean by it could be
Groundhog Day they could attempt again
um they had obviously proven to the
world at this time that they were able
to block it so that they knew it was
achievable
um and this ongoing risk that the
protesters would return and resume the
blockade
um I take it that your concern was
informed not only by what you saw in uh
Windsor but your experience with these
ongoing Slow Roll protests even going
back to January yes
um and as the uh Pou operation loomed in
Ottawa
uh you made clear that you couldn't
spare resources from Windsor to assist
with that right I made it clear that I
needed a contingent of Pou officers
still available
um and in fact after the blockade was
cleared on the 13th and the bridge
reopened on the 14th I understand there
were threats to block the tunnel those
threats came in very shortly after the
bridge was cleared yes
um you mentioned uh the 15th there was a
convoy of vehicles believed to have been
traveling to Windsor that was
intercepted yes
um on the 16th if we could pull up
opp50s209
and scroll down please just pausing
there
um your this is an email dated February
16th and we see your name there
superintendent yes okay keep scrolling
down
um and this is an email communicating to
you and others the most recent updated
PLT messaging that incorporates both the
federal and provincial emergency orders
you recall receiving that
I received a lot of emails but um yes
but you're aware in any event of um the
needing to get out PLT messaging of the
two emergency the two levels of
emergency orders right including what we
see in the first paragraph in Black
persons traveling to any other unlawful
protest sites to participate in or
support the unlawful demonstration can
be charged and that is the PLT messaging
being put out to deter protesters from
going to sites where blockades might be
resumed or renewed yes yes and providing
them the education of what could happen
right uh what the consequences are
exactly so um you also mentioned
um uh the Facebook chat about protesters
heading back to Ambassador Bridge as
um the enforcement action was taking
place in Ottawa yes
um let's just pull up OPP four zeros
4558
I've come to learn this as what we call
fast facts yes
um and this is uh Pages 92 and 93. let's
just start at 92.
um
scroll down please
a little bit more
there we go the bullet point towards the
bottom of the page private chat on
Facebook by Group by the name of Windsor
Convoy for freedom
quote all police are in Ottawa so let's
take the bridge back yes that was a
concern there's another one on the next
page I don't have to um
take you there
and of course superintendent you
um testified before about the uh concern
of the presented by counter protesters
the volatility if we have these two
sides colliding right yes and that
concern also would have Arisen if yet
another blockade popped up in Windsor uh
after it had been cleared right
absolutely
thank you
and it's because of these concerns that
you planned for the gradual rather than
the sort of immediate demobilization in
Windsor right that's correct
um in fact oppos were not removed from
Windsor until February 24th as I
understand it yes and that's you
understand that's after the federal
government had revoked the invocation of
the emergencies act yes
um and uh the we saw in your response to
questions from commission Council uh the
last intersection was planned to reopen
on March 13th on your advice yes
um and I understand from deputy chief
Crowley that
um WPS maintained a perimeter as late as
March 28th
you understand that or you say I weren't
sure yeah I wasn't there but I did hear
it in his testimony
and given all of the
um
concerns and the economic impact of that
bridge being closed down not only in
Windsor but in the entire region you
understood that it would be
appropriately prudent and cautious
um to to keep these measures in place
long after it had been cleared
correct again it was another tool that
we could refer to if we had issues
because when that blockade was cleared
on the 13th or the 14th you just had no
idea whether it would fall into the
hands of protesters again right exactly
thank you those are my questions thank
you
thank you
next citizens for freedom
jccf
good morning superintendent good morning
my name is Alan honner I'm a lawyer with
the Democracy fund and we share standing
with the jccf and citizens for freedom
a superintendent early
since this inquiries started we've heard
evidence about the importance of police
Independence and about how politicians
should not interfere with that
Independence
you will agree with me that police
autonomy is very important
yes and can we pull up SSM
.can
.nsc
dot four zeros
2845
and superintendent you will not have
seen this document before
but it's a readout of a conversation
between the Prime Minister and the
premier of Ontario on February 10th
I just want to take you to parts of that
document and then um ask you a question
about it
so can we scroll down just a little bit
a little bit more
so if we uh if if we look at this
document now the premier and the Prime
Minister are saying hello and in the
first big paragraph Premier Ford says
bigger one for us
and the country is the Ambassador Bridge
and the state ground there
what I think is we gotta stop the spread
of these protests
and he goes on to say that the Attorney
General is looking at legal ways to give
the police more tools do you see that
yes okay and in the next paragraph if we
can just scroll down a little bit
the Prime Minister says first of all
they're not a legal protest
they're occupying a municipal Street and
are not legally parked you shouldn't
need more tools legal tools
they are barricading the Ontario economy
and then later in that paragraph he says
we gotta respond quickly
and if I can take you to the next page
about halfway through
foreign
on the screen the third paragraph from
the bottom
uh the Prime Minister asks has Windsor
asked anything of the opp
have they made a formal request
and if if you look at the premier's
response he says
they've put that request in through the
solicitor general
I spoke to the mayor and that was the
plan
you see that
yes and can we go to the top of the
third page
and so we see the prime minister is
asking what are the next steps
and Premier Ford says
they allowed but without directing them
it's hard to describe their game plan
they'll have a plan unlike Ottawa
uh
where they didn't have a plan
I'll get brief tomorrow from the
solicitor general and we'll keep you
updated this is critical I hear you I'll
be up their ass with a wire brush
now superintendent the question I wanted
to put to you
is and I just want to be clear you did
not experience any political
interference from anyone when you're
carrying out your duties as the critical
incident Commander no I did not and do
you know of anyone else in the Ops sorry
the the opp the WPS or any other police
force
uh who experienced inappropriate
political pressure not that I'm aware of
okay thank you very much
I'd like to just uh switch gears for a
moment here I you told us earlier today
about a conversation telephone
conversation you had
with
um
I believe it was Deputy Commissioners
Harkins and Demarco
and that was on February the 10th and
you told us today that they told you
that Windsor was your priority and that
it was a priority yes and when I read
your witness statement I saw you said
that you described it as a priority but
you also described it in a different way
I won't take you there but
um what do you say in that statement is
that they told you that Windsor was the
priority
does that sound right to you
I I knew it was stressed on me that it
was a priority
and was it the the priority as opposed
to a priority
I all I can speak to is I knew it was my
priority but you would agree with me
that it was a very important priority
regardless of whether it was the most
important yes
and given the economic impact of the
Ambassador Bridge
um
it was it was possibly uh not just one
of the most important priorities for
Ontario but also for the country
perhaps but there is a lot of other
issues that we had to consider right but
we saw from from uh the the conversation
between Doug Ford and prime minister
Trudeau that at least for uh Doug Ford
it appears that Windsor is the priority
well I can't speak to that I wasn't
involved in no but you you've seen the
document that's what it looks like when
he says for us I'll just remind you of
the language here it says the bigger one
for us and the country is the Ambassador
Bridge I can't speak to what he was
thinking okay fair enough
uh superintendent early
um
you can tell me though
uh
that and you know to the to the credit
of you and your team
that you managed to get this blockade at
The Ambassador Bridge cleared within two
days of your appointment
um
as cic
yes
and you would agree with me then that
you and your team managed to resolve one
of the most urgent priorities in the
country without the benefit of the
emergencies Act
correct
thank you earlier today you spoke about
sport swearing in our CMP officers yes I
think your evidence was that the POU
officers did not to be need to be sworn
in because they were enforcing the
criminal code
um but front line officers would be
enforcing Municipal laws and provincial
laws possibly possibly and so you you
sort of creatively solved this problem
by pairing them up with OPP officers and
Windsor Police and Windsor Police yes
and and I just don't understand this
language is wondering if you can explain
it a little bit better
what additional power would that confer
on the RCMP or what benefit would that
can confer to Paramount like that in
regards to having them sworn in
right I mean does would this allow the
RCMP for example to enforce provincial
laws or yes it would thank you
and we heard today that you established
an exclusion Zone along Huron Church
Road and I believe we heard yesterday
that exclusion Zone was north of
Tecumseh
to the Ambassador Bridge does that sound
right yes
and that's the distance of about one
kilometer I believe it's more than that
I think it's about three
okay and when you gave us evidence to
say you said you relied upon the
criminal code to establish that
exclusion Zone yes
do you agree that you could have also
relied upon the Emergency Management and
civil protection act
to establish that exclusion Zone yes
thank you
um my friend from the uh the the
government of Canada asked you questions
today uh about threats that were um
present in Windsor
you but you told us today that you've
read the hand in reports yes insofar as
they concerned uh the municipalities
under your care yes
and uh you would agree with me that in
Windsor there was no extremist rhetoric
um that I can't speak to but it was in
the hand in reports you would agree with
it
yes I mean it was Windsor's
responsibility to be reviewing the
hennan reports in regards to activity in
their area okay well it's it's
opp401688 I won't bring it up uh let me
just move on
um can we pull up OPP four zeros
3038
can you tell us who Karen Johnson was or
is
well the document I'm just just asking
while we're waiting okay um no I I I
don't okay I'm not familiar with that
name well we have an email here and when
it comes up I suspect it will show an
email from Karen Johnson to a number of
people including you and commissioner
Creek
and can we just scroll uh down a little
bit please
a little bit a little bit further
that's stroll up
okay this is not the document I'm
looking for let me ask you a question
though okay um would you agree with me
that there were a total of 44 arrests uh
in Windsor during this enforcement uh
phase yeah I do believe that that was
again we're at the arrest for the
responsibility of Windsor Police Service
right and from from what I recall you
can just tell me if this is that good or
not there were 88 charges approximately
and almost all of those were about 44
were mischief and about 44 were
breaching a court order I believe so and
and none of those are
pardon those two offenses are not
violent defense
right
um
they can be
everybody has there's a potential of
violence in any offense really
but but if somebody was was to commit a
violent offense they would typically be
charged with something like assault or
assault with a weapon yes it all depends
on the reasonable and probable grounds
right kidnapping enforceable confinement
murder
none of that
um
I
I'm just uh just about to to to wrap up
here I just want to ask him
a question about maintaining uh the
roads because you told my friend uh that
uh you know maintaining the roads was a
priority and you said to your I think
your officers that I'm clearing the
bridge is one thing but maintaining the
road is another thing
and I understand you were able to uh
maintain the road just thinking about
here on Church Road yes is that right
and you were able to maintain it
um by installing Jersey barriers along
the side of the road from the bridge to
the 401. uh correct not exactly right to
the 401 but approximately yes and is
that the distance of three kilometers I
think okay that could be I'm okay sorry
I'm not sure about the distances we used
other
um ways as well and the cement barriers
as well along with officers deployed to
the certain traffic stops too right and
you had a traffic plan that that um that
you employed when you were doing that
right correct and that traffic plan I
won't bring it up I think I'm out of
time okay um or very close to it it's
dated February 13
2022. yes I have a couple of minutes
yeah you know you're not near your time
I'll look at you when uh
when you're close to it well I'll I'll
I'll wrap up anyway and try and get some
Goodwill
um
a superintendent uh early uh
I take it it's obvious that if the
traffic plan is dated February 13 2022
it was not contemplating the use of uh
emergent Powers conferred on conferred
by the emergencies act no okay thank you
very much those are my questions thank
you
thank you next is the city of Windsor
foreign
superintendent early good afternoon I
have a few topics I'd like to canvas
with you today okay I am Jennifer King
I'm counsel to the city of Windsor
um first I'd like to speak to you about
your role in Windsor before Deputy
Commissioner Chris Harkins appointed you
to serve as OPP's critical incident
commander in Windsor
this morning you told my friend
commission Council that OPP PLT was
deployed to Windsor on February the 8th
following a conversation you had with
now deputy chief Crowley early on
February the 8th I think it was 2 A.M
yes yes it is my understanding from the
OPP's institutional report and perhaps
I'll stop there have you had an
opportunity to review OPP's
institutional report yes okay so I
understand from OPP's institutional
report and for the record it is OPP IR
701 I don't think we have to bring it up
Mr clerk but at page 27 it says that
four OPP PLT officers were deployed on
February the 7th to assist the WPS
um this is reflected in some of the
documents and I could show them to you
if it could help you confirm for us and
for the commissioner the date that OPP
PLT were deployed
I I know it was in between those two
days as you can see I
lost track of time sometimes or the when
the date changed because I was up until
all hours yes um but I know that PLT was
um deployed okay well why don't we look
at um perhaps Mr clerk you could bring
up OPP four zeros4580
and scroll to page 67.
superintendent early
commissioner karik produced texts with
Deputy solicitor general D tommaso that
have been produced to the commission
um commissioner Creek was kept apprised
of the operations in Windsor right yes
yes and so these are his texts with uh
Deputy solicitor general D tommaso and
if you go to page 67
at the bottom of the page Mr Clerk
the times on this so we have to go back
uh I believe it's five hours
um so I around noon on February the 7th
um commissioner Creek texted the deputy
solicitor general OPP PLT engaged
do you see that
yes and would he have gotten that
information
from you this is February 7th before you
were appointed correct
so I I don't know if he received it from
myself or from the chief or perhaps uh
Acting Superintendent Marcel Boden okay
there are other documents that refer to
PLT being engaged by February the 7th
does this assist you in confirming for
the commissioner the date that OPP PLT
were engaged I know that the discussion
was had that they would go and attend
and assist okay yeah and so it makes
sense to you that would have been
February the 7th based on yes thank you
you spoke with my friend Mr ow about
mayor dilkin's Public Announcement that
you said you watched on February the 9th
yeah I don't remember watching it but I
was certainly aware of it okay so so do
you do you remember whether or not you
heard about it or whether you saw it
yourself I heard had heard about it and
it was on February the 9th yes okay you
were not yet appointed no no
um so uh the mayor and chief Mizuno
former Chief Mizuno of the Windsor
Police Service held a press conference
at noon on February the 9th
um I don't have to bring it up but
there's documents about that press
conference does it make sense to you
this was something you would have heard
around the middle of the day yes okay
um
so this was a joint media briefing
delivered by mayor dillkins and chief
Mizuno do you recall that I do recall
okay okay um it was mayor dilkin's
evidence yesterday that his public
comments were reviewed by the chief of
police or her staff so that there were
no surprises when Windsor delivered a
message did you hear him say that
yesterday
uh no I did not hear him okay other than
the direction that you gave that you
discussed earlier that requests for
resources should not be made publicly
you are not engaged in Communications
were you with the mayor no sorry media
Communications
front that came from the city or sorry
I'm not sure that came from the city or
WPS I understand from your statement or
your witness summary that WPS continued
to have responsibility for media
releases and messages right they worked
alongside of our media officers our OPP
media officers and everything was
brought to the command table for review
okay and you had no concerns with media
releases or messaging after you arrived
in Windsor no
have a couple of brief questions about
the injunction and the continuing
continuation of the injunction earlier
today you described the injunction as a
tool an option for police yes can you
confirm you never raise any concerns
with the city of Windsor about seeking
the injunction I did not raise concerns
no and you raised no concerns about the
continuation of the injunction no
you spoke with my friend commission uh
Council about the traffic plan and this
has been discussed in in your
cross-examination as well I just wanted
to confirm that the purpose of the
traffic plan was to ensure the flow of
traffic from Highway 401 to the
Ambassador Bridge correct it was to
ensure that a protest did not occur
again yes but yes to keep the flow safe
keep the flow safe and keep the flow of
traffic over the Ambassador Bridge yes
clear yes okay and the concrete barriers
were installed on your direction yes
and this was to better manage future
risk of vehicles being used for
blockades right exactly excellent
um those are all my questions thank you
thank you
okay thank you uh questions uh by uh
former Chief slowlease Council
thank you commissioner superintendent
early Tom Curry for the former Chief in
Ottawa hello
um a couple of things just if I could
sort one thing out the the issue that my
friend Miss King was just asking you
about concerning the media here and or
not here in Windsor when you were in
Windsor about resources recall that
issue and my friend Mr Owl asked you
about this
um
do you recall that by the time
you were here in in Windsor as the
critical incident Commander that a
statement had been made
um in a media interview by the mayor
that named the number of officers that
the city had requested city of Windsor
or Windsor Police Service I suppose had
requested being 100
no I was not aware that that was
publicized okay so commissioner I have
the there's a I raised this with the
witness yesterday the mayor yesterday
and he recalled some something about
that my friend was King and I have
discussed this rather than show them the
the media pieces and so on uh I think
it's accepted that that on the 8th of
February the mayor in an interview with
I think it was CTV News
um named that number so I just uh one of
and my friend Miss King can just confirm
that so so Jennifer King uh Council for
Windsor
um yes I I we admit that that statement
was made in an interview with CTC TV
thank you
um
no superintendent early they the these
these issues that you dealt with in
Windsor
this incident was the largest presumably
the largest critical incident you have
managed in your career is that true
uh yes it was one of well is it the
largest though
um
yes yeah because it's it's uh you you
mobilized if I understand from your
institutional report or the services
institutional report
there were in the end 410 members of
your Police Service who were deployed in
Windsor true true yes over the
be at times yes and it would have it
would have peaked at a certain number
and then dissipated as it as the
demobilization went on but in the max
410 yes yes largest number that you've
been in command of yes and uh among the
largest in the province's history in
terms of deployment of Opp service
officers true
I I would think so I'm not sure and and
yet it was probably
um
well did you know how many were deployed
in Ottawa
no I did not know numbers your
relationship with uh with the with the
events in Ottawa can I speak about that
for a moment you had no direct
involvement in in the Ottawa incidents
that true that's correct you had some
points of contact as you've discussed
with Mr Rao about the letter for example
but otherwise those two incidents were
managed separately by by incident
commanders in both locations yes okay
and ultimately the Strategic command is
shared it's common true
shared with
Ottawa and Windsor yes a critical
incident commanders share a common uh
command structure reporting eventually
to Deputy Commissioners and
Commissioners yes correct and so it is
for the Deputy Commissioner or the
commissioner ultimately to set the
Strategic objectives and priorities for
the service yes
in both Windsor and Ottawa yes and and
so when my friend missed well by all of
the lawyers have probably asked you
about this but when you came to to this
first of all in your role as a
superintendent in the in the region
um you learned that there were convoys
in the area heading heading to
eventually to uh Essex County and to
Windsor correct uh there were convoys
that I discussed earlier sir is that
what you're referring to those convoys
actually stayed local in their
respective municipalities okay
and so you were your service was engaged
in providing safe passage and and just
managing whatever came whatever comes
from us a a slow role as it's been
described through your region right yes
that's correct and on the 6th of
February we know that the uh pendon
report uh alerted police services to the
possibility that now on the seventh
there would be a blockade of the
Ambassador Bridge
recall I don't recall reading that
specific report someone in your command
or below you in the chain of command
responsible for intelligence would have
that yes and was there did the what did
the opp in under your region take any
steps to intercept those convoys
on their way to the Ambassador Bridge
we did not have the information to
indicate where they were coming from or
what kind of vehicles or who would be
involved got it so whatever intelligence
came to to you in your region through
the Hendon reports was not sufficiently
clear to be able to take steps for
example to intercept a convoy for the
reasons you've just given right okay now
eventually after the after the
Ambassador Bridge was blocked and then
cleared uh I think one one of my
colleagues asked you about
um the interception of a convoy that was
heading to try to engage in another
blockade and the opp did stop that
Convoy is that true yes and and you
would have done that because by then of
course you'd had the experience of the
Ambassador Bridge blockade you had the
experience of the Ottawa blockade or
occupation as it's been described
and now you had actionable intelligence
to say
um including I suppose the emergencies
act to stop Convoy protesters from
engaging in further blockades true
correct okay
now a couple of things if I could about
your then your engagement as the
critical incident Commander that you've
told us about today the
uh first things first the issue about
the importance of this
um
of clearing this particular protest on
the Ambassador Bridge you've you've
spoken about that I just for your
just get your your help on this from
your statement that you have read to us
or has been filed
um
uh there is a reference on page two and
I have the name of this or they have the
number and I'm going to leave that for a
second
I will offer a reward
to anyone who can tell me the name of
that or the number of that statement Mr
Owl WTS
yes 22. thank you 22. thank you Mr
registrar
page two when we get there
paragraph three you've seen this before
foreign
upon thank you so this is a simple thing
but during a February 10th 8 30 a.m call
middle of the paragraph do you see it
Deputy Commissioner Harkins
Commissioners Harkins and DeMarco again
advice superintendent early that Windsor
was the priority
and that it was urgent to resolve the
blockade that's true isn't it yes and it
was obvious
to the to in terms of setting the
Strategic Direction
that is the role for not just
commissioner Creek but also the deputy
Commissioners to say what are the
priorities right and in respect of the
priorities the rank order of these
priorities
when we speak when they spoke to you
about it being the priority it was
understood that it was the priority for
the Ontario Provincial Police Service
right I understood it to be my priority
so it was my priority that I needed to
focus on yes of course it became your
priority because you were the critical
incident Commander but when they say it
is the priority you understood it was
the priority for the service
true I understood that it was a priority
and I would get whatever resources I
needed yes that's that came that that
followed and that's important but it was
when they spoke to you at 8 30 in the
morning on the 10th and said it was the
priority
it's the priority for the service I
can't speak to that you'd have to ask
them okay well we won't get a chance to
do that but you understood that whatever
else it was it was going to be uh that
task was being handed to you yes
and when they said at the top of that
statement and we have your notes of
course but I'm just in the interest of
time upon superintendent early's
appointment
Deputy Commissioner Harkins and Deputy
Commissioner DeMarco communicated to her
that Windsor was a priority and that she
would receive whatever resources
she needed you needed you understood
that yes and so prior to your ever put
picking up a pen and writing in your
notes the mission statement yes you knew
that whatever resources you needed you
had yes and in fact they had already
begun to roll out prior to your drafting
the mission statement correct
um now of course the the
um
uh
the resources of which we're speaking
were
were a number of different things but in
the main this you understood this was
going to require Pou resources right
and they had they came from Municipal
services and as well from The Hub that
Drew on OPP's resources correct correct
can I just show you please OPP 4543
this is from your uh this should be from
your notebook with the Scribe
um and if we could go please to
I think it should be the first page
initially
so this should be 2200 hours on February
the 9th yeah
telephone conference with Hamilton
Police Service and Windsor Police
Service Waterloo Regional Police Service
to discuss Pou support
and it's set out and that those are the
calls that you placed in order to
generate these these resources is that
right that's correct and then at
um at 7 15 a.m if we could just scroll
down
this should be page seven
so now we're 7 15 on the I suppose the
10th yeah Jamie Sheridan called to
advise
that he and his Waterloo Pou team would
be heading leaving rather for Windsor at
approximately 1100 1100 hours they were
rolling that's correct and then at
um at 8 30 on page eight please eight or
just at the bottom there it is telecom
telephone conference with Deputy Harkins
just scroll down we would could please a
little bit and Demarco
deputies advised whatever is needed for
plan will be available
Province focus is Windsor
and that's again that goes to the point
that I was making earlier the the
provincial focus is is Windsor for
obvious reasons the Ambassador Bridge is
vitally important right right those were
yeah from the teleconference when when
you write down or describe rather writes
down Province focus is Windsor those are
the words spoken by one or both of the
Commissioners deputies uh yeah it's in
the context of the conversation got it
Harkins speaking with RCMP today and
will forward Pou command
RCMP can send Pou team of 150 people
advised deputies
um Amy Ferguson perhaps Angela Ferguson
Angela thank you short form for Angela
will be Pou Commander for OPP Waterloo
Regional Police Service will arrive
approximately 1300 this afternoon
Arkansas advised there is an urgency to
get this resolved did he need to explain
to you why that was urgent or did you
understand the importance of the
Ambassador Bridge I understood
of course by then it was in the popular
press as well that this blockade was
causing enormous disruption yes and I
had also had conversations with deputy
chief Crowley at this time and had more
of a situational awareness understood
now and then you wrote out your mission
statement at 0.900 can I see that at
page nine please
now these mission statements just oh
there it is is that your handwriting to
the Scribe scribe okay so you dictated
this on maybe in the car I don't know
yes the opp and our policing partners
and it carries on I won't read it all
the mission statement in Windsor is is
very similar to the mission statement
that was used in Ottawa have you ever
seen that one no I have not are the
mission statements
um
I mean they're they I I don't want to
diminish the importance of mission
statements I like mission statements too
they're they're very important but these
are very generic General statements that
are used in a number of different OPP
operations is that fair
yeah elements are very simple the
elements are similar yes but each
situation would dictate
the the final mission right so safe flow
of traffic for example is the the the
thing that makes this Windsor specific
yes this one looks awfully much like the
opp mission statement for Caledonia
doesn't it I I haven't seen that one did
you go to calendar were you involved in
Caledonia
um I wasn't on the front line but as a
strategic Commander I was involved so on
and do you recall the mission statement
I don't do you agree with me that it
would
I I don't want to pull it up but do you
agree with me that the mission statement
for a protest like Caledonia would have
similar elements they would have similar
emblems the only thing that's missing is
free-flowing traffic where you're it
because Caledonia didn't it involved an
occupation of a different kind right
correct and do you agree that
um that one was a very difficult
demonstration to try to resolve and was
was not really ever resolved by a
policing solution it was a challenge yes
and do you agree wasn't resolved by a
policing solution
um
I'd have to look at my notes or I don't
recall I wasn't involved sure what was
your you were a strategic Commander
there um for some of it okay yes
put it this way those protesters were
never removed by a Pou action right
correct eventually I think the province
reached a financial settlement and
acquired the land over which the protest
was being held correct okay
um and then a couple of other things if
I if I can
um
Ottawa and Windsor very different
situations correct uh yes Ottawa uh
larger more complex more challenging uh
larger yes more complex each each
incident had its complexities yes but of
course I I'm asking if you can rank them
if you can't just tell me but if but are
isn't it obvious that oughta was a more
complex problem even than the one in
Windsor
I would say that it had different
challenges than the incident in Windsor
okay and much larger yes I will agree to
that can we can I get from you that the
different challenges of what you're
speaking are many more challenges
I wasn't in Ottawa so it's hard for me
to speak to that sir fair enough
now the incident command system and
autonomy
um today you made a change to the
statement that you uh that was filed and
commissioner I'm I'm going to borrow a
nut borrow well it is a loan of sport I
gather that my colleagues from Ottawa
are not going to use their town or
perhaps all of their time so if I could
just have a couple of their minutes
thank you I'll be I'll be quick as I can
be
um have they've been offered yes they
have we're prepared to seat our 10
minutes commissioner thank you thank you
so superintendent I'll be I'll just be
brief with a few other things today you
made a change to this statement do you
recall that yes I do and and did did my
friend Mr Al raise that with you this
morning before you came here
no I I raised it when I reviewed my
statement okay when did you review it
just today uh within the last couple
days okay had you reviewed it before
when it was sent to you or was it did
did they send it to you after they took
it in September yes they did and you
read it but yeah I didn't catch it then
no Okay the reason I asked is because
yesterday I asked uh
um
uh Deputy Crowley about about whether he
knew about that aspect and I and I
wondered if that's what prompted this
did you see that yesterday
um I watched his testimony okay good is
that what prompted you to catch this no
absolutely not I caught it prior to that
okay and the line that you wanted to
take out or did take out was she
informed them
the commissioners
uh or the team rather that the change in
Direction came from commissioner karik
and Deputy Commissioner Harkins and you
you would say instead of that line more
accurately
you made the change after your
conversation with commissioner Harkins
Deputy Harkins rather and commissioner
Kari that's correct now they have a the
two the two senior commands Deputy Chief
or Deputy Commissioner Harkins and
superintendent or and um commissioner
Kari have strategic uh overall strategic
Command right correct and so they set
the Strategic direction that the
critical incident Commander implements
uh yes so there's nothing wrong am I
right there's nothing wrong
with commissioner karik and Deputy
Commissioner Harkins
telling you that you should not delay
your operation while a letter goes to
the protesters in Ottawa but to get on
with the operation in Windsor that would
not be overstepping their Authority
would it
uh
I see it as overstepping the operational
control of the incident was mine it had
to that decision had to be made by me
yes but of course you so what happened
in the sequence and this is important
because my friends I I predict are going
to say that what you did in Windsor
informs what should have happened in
Ottawa so this is important for reasons
that you may not appreciate but let me
just ask you
the if I understand it what happened in
Windsor is that a protester Mr neufeld
correct came to a PLT officer and said
we'll all leave if you give us a letter
from the government yes and so you you
mobilize the government to write a
letter and the solicitor general writes
a letter to say we'll meet with you if
you denounce your unlawful actions and
everybody goes home yes and that letter
gets to Mr neufeld yes and of course
what does he do with it
it shared with everybody but it did not
produce the reaction we were hoping for
do we know anything about Mr neufeld
um I I don't did you at the time or did
you leave it to PLT I left it to PLT I'm
sure the information would be available
in my notes but okay fair enough I
couldn't find it but I but I'll admit
there are a lot of Records
um so and at the same time you said well
we can't give Mr neufeld a letter from
the provincial government from a
minister of the crown
without provoking possibly a reaction
from the Ottawa protesters who aren't
getting a letter from the solicitor
general I did not say it in that way but
I made sure that since a letter from the
government was being issued to the
protest in Windsor that people were
aware across the province that that was
happening got it and you said stop the
presses let's not take action until we
give a letter to Ottawa to the Ottawa
protest there was discussion in regards
to that yes and then the commissioner
well first of all the Deputy
Commissioner rang you correct yes and
expressed The View that that was not the
strategy he wished to follow it was
suggested that it re-evaluate because I
was not aware of the details of what was
happening in Ottawa as he was and as the
commissioner was
yes in other words they're they've got
strategic commands yes and they uh and
may I just please go back to that
statement at 22 Yeah WTS 22 please page
13. I'll just be a second with this
thank you during a 6 47 p.m call and we
have the Scribe notes but I'll do it
this way on the same date Deputy
Commissioner Hawkins told superintendent
early not to pause enforcement out of
concern about the potential impact on
the Ottawa protesters
that's true that's true I shared with
him that I had decided to pause it based
on that and then he shared with me
Insight in regards to what was going on
in Ottawa and that if that was the main
reason not to pause enforcement based on
that got it and so he called you at that
time
um
you don't recall if he called me or I
was updating him well so if we just
scroll up a little bit I think he called
you because stop superintendent early
advised her command table at 6 17 on the
11th she had decided to pause the
enforcement action yes pull down
during a 647 call Deputy Harkins told
you not to pause enforcement so do you
now recall that that
word got to him and he had a different
view I don't recall if I called him or
he called me to be honest okay you have
to well if you called him it was to
check in with him was it
it was to bring in an update okay and
when you did it was that you were
pausing it was yeah it was uh and and
commissioner session of my decision
thank you Deputy Commissioner Harkins
said don't pause
we discussed my reasons for wanting to
pause and he said if it was solely based
on
Ottawa that it that you should not that
it's not to worry about it to remain
focused on Windsor thank you and at the
bottom you pointed out the risk yes you
advised of the risk that police
enforcement could have impacts on Ottawa
and lead to an increase in aggression
and violence by protesters in Ottawa
correct
uh no though the aggression in the
Violence by protesters was in regards to
the response to the operational plan
that I had was going to move forward
with in Windsor
but what does that have to do with I'm
not following that isn't it Ottawa that
you were concerned with because look at
the last sentence
you advise Deputy Commissioner Harkins
of the risk that police enforcement
action could have impacts on Ottawa and
lead to an increase in aggression and
violence by protesters mustn't those
protesters be the ones in Ottawa it
would be protesters uh wherever across
the province and so that's why we were
discussing it
okay
But it includes Ottawa at least yes
Deputy Commissioner Harkins confirms
that he's aware and then a few minutes
later you have a call now with
commissioner karik
and and Deputy yes and am I right that
the deputy got commissioner karik on
because he wanted to emphasize the
message to you that he was giving which
is you should go ahead and and clear the
Ambassador Bridge they supported me
moving forward with the plan
yeah well when you say support you see
superintendent they what they supported
was a different decision than the one
you had taken to the command table you
wanted to pause yes and they said don't
pause they provided me with information
that made me change my mind that the
pause was not necessary that we were
ready to go and reminded me that Windsor
was my priority I mean it yeah I know
that we're
this is can sound like it's semantics
but it's not really semantics because
it's not information they provided to
you
it's Direction they provided to you it
was a discussion I did not find that it
was directive it was a discussion that
we had about my reasons for pausing they
simply took a different view than you
about the importance of not giving a
letter to the Ottawas protesters right
no the letter was going to be given
regardless
well okay then pausing while you but you
wanted to give the letter to Ottawa and
then let it go and do its work right
that was what my first
um option was and that's what I was
considering
and so they said
here's our judgment as strategic
commanders you're a go clear the
Ambassador Bridge
yes that was part of the discussion got
it
um now then uh finally
the PLT which spoke about this briefly
but the PLT was not able to get make
yards in this protest they they it was a
failure of the ability to negotiate with
this group of disparate protesters right
I wouldn't call any work of the
eventually is on team of failure their
effort was there but it did not produce
the results that we were hoping right
and the
well
there are only two ways down this
mountain
these are those protesters were going to
leave because you asked them to leave
and negotiated their withdrawal
including by giving a letter from the
solicitor general of the province
correct or you were going to have to
muscle them out with a Pou operation
right we use an operational plan from
Pou yes uh last question then please
just on the issue of strategic command
could I show you please WTS 39 this is
the witness statement from the
commissioner and I just need your help
again because it's it may be important
to sorting out the roles and
responsibilities of strategic commanders
and incident Commanders
uh page eight please
Under The Heading incident command
system
the commissioner said
this and I don't know whether you've
seen this
uh fourth line down while some incident
commanders do you see it
yes may feel as though they have
complete autonomy this is not the case
the chief or commissioner remains
responsible to provide adequate and
effective Police Services is accountable
to the board under the police services
act in the case of a Municipal Police
Service and is entitled to set strategic
direction or give lawful orders
however incident commanders should have
operational autonomy to carry out
strategic objectives set by senior
command
and
that's accurate yes and so what what
occurred between you and Deputy
Commissioner Harkins and um
commissioner Creek was simply that is
that fair fair okay
commissioner thank you thank you thank
you okay well you're you and city of
Ottawa are overdrawn but uh
we'll see when we get to Ottawa uh the
Windsor Police Service
uh thank you Mr commissioner good
afternoon uh superintendent good
afternoon my name is Tom McCray I'm here
for the Windsor Police Service I only
have a couple of questions okay
um I believe you told one of my friends
earlier today that Windsor Police
Service was responsible for the rest the
arrests that were made yes it's their
jurisdiction and they I I take it that
they were also responsible for
developing the arrest plans is that
correct they worked with me like every
other plan to create the arrest plan and
the public and the Prisoner
Transportation plans too yes they were
we worked alongside of each other to
create those plans
thank you
um there's an organization that I've
learned about called the
um Ontario women in law enforcement are
you aware of them yes
and I understand that you
were awarded together with members of
both the opp and Windsor Police Service
with the teamwork award this past June
is that correct yes and I also
understand that it was deputy chief
Crowley who put you up for that award is
that correct yes that's correct those
are my questions thank you thank you
okay uh
city of Ottawa
we we seeded our time so we have no
questions commissioner thank you
uh Ottawa Police Service
good afternoon superintendent I'm
Jessica Barrow and I'm counsel for the
Ottawa Police Service hello I just
wanted to clarify one quick thing with
you that came out of your conversation
with Mr Curry and that's the change that
you made this morning to your witness
statement yes so just to make sure I
have it correct what you indicated this
morning was that you had a conversation
with commissioner Creek as well as the
Deputy Commissioner yes in relation to
whether to Stand Down The Windsor
operation yes and as a result of that
conversation you ultimately decided to
revert course and continue with the
Windsor operation correct correct
and just so that I understand it the
reason for that was because you obtained
new information in the course of that
conversation correct correct and you
couldn't otherwise have had that
information previously because you were
in charge of the Windsor operation
that's correct and you had limited
information or I think line of sight
into that operation in Ottawa that's
correct and so it was less a question of
being directive and more about sharing
information with you that you couldn't
otherwise have had prior to that meeting
that's correct and so as a result of
that meeting you decided that the risks
you initially were concerned about uh
were not concerns after all and you
could proceed with your operation that's
correct okay thank you those are my
questions thank you
next the
Ottawa Coalition of residents and
businesses
afternoon commissioner Emily
Emeline for the Ottawa Coalition we
don't have any questions thank you
thank you the Convoy organizers
good afternoon Mr commissioner Bathsheba
Vandenberg for Freedom Corp and
protesters we have no questions for
superintendent early thank you
thank you National Police Federation
this is uh Lauren Pierce from the
National Police Federation we also have
no questions
okay the province of Alberta
afternoon this is Stephanie Boos for the
province of Alberta we have no further
questions
okay the Ontario Provincial Police
thank you commissioner we have no
questions
any uh re-examination
no thank you
okay well uh that was a obviously very
clear evidence nobody seems to want to
cross-examine you are limited I should
say well thank you very much for
attending uh you're free to go and we
thank you for your evidence thank you
so given the
Speedy way in which we went through this
I think we'll take an hour and nine
minutes for lunch today
so we'll come back at two o'clock
the commission is in recess until two
o'clock congratulations
order a lot
the commission is
[Music]
yes Allison McMahon commission Council
and our next witness is Paul lasheed
is she
Mr Nasheed will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm I'd
like to affirm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Paul p-a-u-l Winfield
w-i-n-f-i-f-i-e-l-d leashide
l-e-s-c-h-i-e-d
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you
and commissioner Mr lasheed's council is
appearing virtually and would like to
briefly address the commission
okay yes go ahead
my name is
my name is Lonnie rillard and I appear
for Paul the sheet and I'd just like to
confirm prior to the proceeding with the
witness that the protections of section
9 of the Ontario Evidence Act and
section 5 of The Evidence Act of Canada
and vote for the witness
okay thank you
um just for the record uh
Mr lasheed is is under uh subpoena
and uh I have deemed that I will deem
that the witness has objected to answer
each and every question
on the ground that his answers May tend
to incriminate or may tend to establish
his liability to a civil proceeding at
the instance of the crown or of any
other person and if but for the acts
invoked the witness would
or this act he the witness would
therefore have to been excused from
answering the questions then although
the witnesses by reason of his this act
or the
Federal and provincial act compelled to
answer the answer is so given shall not
be used or admissible in evidence
against him in any criminal trial or any
other
criminal proceeding against him
thereafter taking place other than a
prosecution for perjury
in the giving of that evidence or for
the giving of contradictory evidence so
is that that adequate then
yes thank you sir okay with that
introduction I think we can uh proceed
with the examination go ahead thank you
very much
uh Mr lasheed you were interviewed by
commission Council on October 4th is
that correct yes and um Mr registrar if
we could please pull up WTS 60049
Mr lashita is that the a summary of the
interview yes and have you had an
opportunity to review this summary yep
and do you have any corrections to it no
okay then we'll ask that it be entered
as an exhibit
foreign
you live in McGregor Ontario is that
right oh correct and that's about 15
kilometers from Downtown Windsor
15 to 20 kilometers from Downtown
Windsor yet okay
okay I co-own a contracting business
that serves the greater Windsor Essex
County area
okay and have you been a lifelong
resident of the Essex County area
I've lived in Essex County area for the
better part of the last 44 years other
than
the time I spent at University and
briefly in Alberta for uh as a
commercial helicopter pilot
and can you please tell the commission
about how you became involved with
protests against covid-19 public health
mandates
um
I would just say like uh
many other Canadians I've grown a little
wary with the
uh
I guess the direction of
our basic fundamental rights and
freedoms kind of being transformed into
privileges that can be granted or
revoked based upon our
personal compliance with whatever the
latest
mandate or bylaw that's being passed
down by our federal
provincial or Municipal leaders
that led me to be a little concerned as
a father of three young children
the direction that this country is
heading in and so
I participated in several peaceful
lawful protests
um
so that people's voices could be heard
with these same concerns
I mean we had various fundraisers for
people that have been
negatively impacted or had job losses or
had their businesses somewhat run into
the ground or not being able to make
ends meet
um
we've had various freedom
rallies uh
at the uh flag I guess that you would
call it at the Downtown Windsor area of
Riverside and all that Avenue
and are those the sort of weekly rallies
that would take place starting in I
wouldn't say I was there for the weekly
rallies there have been weekly rallies
and I was I did my part to
offer whatever Assistance or support
that I could at Several of these uh
events over the last couple years
okay and how would you typically hear
about protests that you would attend or
fundraisers or rallies I mean I just
have made a lot of friends and uh
that would attend some of these rallies
in the area that have similar concerns
that I do
uh so you know through text message uh
periodic meetups where people might be
discussing
what they would like to do or what
actions maybe they would like to
take next
and would you post about it on social
media or sort of join did you join any
groups um related to more just like
personal interactions with the friends
that were involved in the same sort of
things okay so you weren't part of any
sort of formal organizations I wouldn't
say that there was very many formal
organizations it was kind of a loose
organization with people coming and
going and
that would be about it and and a loose
organization in the sense of just you
have this network of friends who I mean
like I said it would be
some people that were that were involved
with this maybe prior to me getting
involved and then
I would meet certain people
over the course of these events and
um
that would be about it okay and did you
help plan any of these rallies or I mean
I I offered support where I could I
thought I was a calming influence on a
lot of these events when perhaps maybe
things got
contentious or
uh
you know offer support in terms of
setting things up
you know we would have a Sound Stage
perhaps and you know I would offer
support and
moving things from point A to point B or
hauling things from from somewhere to to
wherever the venue happened to be at
okay
and I understand that in January 2022
and continuing into early February there
were slow roll protests on Huron Church
Avenue yeah right and were you aware of
those I was aware of those yes did you
participate in them no I did not like
attend them in any way or anything like
that okay
okay and were you at that time following
what was happening in Ottawa with the
freedom Convoy yes okay and how how were
you monitoring that was it through
social media through traditional media
uh mostly social media and then you know
I had a couple friends that were were
heading up there at various points
during the the Ottawa demonstrations
okay
we'll come back to that
um but you didn't you didn't participate
in any of the events not what did you no
so the blockade starts of the Ambassador
Bridge starts on February 7th as I
understand it
um in the days leading up to that were
you aware that there might be a protest
in that area no
uh so we've heard evidence over the last
day and a half that there were social
media posts about a slow Rule and
potential blockade but that was not
something that that you saw I knew that
there was slow rolls going on
um was there rumors about this event or
that event going on
there's there's all kinds of things
being
shared across social media but I was not
aware of any Organization for an event
that was going to start on February 7th
was a blockade of the investor Bridge
something that you had heard rumors
about
very Loosely like I mean you might have
heard somebody suggest oh well that
would be a
that would be an interesting idea but
nothing that would ever have been
something that I was involved in
discussing
okay
and you attended the blockade for the
first time on the evening of February
7th is that right correct and around
what time would you have arrived I would
estimate around 9pm
and for the rest of the week would you
typically attend around the same time
yeah I would I would usually go after my
young children were put to bed and uh I
would head down from between the hours
of eight and nine until maybe 12 to 1
o'clock in the morning okay
and so on that first evening on February
7th
um where were the protesters located so
where I went was at the intersection of
Gerardo and here on Church Avenue which
is approximately a half kilometer south
of the egress point of the Ambassador
Bridge Southbound on Huron Church okay
and uh Mr registrar could we please pull
up the map of Windsor
so that we can see where that is
and so as I understand it the egress
Point as you referred to it is north of
college on Huron church is that right
correct so with that being the vicinity
of that purple icon
yeah yeah somewhere between the purple
and and maybe just a little bit south of
that okay
and uh Gerardo if that's down the that's
so Gerardo would be
um if you see the second cross street I
I see you there's a little where it says
dot Avenue beside it and you see like an
intersection there
that would be where the intersection of
Gerardo and here on Church would be and
that's about halfway between college and
Tecumseh correct okay
and so when you arrived at the protest
that night uh were Vehicles blocking the
intersection there was probably three to
four uh pickup trucks blocking or
straddling both sides of uh Huron Church
Avenue North and southbound at that
intersection and so were they driving
down
Gerardo I'm sorry I'm going to butcher
that that street name or were they
driving down uh Huron church so they
weren't driving when I got there they
were just kind of straddled across like
perpendicular to Huron Church Avenue so
that they were impeding the traffic at
Gerardo and Huron Church
how many vehicles were blocking the
intersection I would say three to four
and did you participate in that blockade
no I parked much further away on a side
street and so then you walked in yes and
were there were most people in their
cars or were they on foot uh they would
be on foot other than those three to
four cars that were involved there
everybody else would be on foot roughly
how many other protesters were uh when I
got there maybe
40 50 somewhere in that range
they were standing in the intersection
on the sidewalks on the sidewalks uh
some in the intersection of that area
and were there police present yes
what were they doing
uh so there would have been police
vehicles at the intersection near
um
I guess on the east side of that road
where the Assumption High School area is
mm-hmm and have they set up blockades
anywhere
so I didn't discover that until after I
left that evening and then I had seen
that there was uh Windsor police
vehicles that several of the
intersections surrounding the general
area and that's on February the 7th yes
and yesterday we saw evidence that
protesters had started setting up a camp
on the first night and had told police
that they were staying put and not
moving is that something that you
observed
I didn't observe that at the Gerardo
intersection which is the only spot that
I really walked okay so you weren't at
College Street for example not on
February 7th and you didn't sort of walk
by there when you my Impressions that
Gerardo was that there was
um
semi trucks backed up on both North and
southbound lanes for
as far as my eyes could see so I had no
reason to really walk along all of the
other semi trucks on the road that were
just sitting there idling
and was your impression that they were
backed up because because of the
blockade ad uh Gerardo yes that's
correct okay
and what time did you leave the protest
on that first night I would estimate
one o'clock in the morning
did you expect the protesters would stay
overnight when I left there was probably
a dozen or so protesters left there and
I had assumed that that would be a
one-off site type of event and it would
be over by the next morning or later
that night so while you were there you
hadn't discussed with anybody that uh
that you might that they might stay
there overnight
I think I might have asked like is
anybody planning to stay here
beyond the evening because the numbers
had dwindled as in the three or four
hours that I was there and I had just
assumed by one o'clock in the morning
when it was kind of apparent that there
was more police presence in the area
than there were protesters
that this wasn't going to go on for any
length of time
okay
and you attended the protest again the
next night is that right
I mean I I remember
asking a friend the next morning
is anything still going on at the
Ambassador Bridge or Huron Church area
um
and he said yeah that's still going on
which I was very surprised of
um
and so yeah I went down
the second the second evening about the
same time
and was that friend somebody who had
stayed overnight at the protest no did
you know any of the people who were in
the trucks blocking the intersection
that night I had never seen any of the
people in the three or four uh pickup
trucks or SUVs uh that were there that
night prior or since
and so on the second night the protest
is more centrally located at College
Street
um were the lanes All blocked in every
direction on uh
excuse me was Huron Church blocked in
both directions so on that second night
the
protests seem to be
centrally located at the southbound
egress point from the Ambassador Bridge
so those Lanes would have been blocked
Northbound I believe there was
maybe one or two protest vehicles on the
Northbound area but the entire perimeter
I guess of the college here on Church
intersection was
um cordoned off by police vehicles
so all four points of the intersection
were blocked off by people I would say
three of the four inner parts and then
the southbound uh Huron church just
south of College Avenue that was where
more of the protest vehicles that didn't
fit on say the north side where the
egress area is from Ambassador Bridge
they had started to to park on that
South section of the southbound Lanes if
Huron Church south of College Avenue
and approximately how many protesters
were and were there that night
uh people are Vehicles both
I would say perhaps 40 vehicles
uh
a few large semi trucks and
probably between 100
150 protesters
again the numbers the numbers fluctuated
over the times that I was there usually
dwindling as the evenings got later
and did the crowd Dynamic changes things
got later
I would say from my interactions with
other people the crowd Dynamic might
have changed from the daytime to the
evening times
but from the times I would get there at
nine till one o'clock which was my
average times that I would have been
there
uh
Dynamic would have stayed the same just
the numbers probably would have dropped
off as people left to go home
and could you describe what the the
atmosphere was like when you attended
the protests
um I mean there would be music uh the
national anthem would be sung you know
periodically
uh there would be food uh being shared
amongst anybody and everybody that was
wanted to to be part of that
uh
generally just a peaceful
uh Gathering of people that were there
for various reasons
and did you talk to other protesters
about their reasons for being there
and not really specifically uh
it's probably largely assumed the
reasons I mean I think I spoke to a few
of the truck drivers who expressed their
reasons for being there was was more in
line with the fact that they were about
to face losing their ability to cross
the international border without
compliance with the mandates to cross
Drive their trucks to and from the
United States
personal vehicles there as well and
individuals who weren't truck drivers
exactly and do they have different goals
I don't think I really spoke in depth
with some of the strangers that I was
meeting for the first time about why
they were there I think it was just
assumed to me that they were there
celebrating
um or expressing their peaceful right to
to protest
and on the Tuesday what was the police
presence like
well that certainly had grown
um
definitely seemed to be a little bit
more organized than on the first night
when things were were a little bit more
new
um
they generally seem to be
from the ones that I was able to
interact with or or or witness other
people interacting with very friendly
and cordial with the protesters that
were there
did you have a did you interact with any
of the police officers
uh not more than to uh be a party and
perhaps talks that they were having with
other people
um other than to offer hellos or
greetings to to some of the officers
that might have been in the areas where
I was
and did were they telling you anything
about your right to be there or
encouraging you to leave anything like
that
um on that second night certainly there
was a lot of I shouldn't say a lot there
were some police officers that would
suggest
um
we support your right to be here or
we're happy that uh
maybe not the word happy we're we're in
support with with what you're doing here
and everything seems to be peaceful
um
I'd be about it so there they weren't
advising you that you had to leave or be
arrested no okay
and uh were there more barricades on
this night than there had been the
previous night or was it pretty
consistent I mean the previous night I
wouldn't suggest that there was I didn't
remember seeing barricades I would say
that there was police cruisers at
intersections and I guess if that
represents a barricade uh that would be
what I would say on night number one and
then night number two they would have
some of those construction like the
orange construction wooden barricades at
some of the intersections in the area
okay
and I understand from your interview
summary that some protester Vehicles
were able to come and go from the
protest area on that second night yes
okay and how did that work if there were
the wooden barriers and cruisers
stationed along the
uh well I remember noticing around
between somewhere around midnight and
maybe 12 30 a couple trucks that uh semi
trucks are large large-sized trucks had
entered or had had to go around the
Tecumseh Road
uh Huron Church intersection to go down
some of the the the residential streets
that would be west of Huron Church
um and you could hear the horns
um
and they entered I believe at College
Avenue and Huron Church where there
would have been a police cruiser and
orange barricades
um and upon them arriving at the
intersection I saw the police officers
get out of the vehicles remove the
barricades and and allow the trucks to
enter into that intersection and then
basically direct them to park on the
southbound Lanes of Huron Church Avenue
south of College Avenue
and did you see any other cooperation
between the police and protesters
I mean generally I think in that second
night there was an ability for vehicles
to to leave later on in the evening if
they were not planning to to remain
parked on here on Church Avenue that
night
I'm not exactly sure where they were
facilitated to come and go uh I know
there's a couple intersections there
that would allow you to exit to
the west of Huron Church
and perhaps they were uh
you know the Cruisers maybe would have
allowed some of those trucks or
passenger vehicles to exit at that point
I don't remember actually witnessing how
they were getting out
so something that you were aware of but
I just remember I guess I'm deducing
this from the fact that there was
different Vehicles there say on night
two from the subsequent nights and I
could only assume that they had to have
been able to leave on their own accord
with police cooperation
uh Mr commissioner I just want to say
for the record uh the map that I
referred to earlier is uh doc ID com
650930 and that's a screenshot of the
same map that was shown to you yesterday
and a link for which was circulated to
the parties yesterday I just wanted to
clarify that point
now on Wednesday night were protesters
still at College yes
and were there also additional protest
sites
I had heard that there was a
there was there was
approach some protesters that wanted to
perhaps blockade the Wine Dot entrance
to the Ambassador Bridge I never went
over there to see it uh I know that
there are some protesters that perhaps
wanted to
be involved with blocking the Tecumseh
Road and Huron Church intersections
but I I never really walked
to the Wyandotte area to see what was
really going on
okay and the just referring back to the
map
um Wine Dot is the where there's a entry
into the Ambassador Bridge Port of Entry
it would be like the ancillary entry uh
whereas the main entry would be
Northbound here on Church uh into the
Ambassador Bridge area
and was that to your knowledge was that
intersection completely
um blocked the Northbound entrance to
the Ambassador Bridge the Wyandot with
the Wine Dot one again I didn't go there
I just remember hearing some protesters
say uh it's blocked and then you'd hear
it's not blocked and then it's been
given up to
um
in negotiations for for emergency use
vehicles to to come and go but again I
never saw it with my own eyes to be be
able to say when it was blocked when it
was not blocked
did you were you aware of who was
engaging in negotiations over things
like emergency planes I would have just
I would have been hearing this third
hand from somebody that maybe would have
heard those
negotiations prior to my arrival okay
and so at this point was any traffic
able to enter or exit the bridge
is to the best of my knowledge the
Northbound entrance to the Ambassador
Bridge was always open and I believe it
was being used by law enforcement or
perhaps cbsa to come and go because
that's a very large like two or three
lane uh entrance point to the bridge and
it was secured uh from night number two
until the end of the the demonstration
by law enforcement and it was never
really impeded
by protesters although because here on
church was was basically blocked by or
secured at Tecumseh Road by Windsor
Police surfaces or other law enforcement
that you couldn't get to that Northbound
area as a
as a vehicle no vehicle could really get
into that area
were there also vehicles at the or
protesters excuse me at the Tecumseh
Road intersection
periodically I believe I would see some
but it was a very small contingent that
was that was at that intersection
okay
and what was the crowd like relative to
the previous nights and this is on the
Wednesday we're talking
uh
largely the same as the previous night
um perhaps a little bit larger maybe in
in the number of people that were there
but the same sort of things going on
national anthems food food uh
or let's say uh cordial atmosphere
amongst everybody that was there sort of
a party like atmosphere or yeah but I
mean it would die down from being a
party as the as the evening got later
and colder and
and were people drinking alcohol I never
saw that you didn't see anyone drinking
okay or using drugs I didn't see that
what was the police presence like on
Wednesday night
so it started to become more apparent
that it looked like they were preparing
um
I believe seeing police vehicles that
didn't look recognizable to me as
Windsor Police Service Vehicles there
um I remember seeing around midnight or
one o'clock like a green uh pickup truck
with several
what I could only estimate would be like
SWAT team type uh members dressed up in
the back of a truck
um kind of coming out of that Northbound
entrance area into the Ambassador Bridge
and and they would come and
I don't know either do whatever that was
that they were practicing to do or if
they were trying to gather information
and then and then they would leave
and it looked to you like they were not
Windsor police officers it didn't look
to me like a vehicle I had ever
recognized as a windsor police vehicle
and I believe it was like a green uh
like F-250 or F-350 Style
vehicle
so moving to Thursday night in your
witness statement you said that uh
police started to encourage protesters
to leave the area is that correct I
would say that was on Friday I think is
when I would I would gather that I
started to hear
some of those suggestions okay it was on
Friday and was that was a change in
messaging from what you'd heard
previously from police
yeah I would say so
and how did the protesters react to that
message I think most of the protesters
were still still were
Stewart of the opinion that they were
not going to leave until
some some level of achievement had been
made for the the purposes of their
demonstration
and what would some level of achievement
be uh perhaps maybe a discussion with uh
with somebody that they were seeking to
have a conversation with
um I guess I could only speak for
hearing some of the the drivers of the
larger trucks
um that we're going to be faced with
losing the the ability to to perform
their job if they weren't going to
comply with a mandate and so that was
their
in my estimation reason for being there
did it feel like the protesters were
United on that point or did people have
different motivations I would say some
of the protesters and certainly the ones
that were in the profession of driving
heavy trucks
um
but again I'd be assuming what what
every person's reason uh that wasn't a
truck driver was there why they were
there
but there wasn't sort of a formal List
of Demands that you were aware of there
was nothing like that
and before Friday night did you believe
that the protest was lawful and
you could remain there without fear of
arrest correct yeah
and on Friday did that change
I mean I was not aware of the details of
the injunction I had heard that it was
being discussed
um
I showed up on that that night the same
way I had done the previous four nights
uh
to be part of a peaceful demonstration
and observe with my own two eyes what
was happening and
in the backyard of my own community that
I've been a part of
what did you understand about the the
injunction that night not very much to
be honest
but you knew it had been granted I
wasn't sure when perhaps it had been
granted I just knew that it was in in
talks
um
that was about the extent of it
if I could please pull up uh WPS
I believe it's seven zeros four nine
foreign
so this is an affidavit that was filed
in in the injunction proceedings
and on page 16 there is a message to
demonstrators which I understand was
distributed by The Windsor Police
Service on February 11th
and you can see on the screen that it
says the Windsor Police Service wants to
make demonstrators clearly aware that it
is a criminal offense to obstruct
interrupt or interfere with the lawful
use enjoyment or operation of property
the offense itself is known to Mischief
of property
the unlawful Act of blocking streets at
and near the Ambassador Bridge is
resulting in people being denied the
lawful use enjoyment and operation of
their property and causing businesses to
close down we are providing notice that
anyone blocking streets or assisting
others in blocking in the blocking of
streets may be committing a criminal
offense and must immediately immediately
cease further unlawful activity or you
may face charges you could be arrested
if you're a party to the offense or
assisting others in the direct or
indirect Commission of this offense
is this something that you saw while you
were at the protests no did you see it
at any point no no is it consistent with
what you were being told by The Windsor
Police Service that night
no I was never told any of the what you
just read off there
so you weren't aware that that um you
might be charged with Mischief for
example no
I understand that uh Friday was the last
day that you attended the protest is
that right correct and why was that
I think I just got the sense on that
Friday that they were going to put a uh
put an end to this protest
um
and the following Saturday again I I'm
I'm only able I was only able to go at
these later times in the evening after
uh I'd worked all day and and again put
my children to bed at night and on that
Saturday it was kind of clear that
things were were escalating to the point
that this was going to come to an end
and there was no reason for me
to head down to there
and on the Friday Ontario declared a
state of emergency where you are of that
again I might have heard it on uh on the
radio
did that influence your decision to
leave the protest
no again I was just there to to I was
there to witness what was happening
um so that I
so that I could know what was actually
going on down at the Ambassador Bridge
demonstration because I figured that was
probably the only way I was going to
know really what was happening is to
witness it with my own two eyes
and that brings up the issue of media
coverage which is something that you
spoke about in your interview summary
um did you feel that the media coverage
of the protest was generally accurate
uh I would say that there was a lot of
um
perhaps exaggeration of what was
happening at the demonstration in
Windsor it was certainly being painted
as
something that I didn't witness for the
the five days that I was there which was
simply a peaceful protest of people that
wanted to have their voices heard and
how was it being painted
uh I mean I remember seeing
videos or Clips on the mainstream media
showing trucks like backed up across the
Ambassador Bridge uh beyond that first
night which which
did I mean I think they cleared the
Ambassador Bridge within 12 hours or so
on that first night so that was never
that was never going on the rest of the
week there was only like four to six
semi trucks that were involved in
impeding or block hating traffic on that
southbound Huron Church area and it
certainly made
the coverage certainly seemed to make it
sound like it was it was much larger in
scale and scope than than that
and
was there any information about the
effect of the blockade that you felt was
inaccurate
in terms of the kind of economic impact
on again I don't know what the actual
economic impact is because that's not
something I I study or or really learn
or know about so it was just sort of the
images that you were seeing didn't
reflect what you were I mean not just
what I'm seeing in Windsor but I mean
I kind of observed the same sort of
misrepresentation uh from what I would
hear from friends that were in Ottawa
versus what was actually being shown on
television in regards to the nature of
the demonstrations that were going on
okay
so I'm going to go briefly back to the
state of emergency
um that was declared on February 11th
um
effective on the 12th midnight of the
12th and if we could go back to WPS
7049 please
and page 19.
this is another flyer that I understand
was distributed on the 11th
is this something that you saw no
okay
now I'd like to uh ask you about sort of
the organization of the protest and the
leadership which is something I know
we've already touched on a little bit
um but your evidence earlier was that
you weren't aware of any formal plan
around the protest am I getting that
right yep that's correct
and so you don't know who started it
or or how they disseminated the message
to go to Huron church and no sure don't
okay
so to the best of your knowledge it just
came together kind of organically
that would have been my assumption yes
and Did You observe anyone who appeared
to be speaking on behalf of protesters
to police
no
so as far as you were aware police were
sort of just interacting with with there
were certain groups that the police
would be talking with uh but not like
one Central group that it seemed like
they would be engaging with on a routine
basis
So when you say that there were groups
that they would be engaging with do you
just mean that on a given day that you
might see them talking to a particular
group of people but the next day you'd
see them talking to someone else yeah
yep okay so there was no consistency in
who was it was it was a leaderless
movement that I I didn't see
one focal point uh that was being
discussed discussing things with with
law enforcement uh on a routine basis
and did you have a
sex would have ended at some point if
the police hadn't intervened or was it
the police intervention that brought it
to an end
I could only speculate I mean the police
brought it to an end uh how how things
would have unfolded if that didn't
happen
I don't know
but at that point on Friday when you
left there was no sort of sense that
everyone was going to start packing up
and leaving no I didn't get that sense
yeah something that you mentioned
earlier was that some people at the
protest felt that they um
they wanted to talk to somebody in
government is that right
um I wouldn't say that would I guess
that would be an assumption that I made
that you know they wanted to have their
voices heard
because they had largely been silenced
and they had no other
they probably felt they had no other
option as to who could they talk to
regarding
the mandates that were coming that would
force them or or cause them to be able
to lose their ability to to do their
jobs crossing the international border
and so
um
and I know that this is something that
you had mentioned in your interview
summary as well is that you felt like
politicians weren't refusing to kind of
engage with the protesters and hear them
out is that true yeah I never saw any
politicians came to to engage with
anybody there so as apart from the
protesters generally for you personally
was it a goal to have a politician come
and speak to you or acknowledge the the
protest
no I wouldn't say that I went there with
any goals
okay
uh could we please pull up
ont50858
this if you could scroll down a bit
keep going a little bit more thank you
this is a letter from the solicitor
general of Ontario Sylvia Jones to the
commissioner of the Ontario Provincial
Police which is dated February 11th
and
um
it states this letter is being sent
regarding the protest activity occurring
in Windsor and restricting access to the
Ambassador Bridge which must end the
government of Ontario is proposing that
a meeting occur with an agreeable time
within an agreeable time period between
a select group of protest leadership and
representatives of the province to allow
their issues to be heard
to move forward with our offer to
schedule a meeting all protesters must
leave the protest site immediately
denounce all unlawful activity and
encourage a period of quiet this means
no unlawful unpeaceful unsafe protest
activity can occur between the time of
acceptance of this offer until the
meeting takes place
have you ever seen this letter before no
so it's not something that you was
shared with you on the 11th no
was the offer set out in this letter
something that you think you would have
been interested in or
me personally
um
no
why is that I mean I just I I was there
I was there to observe what was
happening and to support other people
that were there for their particular
reasons to conduct themselves in a
peaceful lawful protest
you don't think that
that stirs would have wanted to do
to accept this offer of a I can't say
that other protesters there's probably
other protesters that may have have
accepted this offer but I can only speak
for myself okay
are you in contact with anyone involved
in the Ottawa protests
uh
uh I had some friends that had gone up
to to Ottawa and I would interact with
them or ask them how things were where
wherever they were at
and were these friends from Windsor
Essex County area yep okay were they
involved in the leadership of the no
Ottawa protests they were just
protesters you were just they were just
people that wanted to go up and support
uh in whatever ways they could from our
region
and did you
um did were you in touch with anyone who
was in the leadership of the Ottawa
protests
I guess you'd have to Define what do you
mean by leadership of the Ottawa
protests
for example uh this commission has heard
from Chris Barber no Pat King
I think I had a brief exchange uh
just to ask if there was any sort of
connection between what was happening in
Windsor and what was happening in Ottawa
and I I got a categorical no response to
that
okay
and when you say you asked if there was
any sort of connection was this
um were you asking for support or was
this no is there an existence there were
so many rumors throughout the entire
week of oh there's convoys coming down
to Windsor and hundreds of vehicles
coming down to Windsor and I was just
trying to figure out like what perhaps
is actually going on here
um and what might be going on here in
Windsor
uh can you tell us about the rumors that
you were hearing about the connection
that there was constant rumors of
uh more trucks are on their way from
this location or that location
and so besides Pat King were you in
touch with somebody like tomorrow Leach
no
um
James bouter no any other person who's
sort of identified as a figure of a
leadership figure within the no Convoy
movement no
was disrupting cross-border trade one of
the reasons that protesters decided to
blockade the bridge specifically again I
could only speculate at the reasons why
other people decided to choose that
location
did you think that that was a reason
that the bridge was a good location for
protest it's certainly a strategic
reasonable a spot where you could Garner
some attention that might allow you to
to have your voices heard if that was
the intention
now we heard evidence yesterday about
children present at the protest is that
something that you saw
after nine o'clock at night no I didn't
see
I didn't see anybody that would be
considered a child I mean there might
have been some teenagers there but no it
was it was usually an adult crowd when
when I would arrive
okay
did you ever hear anyone suggest that
children could be used as human Shields
no
and
after the blockade ended
um after that first after the the
weekend where the police cleared out the
protest on the 12th and 13th
um were you aware of any discussion
about doing another protest at the
bridge
no I never heard about that
so there's you never heard of uh the
slogan taking back the bridge while the
police were kind of busy in Ottawa no
on on social media
ever saw that nope
and was there and there was no
discussion of reestablishing the
blockade after the injunction expired
not that I was aware of
is there anything that I haven't asked
you that you think is important for the
commissioner to know hmm
I think you've covered everything in my
my statement there
those are my questions
thank you
okay first uh the government of Canada
good afternoon Mr commissioner Mr
lasheed Cynthia Lau one of the council
for the government of Canada
Mr lasheed you had testified that you
co-owned a contracting business
you are the owner of a custom Cabinetry
business in Ontario correct correct and
if that has been in operation for 12
years as far as your co-ownership is
that right correct
and you offer services for Designing
building installing kitchens and
Cabinetry bathrooms and custom Living
Spaces correct correct
you would agree with me that your
business uses higher quality materials
would you not sure
and some of those materials aren't this
one please yes
go ahead
yes ma'am please ask the relevancy of
this line of questioning
you certainly can ask uh what's their
relevance of his business and the
quality of the materials this is a
background information pertaining to
the overall business and economics of
the Ambassador Bridge in the Windsor
area
so to exploring on the business area
that
that okay
sure thank you sir
go ahead and some of these supplies are
imported from outside of Canada would
you agree with me sure
and some of these supplies are also
imported through the Ambassador Bridge
Port of Entry would you agree with that
correct
you would also agree with me that
maintaining a healthy supply chain has a
significant impact on your revenues
would you not
yeah I would agree with that
and you would agree with me that an
interruption in the supply chain impacts
other businesses aside from your own
correct
and it would also impact the automobile
industry
I would assume so yes
you had testified that you've been a
resident of Essex County for
approximately 44 years
correct
and you also testified that it's a
strategic spot to Garner attention to
have your voice heard
correct
you are aware of the importance of the
Ambassador Bridge for the effective
efficient free flow of trade and goods
into and out of Canada and the U.S fair
to say sure
and you're also aware that the
Ambassador Bridge is a vital commercial
land border crossing are you not yes
and you would agree with me that traffic
disruptions will affect Canada's economy
and supply chain yes
before February 7th there was a slow
roll in the area of a bastard bridge for
a couple of weeks as I understand it is
that your understanding again I didn't
participate any of the slow rolls but I
was aware that they were going on at
certain times
right and I take it that
that you were following what was
happening in Ottawa mostly through
social media
yes
and a blockade was ultimately set up at
Ambassador Bridge on February 7th
again my only understanding is the
blockade was uh set up at Gerardo and
Huron Church on February 7th right and
you were present there on that date yes
do you also understand that the blockade
was inspired by the events in Ottawa
I can only assume that
and the vehicles that were parked were
parked on Huron Church Road which is the
main entrance and exit to the Ambassador
Bridge is that correct yes
and you had testified that on the first
evening February 7th you parked your
vehicle
on Gerardo and Huron church and they
walked in from the side street onto
Huron church is that right I did not
park my vehicle out here on Church in
Gerardo I would have been on a side
street far west from that intersection
all right
um so I understand that you are
at the site of the blockade from
February 7th to the 11th each evening
approximately eight to nine PM till
about midnight or one o'clock is that
that's correct
and for the other evenings I'm talking
about the 8th to the 11th were you
parked on Huron Church no
you were parked on the side street
beside streets or
perhaps like uh the strip mall plaza up
near uh
Tecumseh Road
uh east of the intersection at your own
church right and then you would attend
Huron Church by way of walking and you
would be one of the pedestrians on the
street is that fair to say I would
usually walk down the sidewalk on Huron
Church Avenue towards the college uh
intersection
and then would you situate yourself on
the street as a pedestrian at some point
during the evening I would just
intermingle with some of the people that
perhaps I I recognized that would be in
the general area
the general area of the street of yes if
you're in church and College Avenue
Jane
the time of the protests you are
communicating with other protesters by
way of chat applications and text
messages as I understand it is that
correct correct
and throughout these exchanges you were
communicating relevant information about
the status of the protests is that fair
to say
uh
uh relevant information I would just say
general information okay so general
information for example about planning
no
general information about developments
uh yes
just of what I was seeing
observations that are happening about
observations that's best
all right would you agree with me that
there was no one person or group in
charge of the protesters I agree yeah
and you'd further acknowledge that you
had described it as a leaderless
movement there was a diverse group of
protesters is that fair to say yes
there was no one directing the protests
no
and there's no agreement on strategy
not that I was aware of
and there was no agreement on which
intersections to block As I understood
it you said that some of the protesters
yet overheard wanted to block Wyandotte
Street Ambassador Bridge others wanted
to walk to come see and Huron But
ultimately there was no agreement
correct
and you would be making assumptions
about the goals of the protesters is
that fair to say that's fair yeah
the last day that you were at the
protest site was February 11 2022.
correct
and I understand from your interview
summary that at that point
you saw that law enforcement was
building up and you were encouraging
people to leave is that a fair
description yep I would say law
enforcement was building up prior to the
that Friday though
but by February 11th it had increased in
that building up of their their presence
and their involvement at the site is
that fair absolutely yes
and things were escalating in fact
escalating by what do you mean in
regards to the protesters or
he was escalating insofar as the
encouragement for people to leave and
that there was a perception that the law
enforcement was pending fair to say
there is definitely a perception and I I
had overheard a couple Law Enforcement
Officers suggest that maybe you've made
your point
uh it's time to go home now
and you did go home in fact you didn't
return on February 12th correct I did
not no
you would agree with me
that a potential unlawful protest did
not deter all of the protesters from
returning after February 11th correct
correct
correct yeah
because they didn't have a leader to
direct them that whom they followed
again that would be an assumption as to
why they decided to to be there Beyond
them
and it was also your belief that on
February 12th there would be skirmishes
or mass arrests correct
can you repeat how you want that quote
how you asked that question
sure on February 12th you had
anticipated as I understand from your
interview summary that there would be
skirmishes or mass arrests it became
apparent I mean you you saw the
militarized police vehicle uh staged
there and it kind of looked like there
was going to be an Abrupt end put to
this protest and some of your friends
were actually present at the site
of Huron Church on February 12th correct
they were there I'm not exactly sure
where okay and they told you what was
happening on the ground floor
I would have heard it from third hand
information after the fact
and some of that third had an
information that you heard was that
there were individuals who were shouting
slurs at police I had heard that that
was that was going on yes
you would agree with me that that could
increase the level of aggression of the
crowd
again that'd be an assumption
and police as I understand it we're
giving protesters the option to leave
the blockade area say that again they
were they weren't police were giving
protesters the option to leave I believe
so
but they didn't all leave did they
again I was not there that day
well did you hear from your friends did
all the protests again I would I would
have been watching it on on social media
like like anybody else to see what was
actually happening on that February 12th
okay so based upon what you saw you knew
that not everyone had left correct
foreign
starting February 7th I put to you that
no other vehicles except for emergency
vehicles could get through the Huron
Church area due to the blockade
oh well I mean certainly Vehicles came
came and went from that intersection
that I was witnessing on those first or
that second night
well the Windsor Witnesses would say to
the contrary
foreign
as I understand it you are motivated to
attend the protest because you are
skeptical of mainstream media correct
that was one of the reasons correct
what was the other reason
uh
I mean as as a small business owner that
uh has largely not been economically
impacted over the last couple years
um I wanted to support show support for
several of my other fellow business
owners who either lost businesses or or
were barely able to make ends meet
um who wanted to have their voices heard
um that had largely not
not had that opportunity or had been
silenced over the previous year
regarding these mandates that were
adversely affecting their ability to
conduct business
and I put it to you that the small
business owners would include people who
relied upon the supply chain being
viable coming through the Ambassador
Bridge Port of Entry I can't speak as to
how that would have affected other
business owners
and you wanted a first-hand account of
what was happening that's correct
you had testified as I understand it
that you never saw trucks backed up
across Ambassador Bridge beyond the
first night that's correct so that would
be February 7th correct yes
and as I understand it among other
things you do not do not believe that
the blockheed at The Ambassador Bridge
overall has been accurately portrayed
somewhat out
I'd like to turn to a video
PB dot can
dot four
zeros1800
underscore Rel period zero zero zero one
and I'm going to turn you to
video footage from V WDIV of February
8th Mr clerk could you please turn up
that video for me at timestamp 114.
see this is going to be pretty well the
end you're now up at the limit of your
time so you're going to have to be brief
okay
also developing that I protesters
against Canada's vaccine mandate forcing
the Ambassador Bridge to close that
group disrupted travel going into Canada
creating a huge backup on our local
freeways especially on I-75 the protests
all started about 10 days ago in Ottawa
with truckers calling themselves the
freedom Convoy the group opposes a
recent mandate requiring drivers
entering Canada to be fully vaccinated
or face testing and quarantine
requirements Tim Pamplin near the
Ambassador Bridge tonight with the
latest Tim the backups on 75 to the
Ambassador Bridge Toyota around about
three o'clock this afternoon and as day
turns tonight the situation hasn't
changed any thousands of truckers now
stranded on Detroit roads with nowhere
to go we got a green and bear it right
you know there's just
can't get upset I'm not the only guy
stuck out here but fortunately I do have
a sleeper cabin I feel for many of these
drivers that don't have that option from
Skyfall you could see the protesters on
the Canadian side in Downtown Windsor
blocking the road and essentially
shutting down the busiest border
crossing in North America and with the
bridge shut down the backup started
piling up here along 75 in the service
drive in this rig naves carrying a load
of bread for cereal destined for Toronto
it doesn't make sense to disturb the
rest of the public right so they they
shouldn't be blocking the borders and
they shouldn't be blocking the roads I'm
triple vaccinated I'm pro-vaccine but
I'm Annie mandate it's time that the
mandates are over it's time to people to
travel freely across the border both
sides
pause please
Mr lasheed you would agree with me that
this is an accurate video clip of the
impacts caused by the blockade at The
Ambassador Bridge would you not
I would agree that there is like the
last part of your statement that there
was an impact of the blockade at The
Ambassador Bridge
commissioner may I just show one one
minute video
okay but that'll have to be it thank you
very much for your Indulgence I'd like
to turn to PB dot can dot four
zeros1802 underscore Rel period 301
and timestamp 327.
this is a video of the February 10th
Blue Water Bridge area
oh and tonight three of the blockade at
The Ambassador Bridge with protesters
preventing all traffic from entering
Canada and tonight that protest over
Canada's vaccine mandate is now having
an impact on the Auto industry so-called
Freedom Convoy forced the shutdown of a
Ford plant in Windsor and cause General
Motors the plant in Delta Township to
cancel its second production shift
Wednesday the longer the blockade goes
the bigger the impact with the
Ambassador Bridge carrying 25 percent of
all trade between the U.S and Canada
with travel still partially shut down
there the Blue Water Bridge in Port
Huron has been overwhelmed Tim Pamplin
is there with the night Cam
going into day four of the blockade at
the border forcing thousands of semis up
94 and 69 to the Blue Water Bridge it's
unequipped to handle so much truck
traffic and the backups continue growing
thank you very much
um so I would put you that you would
agree that these are accurate this is an
accurate video clip of the impact caused
by the blockade at Blue Water Bridge
which is one hour and 12 minutes away
from ambassador
kind of I wasn't there to see see what
was going on and I can only assume that
blue water would have been far busier
because they were not able to cross at
The Ambassador Bridge thank you those
are my questions thank you Mr
commissioner for the time okay thank you
next is the Windsor Police Service
good afternoon Mr leishey my name is Tom
McRae and I'm here for the um
Windsor Police Service
um first I think you told my friend for
Canada that you parked at a strip mall
off Tecumseh
is that correct uh yes did you have
permission from the owner of that strip
mall to park there uh no thank you
I understand from your evidence I think
to again my friend from Canada that you
used chat applications in your
discussions with your friends sure uh
during this what chat applications did
you use ah just regular text messaging
or
Telegram
I I perhaps there's others but that
would be for the best of my recollection
how did you communicate with um Mr King
in Ottawa
uh
uh one of those two I would assume thank
you did you have
um
those messages available to you at the
time you were interviewed by commission
council at the beginning of October
ah that would have been on my phone yes
were you asked to give copies of those
Communications no have you produced any
documents within this commission hearing
beside your statement sure no thank you
I understand that at one point you said
you were not I want to get your evidence
fairly put
you had no goals in attending other than
I'm putting together your answers uh
seeing what was happening because you
didn't trust uh conventional media and
to support your friends is that fair
that's correct all right and you didn't
support conventional media
does that mean you did not uh observe
conventional media just through eclipse
or or third-party information that I
would have received
um I certainly would have seen Clips or
heard on the radio perhaps their
assessment of what was happening there
thank you uh and on the radio or through
these clips did you uh learn about the
injunction that was obtained by the city
of Windsor on the 11th no
so at no time did you learn about the
injunction that the city of Windsor just
overheard discussions that there was uh
talks of an injunction on that that
towards the end of that week
okay so you don't know and you did not
check to see uh whether or not that
injunction was issued no
you said you had friends who you were
supporting uh by your attending at the
uh
at the bridge site uh were any of these
friends in the Auto industry employed in
the Auto industry uh
no not specifically did you learn
through your review on social media or
otherwise uh of the views of
people in the automobile industry
repeat that question again well my
friend from Canada showed you a video
clip the second one which suggested that
there were automobile shutdowns the Ford
plant I think uh and another plant one
one in some Township in Michigan
um it's clear I put to you sir that the
automobile industry in particular was
being affected by the uh shutdown of the
Ambassador Bridge do you accept that
uh that would be an assumption I mean
I'm not involved in the automotive
industry but it would be a viable
conclusion okay so you don't know but
you don't disagree is that fair that's
correct all right did you discuss the
impact of the shutdown of any of these
Auto uh manufacturing facilities with
anyone who is employed at any of these
automobile manufacturing facilities no
did you were you concerned at all with
the impact of the shutdown of the
Ambassador Bridge on any of these people
employed at these facilities
again I was there I was there to support
friends that I know have been negatively
impacted over the last couple years
um in various professions uh regarding
these mandates that were being put in
place and at the time
um of this blockade of the Ambassador
Bridge there had been a shutdown with
the province-wise shut down a month or
so earlier is that correct
you'd have to get more specific for me
to answer all right I'll move on
yeah
foreign
excuse me Mr commissioner
if we could go to your witness statement
and I will get the number wrong
it is WTS
49 49 thank you
could we pull that up please Mr clear
uh could you go please sir to the bottom
of page five
that statement
and I'm focusing now Mr leysheet on the
events of Saturday February 12 2022.
just to make it clear to the commission
um you did not attend on that day that's
correct and I think your evidence was
and it is in the statement that you were
concerned that there would be skirmishes
or mass arrests
I just would say that it looked like
there was going to be an Abrupt end put
to the demonstrations that were going on
all week and like I stated before I was
only ever available or had an option to
attend late in the evenings and
it was pretty apparent that it it was
putting it was being put to an end and I
wasn't going to go back in the evening
on Saturday to be a part of that and you
were of that view even though your
evidence earlier as I understand it was
you didn't know that the police were
warning that there that these protesters
were engaged in criminal activity nor
did you know about the injunction is
that fair I just made my assessment
based on the the overall stance that the
police had taken towards the end of the
week that things were going to be put to
an end and the rumors that I had heard
swirling that
you know there was uh paddy wagons or
police vehicles staged to be able to uh
conduct Mass arrests
the second last paragraph of your
statement which is before you sir says
some of Mr Lee shade's friends were
present at the protest
so you're getting this second or third
hand is that correct yeah they told him
that some individuals were shouting
slurs at the police as they disclosed to
you the nature of the slurs that were
being shouted at the police they were it
was more the context that they weren't
sure of the particular individuals that
were were shouting these slurs at the
police because I didn't know any of them
and neither did they and I guess the
context was more regarding the nature or
the the purpose of why these slurs were
were being used and
that that would be the extent of it his
friends meaning your friends believe
that these were Jean provocative that
would have been their their uh
assessment that it was a possibility
sorry so when we say uh Jean Paul for
Qatar are we talking about false flag
operations in the language of Alex Jones
again this is just what I've he I'm
hearing third hand from from Friends uh
that we're saying that they they
observed this particular activity yeah
but what what was the motivation of
these Jean provocateur I it wasn't my it
wasn't not my uh I was not alleging
these I was just hearing this third
third hand information were they trying
to provoke the police into action in
order to uh
create a problem that would just grow
and grow or were they provoking people
in order sir I think we can all
speculate as to
here but if we could stick to the strict
dialogue that's within my Witnesses
knowledge please
I object to that objection by uh Mr
commissioner for some reason the
commission put this in the witness
statement it is fair cross-examination
fodder the commission is asking that or
the commission counselor asking pardon
me that the commission take this as
evidence and if it's second or third
hearsay well I guess that goes to wait
but it doesn't mean I cannot
cross-examine on it well you can ask him
about it but there's only so much he can
say so let I hear you but let's I'm just
trying to get as far as we can go with
what he can say
well thank you let's take it one
question at a time all right I'll take a
step back
sir your friends told you that these
arjon provocateur were trying to
antagonize the police into using
violence I think the context might be
that
the protest was peaceful for the entire
week and there was no reason for any of
the people that I knew or any of my
friends uh describing people that they
knew there to engage in violence that
was never the intention of anybody there
so it just seemed uh
perhaps out of the ordinary or it didn't
fit with the
the general stance of the protesters for
the entire week uh that I was I was
there or the five nights that I was
there
do you have any insight as to why this
stance changed at this time
again this was this would be the
speculation that perhaps
there was people that wanted to have uh
some sort of a violent end to this
um
five or six day demonstration and by
people do you mean the protesters
again this would be my speculation
hearing from them whether it was
protesters or if it was in fact agent
provocateurs uh that you've you've gone
over here that wanted to have some sort
of a violent clash with police because
for the entire week I was there there
was there was no uh violence being
directed towards the police and so it
just seemed from my friends that I had
discussed this with
um it didn't fit in line with the
the goals or reasons for any of the
people I knew that were there
did you disclose the identity of these
friends to commission counsel during
your interview
no
have they been do you know if they've
been interviewed by commission counselor
I have no idea
how did you come to be interviewed by
commission Council
uh I think we had a gathering of anybody
that was that was a witness to the uh
Ambassador Bridge demonstration in order
to offer a written statement of their
own witness testimony of what they saw
for the five or six days or however many
days any any of those people were there
when did that happen do you recall
sometime in the summer time I believe
late summer perhaps
thank you those are my questions thank
you thank you
next is the city of Windsor
Jennifer King counsel for the city of
Windsor we have no questions
thank you
the citizens for freedom jccf
Antoine diet for Citizens for Freedom
we'll see in our time to counsel for Mr
Rasheed for the shade
scene to whom
his lawyer okay thank you
uh
city of Ottawa
and dirty
for the city of Ottawa we have no
questions thank you uh Council for
former Chief slowly
um Nicholas the stuff no performer Chief
solely we have no questions thanks
OPP
commissioner this is Janine Percy for
the opp I have no questions for Mr
lasheed thank you Convoy organizers
uh good afternoon everybody for the
Convoy protesters and we have no
questions for this witness Okay so
it's uh
for Mr Lee Shields
Council go ahead
thank you sir
Mr Lee Shield
it's my understanding that you begin
attending uh protests when some of these
mandates were laid down by the
government do you know approximately
when that was
when I began attending or when the
mandates began
when you started attending protest
um I believe it'd be in 2021
okay and how many approximately can you
tell me some details about the protests
that you went to in the Windsor area
uh several of the uh rallies at the
Great Canadian flag at the end of uh
OLED Avenue and Riverside Drive
uh one of the uh rallies in front of the
health unit on Oleta Avenue and you know
various fundraisers that were being held
to support people who had you know
suffered Economic Consequences during
the past couple years
and would you say that the theme of
these protests was usually the same
um I mean some of the fundraisers might
have been geared towards something
specific but generally it was uh to
create awareness or give other people
the opportunity to to have their voices
heard or gather with other people that
maybe were sympathetic to
um
some of the adverse effects that they
had been experiencing over that last
couple years
and can you just expand on that what are
some of the things that people were
protesting about or gathering about
uh well certainly uh you know I have
friends uh in you know professions of
nursing or uh firefighting that had lost
their jobs uh to these mandates
um several small business owners who
have been pushed to the brink of
bankruptcy because they were no longer
able to conduct business due to the
mandates that had been
passed down from from federal or
provincial uh
politicians
so almost similar to trade stopping on
the bridge then some people were
claiming that their economic well-being
had been cut off because the mandates
certainly I would be there to support
individuals that I knew who were
negatively impacted over the last couple
years
so as a financial
for some of these people these people oh
absolutely there's a grave Financial uh
impact to to several people that I know
in uh small businesses and uh
other lines of work
now I noticed that Windsor
hosted some protests if you want to call
them that Gatherings and they had some
High Media profiles there I understand
that Chris Skye was there on August 28
2021 approximately how many people
attended that do you think just your
approximate I'd guess somewhere between
maybe 1500 to 2000 perhaps
was it well publicized
uh from from the standpoint of like
social media or are we talking Legacy
Media that's social media because it
wouldn't be on the mainstream correct
correct uh yeah it would be uh it would
be shared around the various uh social
media platforms
okay and is that the same way that the
protest on
um I believe it was September 18 2021
there are about a thousand silent First
Responders was that the same type of
deal was it promoted the same way
yep yeah I would say it was promoted on
social media it was at the same place
and there were there would likely be a
thousand or so um
other protesters or gatherers to support
the silent protests that the EMS and uh
Windsor fire department uh were
conducting
we're in the town
I went by say the Chris Skye protest or
I went past the Thousand protesters for
the First Responders would I pick up
what it was about
if you if you stuck around I guess to to
listen to the various speakers uh that
would be
giving their give giving their speeches
those particular days
okay
so do you believe that the mayor was
aware that these speeches were going on
when Chris Skye was in town or when the
Thousand uh protesters came out to
support the First Responders
I'm not sure where you're going with
this uh the mayor whether he knew about
the Chris guy yeah maybe I'm looking
like sorry I if I could be helped to
understand how this is going to help the
commission
publish the level of community
protests over time such the point that
it culminated in the bridge being
blocked
not sure that helps the commission but
go ahead okay
let me go with the more direct line here
did the mayor ever come out to any of
the protests that you were present at to
try to understand why people were
gathering no
okay
and did the protesters ever reach out to
your knowledge to the mayor to
communicate and say this is why we're
unhappy
I'd be speculating but yeah I believe
there were some people who had written
written emails uh uh or made social
media posts uh do the Merit Drew dilkins
of Windsor at the time
okay and that would be in line then with
the municipal policy on complaints so
then the protesters did bring the
complaint to the mayor sorry is that
giving are you giving evidence about
what the municipal
I mean I I don't know there's any
evidence about no I'm trying to
understand yeah if the protesters had
reached out to the mayor to clearly
communicate what their ambition was
through the protests yeah and he said he
was speculating and then you said
something about the complaint process
which is what I was curious about
there's I don't believe there's a
science about that no just to make sure
the protesters acted fairly in trying to
resolve the complaint first with the
mayor with the town before they set up
their protests it might help if you
establish the same protesters that were
doing it which may well be but I don't
know
so the group that was participating in
these protests the the three that we had
discussed there was Chris guy the silent
responders and then by the flake
were those all the same group were they
just kind of growing was it the
community of Windsor
I mean there was various groups that
were that were helping to organize these
uh events and and bring in different
speakers
um but yeah largely the same
same people were were
organizing or
having these gatherings
okay so I'm gonna take
a kind of take word now
um to the night of February 7th which is
I believe the first night of the
blockade at The Ambassador Bridge
correct correct yep okay
So when you say that this was a group
that was you know growing through time
and there were familiar faces there did
you recognize any of the people that
initially blocked the road where you
were no
I had never seen them before
okay
and what would you say like were there
emergency lanes that were left open
throughout the week or on this
particular February just on this one
night were there emergency lanes when
the block Cape was originally put down
so the original blockade that I was
witness to was at Gerardo
um where the vehicles had straddled here
on Church
um
I don't know that I would say particular
lanes were open I can I can a test that
I saw one truck driver who had suggested
to some protesters that he was diabetic
and he needed to move through the
traffic in order to
get his medication or whatever it was
that he needed and the protesters moved
their vehicles to allow him to
pass through the southbound here on
Church area
okay during the first night of the
protest did you see the police put down
any Jersey barriers like the concrete
barriers or obstruct any lanes
uh there was no Jersey barriers on that
first night no
okay and did they obstruct or close down
any lanes
they definitely secured several areas
around the perimeter with police
vehicles
okay and
any that the ratio was the been police
and Pro and protesters the first night
by the end of the evening there was in
my estimations substantially more police
Personnel there than there was
protesters
so granted that you know according to
previous consuls questions there were
Auto Plant shutdowns this is the busiest
border crossing in North America it's a
vital crossing of the border and it
controls the trade for millions of
dollars in our country back and forth
um do you think the police were capable
of shutting this down on night number
one
uh I believe if they would have chosen
if that was their objective on night
number one certainly the few vehicles at
Gerardo and the dozen or so protesters
that would have been there when I left
I believe they could have
shut that down if that was that was the
intention
okay thank you
and when you were at the bridge and I'm
just gonna speak generally about that
week that the days that you were there
of course what kind of an environment
was it how'd you feel there
uh it was just a peaceful uh Gathering
music food uh being shared
um
very cordial
and you said you weren't there during
the daytime so that's fine but when you
were there in the evening did you see
any families or not in the evening times
no
how did you know that families were
there in the daytime I mean I had other
friends that uh had either gone during
the day times or shared pictures and
videos of of you know children playing
soccer or um
oh you know having a festive atmosphere
with children and families during the
daytime hours
the children weren't there
um
did you ever witness anybody trying to
use or threatening to use a child as a
human shield no no I didn't see
it and did you witness any acts of
vandalism looting or disorderly conduct
by the protesters no no not quite the
contrary
did you see any illegal weapons no
did you see any registered weapons no
did you witness any acts of violence no
was there ever a time that you felt
unsafe while you were at the bridge
never
you feel like you were being surveilled
or watched
I mean it was pretty clear with the
there was drones that were circulating
overhead and
um some of the law enforcement personnel
there would have
cameras or smartphones I guess scanning
around the area to
gather their own intelligence I can
imagine
were you one of the people impacted with
your bank account was your bank account
Frozen uh so I lost access to my bank
account on February 18th
okay tell me about that what
exactly so I just I had I had gone to my
bank to deposit a uh a check from my for
from my business that I'd written to
myself and upon trying to use the ATM I
got a an error message or a message that
was not going to allow me access uh
into my bank account I I tried a second
ATM machine and got the same error
message
I tried uh my online banking when I got
home via my computer and continued to
get messages that were not allowing me
to access my my own bank account
and when did that change how long did it
last for so
I was able to access my account I
believe on the following Tuesday which
would be after the the Family Day
holiday weekend
so is that a period of about five days
then uh
oh four days give or take four days okay
did you ever find out why no
okay thank you
and just a follow-up question from a
previous uh council do you need to ask
permission from to park at a mall in
Ontario in the parking lot
that I'm aware of
okay thank you
so I'd like to go and revisit some um
earlier testimony from inspector Dana
early
and this was testimony I believe it was
earlier today or was it yesterday
and we've been talking about an
exclusion zone or essentially an area
that was controlled by the police are
you familiar with that area
yes
okay
and let's just Define it what did they
mean by that just so we can get that on
the record what was the exclusion zone
or the controlled area
I believe the controlled area was was at
the southern
Southern border where Tecumseh Road and
Huron Church Avenue intersect
play a video and the code on it is cff
six x zero
14.
and it's a multimedia file
excuse me uh commissioner
I'm sorry to interrupt as Janine kabersi
Council for the opp
now seeing that it is uh cff 14.
um this was a video that was provided to
us over the lunch break we only had an
opportunity to view it once Mr lasheed
had already started his evidence we have
no context for it we see in his witness
summary that he indicates that he did
not attend to the protest
um starting on the February 12th with
the action so I just wonder uh how it is
that this witness has any connection to
this video or can speak to it so that's
that's a concern and um
okay well maybe you can help us on why
this video is being played for this
Witness
because I'd like to Define where the
exclusion Zone was and how the crowd was
behaving how the police were interacting
and actually I'm sorry I did receive 2
000 pages of disclosure
about 24 hours ago so this was the one
thing that we asked to be submitted I
did provide it to council okay maybe you
could start by asking him how we knew
what the exclusion Zone was and go into
that but not sure showing a video is
going to assist uh what's the date of
this video and we don't know who took it
and it's obviously during a period he
wasn't there so I'm not sure how that
can all be done
well I think it's identifiable to this
incident and I believe it provides
geographical information that perhaps
could contradict previous testimony
well I'm not sure we don't do we know
when this video was taken
and I believe it was
and so when was it taken
I believe it was taken on the 13th okay
and uh you could start by asking him if
he was there on the 13th when this video
was taken
he was not no well I think the video
should have been put to someone who
could speak to it
the video
the thing is that there was double the
evidence sent out the other night so he
went through it all and this was the
response to the one to the Thousand well
two thousand pages I received because it
puts the exclusion Zone into context and
it contradicts previous testimony but
your counsel to this witness you're not
a party so I'm having some trouble with
this uh
so I'm sorry if you're gonna ask him how
he knows the exclusive the exclusion
Zone and he can explain what it is but
I'm not going to allow the video to go
to this okay
perimeter did a perimeter walk around
what tell me what you saw
um the police earlier I'm going to
clarify this first the police earlier
had stated that they were clearing
certain areas and there were areas that
were under their control
and the question I have and the reason I
want this video for it is because I want
to know
um is the corner the southeast corner of
takumsa and Huron Church Road part of
the exclusion area to your knowledge
to my knowledge the exclusion Zone ended
at the intersection of Huron church and
Tecumseh Road East
okay
and was there any footage that you're
aware of that showed violence outside
where the police were tackling people
outside the exclusion Zone
again I wasn't there I wasn't there on
the days of Saturday and Sunday when
this when the police were putting an end
to the demonstration
okay but I believe there was videos of
these arrests taking place in in areas
uh in the general vicinity
okay and to your knowledge then uh the
southeast corner where the gas station
is I believe it's a shell that is not
included in the area they said was under
control
no I believe there they were they were
controlling up to Tecumseh Road and
pushing protesters uh onto the other
side of Tecumseh Road outside of the
exclusion Zone
okay those are my questions sir
any uh re-examination
uh no there's no re-examination thank
you
okay just I'm just trying to understand
you you say you know the exclusion Zone
how do you know that I would I would be
saying I know it based on previous
testimony that's been given uh
yesterday perhaps so you don't know you
just listened to the testimony yesterday
I guess the exclusion Zone was never
something that I was told when I was
there at the event I'm just basing it on
where I saw the police have their
barricades set up in the general area
around the entire demonstration okay so
you didn't really know you're just
speculating it would have been something
I would have discovered after the
demonstration was over
from listening to the testimony here
from listening to the testimony here and
perhaps videos on social media that
occurred after I was no longer
participating in attending the
demonstration there were social medias
educating you on the exclusion zones
I think that when you saw
um like video assessment of the end on
the Saturday and Sunday they were
they were basically showing where
protesters were being pushed out of the
area that was going to be secured
for
them to be able to reopen here on Church
Avenue to truck traffic onto the bridge
okay and then just a question you were
there uh for a few days uh the evenings
rather were
is it uh
news to you or did you only find out
today that there were plant uh
plants shutting down and people getting
laid off because of the bridge
no I knew that there was there was
negative impacts to
businesses uh in the Windsor and greater
areas Beyond Windsor
as a result of the blockage at The
Ambassador Bridge and that didn't
concern you
I mean I've been concerned over the past
couple years of the impacts that were
happening to our businesses from a whole
bunch of different uh for a whole bunch
of different reasons
so more impact was not a concern to you
uh I mean I'm I'm concerned for
anybody's businesses that are negatively
impacted
but to to gauge whether one is more
severe than another uh
that wasn't something that I really did
okay thank you thank you for your
testimony you're free to go thank you I
think we'll take the morning break now
thank you Council for your assistance
um so we'll take the morning break or
the afternoon break I keep saying the
morning break I'm sorry
um obviously I only work half days
um the so we'll come back in 15 minutes
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
thank you
foreign
previous weeks
order a lot
the commission has reconvened the
commissioner
Ben Hogan boss
Mr van houtenbos will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm the Bible please
foreign
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Marco van
yougenboss
m-a-r-c-o-b-a-n-h-u-i-g-e-n-b-o-s
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God
thank you
thank you
so for the record Alexander Hein
commissioned Council Mr commissioner the
first thing I'd like to do is pass
over to my friend Martin regman who is
Mr van hug and boss's lawyer who has an
objection to me
good afternoon commissioner Martin
Raymond for the record
Mr van hugen boss has recently been
charged in a relationship in relation to
matters that he may be asked questions
about in these proceedings
namely the events in kuzo Berta that
took place between January 29th and
February 15th of this year 2022.
on Friday November 4th 2022 Mr van
hugenbos elected to be Tried by a jury
of peers
was summoned to testify this afternoon
his testimony is compelled and subject
to Nationwide publication
Mr van human boss invokes the protection
afforded to him under the Canada
Evidence Act specific section 5-2 as
well as the related provisions of the
Alberta Evidence Act to protect his
interests
against any self-incrimination he also
benefits from and seeks the protection
of section 13 of the Canadian chart of
rice and freedoms in his anticipated
testimony
for the record he objects to answer each
and every question on the grounds that
his answers May incriminate him or may
or could be used to establish any
liability in criminal or civil
proceedings he is compelled to provide
answers
and we can proceed with the questions
thank you
ahead so Mr clerk I'll start with asking
you to pull up Mr van hugen boss's
statement of anticipated evidence which
is SAE 703
so this is the statement of anticipated
evidence that we sent you a few months
ago for your review is that right
correct and have you had a chance to
review this statement
yes and would you like to make any
amendments to it nope
thank you so Mr van hugenboss you're
originally from Holland is that correct
correct and when did you move to Canada
in April of 1996
and I understand that you currently live
in Fort McLeod in Alberta is that right
correct
and what do you do for a living
I um I'm sales I'm an owner in South
Country doors and my role there is um
to run the business and as a sales
manager
and so you were City councilor for Fort
McLeod at the time of the freedom Convoy
protests in January and February 2022 is
that right correct and I still am
and so I understand that you
participated in the protest activities
that occurred in Coots Alberta is that
right correct in your statement of
anticipated evidence you said that the
protest commenced as a slow roll Convoy
on January 29th and that you joined on
that day is that right yes what
motivated you to join
the
um provincial
mandates the prior years and the Federal
border mandate as the cherry on the top
that
um broke the camel's back in regards to
the residents of Alberta and their views
on covet
and that it was that there was so much
frustration that
we expressed that through slow roles and
similar activities
when you say the Border mandates you
mean the trucker vaccination
requirements correct okay and
different slow roles converge in
Lethbridge I understand on January 29th
and you were planning on driving from
there to Coots is that right yes there
was a staging area at the Flying J
and
um smaller convoys or individual convoys
came from all parts of Southern Alberta
and possibly further and so you met up
with this Convoy in Lethbridge in your
own vehicle yes that was a semi-truck
pickup truck that was a pickup truck
you also said in your statement of
anticipated evidence that participants
generally understood through social
media posts that the plan was to
converge on Highway 4. and then drive
down to Coots and Which social media
posts were you specifically talking
about
I was aware of a social media page that
was being shared on Facebook
okay so Mr Clark if we could pull up
alb401677
and so just by way of background this is
an email exchange data January 26 uh
between a cbsa official and a government
of Alberta official so Mr Clark If you
just scroll down a little bit that's a
little bit more perfect and so Mr
McCauley from the government of Alberta
says that the cbsa to the cbsa official
that there is online activity regarding
a January 29th Convoy to Coots
associated with the brother broader
trucker protests understanding that that
means the Convoy to Ottawa and he links
a website entitled Freedom Fighter
nation and a Facebook group for the
Lethbridge Freedom Central do you see
that there correct did you come to learn
about the Convoy through either of these
websites
um no I was made aware of it through
individuals I knew sharing it on
Facebook I was not aware of this the
first time I see Freedom Fighter Nation
um but the freedom freedom Convoy and
freedom Left Bridge is is
I I might have seen it through that or
through somebody sharing that
information
great and if we can just scroll down to
page two I'm just going to show you a
flyer and this was shared by I believe
Lethbridge Freedom Central so when you
were seeing some of your friends sharing
on Facebook about this event were you
seeing this flyer nope this is the first
time I've seen this one but I imagine
there was different versions out there
okay and was it your understanding that
the plan was just to slow roll down to
Coots from Lethbridge and then go home
or was the plan always to blockade the
Port of Entry
there was
um the the Slow Roll was definitely the
focus but I believe through the
um
uh through the accumulation of I believe
the previous slide had 5 000 vehicles or
whatever the the amount was we knew it
would result in a legit logistical
Nightmare and uh that may have been the
intention to create a an inconvenience
So when you say you knew when there were
5 000 Vehicles how were you aware that
there were five thousand vehicles on the
highway sorry I go back to the previous
slide that was the report from cbsa and
the RCMP that speaks to the amount that
I'm just going to use whatever that
amount was okay and I think for the
record actually the cbsa and their
institutional report said there were 1
000 Vehicles sorry one thousand views
yeah thank you and
we're going to stay on this document Mr
clerk if we could just go down to page
three
so this is a flyer that was posted
um on one of the websites linked by the
cbsa official and it says lockdown Coots
border trucks and vehicles all over
Alberta planning to head for Coots
starting January 29th staying there
until all mandates and restrictions are
lifted do you see that I do it also says
calling all semis trucks SUVs cars
meeting point Flying J lothbridge which
you referenced earlier 5 a.m order
shutdown on this day that albertans hold
the line to take back our given freedoms
do not budge do not move do not
surrender did you ever see this flyer
this is the first time I've seen this
so was it your personal intention to
block the border and not give up until
all the mandates and restrictions were
lifted as is stated in this flyer it was
never my intention to block the Border
it was always Our intention to create a
inconvenience at the Border in the
afternoon of January the 29th but you
would agree based on this flyer that it
was some people's intention at least
based on this flyer I could see that
there were people who would have these
intentions
okay so you drove down to Coots on
January 29th and because this is you're
the first protester or sorry the first
witness to speak to Coots and not
everyone
um Like Us is from Alberta we're just
gonna pull up the Coots protest map
which is an interactive map and I'm just
going to show for the public and the
commissioner's benefit the
route from lothbridge down Highway 4 all
the way to Coots so do you see that
there correct and is it the route that
you took
yes other than I would have I wouldn't
have started a I would have started in a
former Cloud okay right but you
converged in Lethbridge and then the
general Convoy drove down to Coots yes
okay so we expect to hear evidence from
the mayor of Coots that he observed the
RCMP escorting the Convoy to the
eventual location of the blockade the
intersection with Highway 500 1.3
kilometers before the border crossing
would you agree with that
if if that's what happened I would agree
with that I was not at the front of the
Convoy so I did not see the rcmps score
does okay so you're not aware that the
RCMP was escorting the Convoy at all I
was aware of the presence of RCMP
because they they were there
um you know
the traffic was heading south and
occasionally we'd see RCP fly by or RCMP
going north or so the presence of RCMP
was noted but I I was not aware we
received an escort to the Border okay
um
and if Mr clerk we could then click on
Coots U-turn and unclick directions
thank you and then we'll just zoom in to
Coots and that's for the benefit of the
public and the commissioner just to see
sort of what the Coots Village and the
Port of Entry look like
um so I understand that some Vehicles
when they got down to Coots and if we
could just zoom in a little bit more
made a u-turn
at the point that's the blue point
on the corner of Highway 500 and Highway
four is that right
correct that is the intersection that
you can accept our inner access the
Hamlet or Village of Coots and being the
last major intersection before the
cbsa and that's where the Convoy was
turned around to position it back
northward
okay so some Vehicles did the U-turn and
drove back out but others I understand
stayed in Coots and parked there is that
right uh
that intersection became very busy as
the Convoy neared Coots
coming around the corner here after the
railroad tracks
in between the highways there is a a
scale house like there's
um a commercial inspection facility
and when you say a scale house you mean
to weigh trucks that are going through
the port of entries correct in you know
trucks going south and trucks coming
coming north right
[Music]
um
they open the scale further slowing and
restricting traffic
which in and of itself caused a uh quite
the backup
but after the scale
individuals could
turn around and further up once they
once they were back in Milk River or
close to they could rejoin the Convoy
and continue to loop back and forth but
there was also a staging area and not
staging it became a staging area of just
people watching this event from the in
the ditches you know it was It was a
there's a lot of people in one location
so there was no designated area but it
was a lot of vehicles and a lot of
trucks everywhere in the staging area
that you referenced is that sort of on
or around the yellow point which I
understand doesn't it's where the
protesters were predominantly located uh
that would be the green points the green
point so that's The Smuggler Saloon
correct and behind the Smugglers is a
very unofficial truck stop but it's just
a wide open gravel parking lot
and for the benefit of of everyone here
could you just describe where some of
the semi trucks that were part of the
Convoy ended up in relation to the
yellow and green point so between sort
of where the the I guess that's the
northbound lane and The Smuggler Saloon
um at what at what particular time when
on January 29th we're still on January
29th during the movement of traffic or
after traffic after traffic traffic had
arrived uh well there was I believe the
the backup was halfway to Milk River on
both sides like
um Saturday night
a lot of the Thousand hadn't left you
know these were semis and they stayed
for the night
um due to the backup
created by the border or not the Border
sorry the the intersection and
everything around the intersection
and so were there semi's pickups sort of
piled up uh right there that was causing
this
um this traffic jam from Coots to Milk
River yes what did that look like
it looked like semis and uh semi's
parked through the intersection
preventing the flow of traffic
and where were you at this time
um I was
I would say in the vicinity of the the
blue the yellow the green
I was in the area so you sort of parked
your pickup truck and you were wandering
on foot or were you in your vehicle
stopped
my pickups were initially
um
in the parking lot on the green like
Behind the Green Dot
okay so we're gonna
move forward then to January 31st so by
January 31st I understand that some
Vehicles had left
um Coupes that either had returned home
or gone further up Highway four and I'm
referring or I'm getting this
information from the cbsa's
institutional report that said that
there were 176 Vehicles sort of left
around that time does that occur with
your recollection yeah possibly yeah
okay so the rest of the 1000 Vehicles
had pretty much gone gone home correct
it was never the intention to
um to remain
well right but we did establish earlier
that it might have been some people's
intentions to remain some of those
people making up the 166 Vehicles that's
behind right
so Mr clerk if we could pull up pbsc can
four zeros one four seven three
and so this is a an email from the
commissioner of the RCMP uh Brenda lucky
to the minister of Public Safety Marco
Mendocino the deputy minister of Public
Safety at the time was Rob Stewart and
the president of the cbsa who at the
time was John sowski could you slow down
I apologize for the interpreters
thank you commissioner and the date here
is January 31st do you see that yes and
if we just scroll down a little bit
a little bit more
so
at the bottom of the page
we see that point right there that says
Highway 4 so that's the third Point down
under current status
so it says Highway 4 to and from the
Canadian side of the border crossing at
Kutz Alberta remains completely blocked
the blockade primarily the semi-truck
blocking the northbound lane with
smaller truck reinforcements is being
controlled by Splinter groups the
organizers of the Coots protests are
distancing themselves from the Splinter
groups she then says that the rcmp's
consultative conflict management group
which is the rcmp's equivalent of a
police liaison team
continues to engage protest participants
however the engagement from the
organizers has diminished and the
Splinter groups have not been receptive
do you see that there yes
and so at this point had you established
yourself as a spokesperson for the
protesters this is on January 31st no
do you know who she's talking about when
she says organizers
I believe the individuals that would
have built the the posts the the two
previous Pages
um that organized the slow role and
invited people to participate in this
protest the two previous Pages meeting
that email that we saw with the two
links to the website in the Facebook
group is that what you mean correct yeah
okay so Lethbridge Freedom Central and
the other website
um
so at this point you I understand that
you had Communications with the police
and specifically ccmg officers later on
and we'll get to that in a minute but at
this point on January 31st have you had
any contact with the rcmp's CM ccmg
officers
not that I'm aware of but it might have
been in passing without any with outside
of any official goal you know we were
never
hiding the RCMP had full ability to walk
through our midst and to drive drive
around and etc etc it wasn't a
you know we didn't blockade RCMP from
engaging with us okay but it wasn't as
though you were engaging with the RCMP
on behalf of the protesters no there
there was very little structure being so
organic of a protest
um we all converged as individuals and
possibly as as groups smaller groups
from different municipalities to to this
location and from there
um it speaks to Splinter groups but
it there was there was no groups that
were previously engaged in anything that
were part of this it was when I say
groups it would be you know uh six
people came from the town of Coaldale
and they're familiar with each other and
they drove in a convoy together so
they're going to band with each other if
they if they're all sudden with
individuals they don't know right you
stick to your own until you become
familiar with each other
right so because it was like an organic
protest a sort of a grass roots movement
with different people from all over
Alberta when she says Splinter groups
you also don't know what she's referring
to
so when I think Splinter groups I think
we're talking more in different
positions different views on where we
were at that time uh in regards to the
Border or the highway was blockaded by
multiple trucks not just one
um they may had the perception that if
one truck moved traffic could flow but
essentially it was a combination of
vehicles that created the
um at the uh the inconvenience at that
in intersection
okay so let's then move to the next day
which is February 1st um and also
February 2nd so at this point had the
RCMP set up checkpoints
on Highway 4 as well as Highway 500
which is the highway that we saw earlier
with the map
I don't believe that the checkpoints
were set up at that time
okay do you know when the RCMP set up
those checkpoints I believe they set up
the checkpoints
um
later in the day on February the 1st
okay later in the day on February 1st
yes traffic was able to free flow back
and forth
um you know people came people left on
the Sunday which is
the the 30th
31st yeah sorry I believe they didn't
they set up checkpoints
on the later in the day on the 31st not
the first okay on the Monday okay so Mr
click I'll just ask that you zoom out on
this map
uh just so that everyone can see when we
say checkpoints
um we're referring to the points in red
Mister van hugenbos is this Accord with
your recollection of where the
checkpoints established by the RCMP were
this is this is some there was more
every
every dirt road leading to Highway 4
would would have had a checkpoint
so these may be
the
you know
the majority of the gravel roads but
there were more entrances and exits that
were being monitored by the RCMP or
stakeholders in this so
okay so there were some protesters still
in Coots and if we zoom in Mr clerk to
the point at the top near Milk River
where there's a yellow and a red so this
is a checkpoint by the RCMP in red
um were you ever aware of this
checkpoint
and so the red
became a so these these checkpoints were
all established when this this red
um checkpoint on the highway was was was
created
because
the traffic the most convenient way to
coot was on the highway going you know
the speed limit 110 kilometers an hour
but if you were to hit that checkpoint
any Alberta from this area would take a
side road and take five minutes and make
their way to Coots
through a back road Etc that's when all
the additional checkpoints in the
previous slide were established
so the goal of this red checkpoint was
to prevent the Coots blockade
from from being built up with more
trucks and more more protesters okay so
it was your recollection that this was
sort of one of the first or the main
checkpoints that was established I
believe they would have all been
established at the same time there would
have been an RCMP objective to prevent
the public from having easy access to
Coots what about one of the main
checkpoints it is definitely the main
checkpoint it is the main checkpoint
okay thank you and
um you just alluded to this but
this checkpoint had the effect of having
sort of a buildup of traffic that led to
a second location of protesters which
um
is identified by the the yellow point if
you could please sort of walk us through
how that happened
um and what that looked like from your
perspective
so
as previously mentioned the slow roll
and and its possible Intentions by
different participants of this low role
and protest resulted in in the blockade
and once the weekend was over
and it was still there it I'm not I
wouldn't say it hit the news right away
but it became through social media
platforms through alternative media and
possibly even through MSM it um
it
became
uh something newsworthy and it attracted
individuals
it attracted individuals so these
individuals would
come to Coots and essentially bolster
the ranks of of the protesters Etc it
just grew and grew
the RCMP
and their their intentions was to
prevent this as a result this Milk River
blockade is what it's called
or Milk River protest was formed and the
amount of individuals that Converge on
this site was initially vehicles from
the surrounding areas within an hour or
two parked in their trucks parked in
their cars parked in there
whatever they were using to get there
all pointing South looking to get to
Coots with the RCMP get in in the way of
their ability to do that very quickly
Camp was set up and
um
it it became something similar to to
Coots but in support of Coots you know
it was always the attention to get to
Coots right that was their goal
right
so there was a
Milk River protest Milk River blockade
around check that checkpoint which is
checkpoint 10 for the record and there
was a secondary location in Kutz but the
idea is that the Milk River protesters
were there because they wanted to get to
Coots to join correct okay and you were
personally located in Coots at this time
is that right I had the ability to no at
that time uh until this was established
I was in codes correct yeah okay
and so we're still on February 1st and
2nd I understand and
um you'll provide more clarity on this
that some protesters got around
checkpoint 10.
using either tractors or other vehicles
uh to get to Coots and this led to an
enforcement effort by the RCMP could you
please describe what that looked like
what that event was from your point of
view
so the events were the enforcement
effort commenced on the First on Tuesday
in Coots
um
being organic in nature the trucks were
on the highway on both lanes going north
and south but in that particular area
the lanes were actually
Facing East and West
if you want to go back to that slide I
could explain that um and sure yeah we
could go down to back down to Coots
right so so right around the
um
commercial inspection site you can see
the highway here is actually east to
west for all of a mile
from the intersection from the yellow
bullet point till about the welcome to
Alberta sign
at that time that Highway both lanes
both directions was
full of motorized vehicles anything from
uh tractor trailers to trucks to
whatever was on the highway
and the RCMP staged close to the
railroad with I would say 100 officers
and started to commence enforcement in
the form of
knocking on the vehicles the the
truckers or the protesters were in there
in their vehicles and asking them to
leave or
face arrest
so one by one they
it was a pretty obvious decision for
most you know it was time to leave
they were able to work their way down
one lane truck by truck without any
ability to without us get giving us any
ability to
respond or or do anything about it right
we were watching it from from our
vehicles and we've seen the RCMP come
closer
this was all being streamed on many
social media platforms Facebook tick
tock
Telegram and others
so you have these individuals at The
Milk River blockade who are looking to
get to Coots
who have been and we're talking it was a
balmy weekend
you know 10 degrees into January but
Monday morning the weather turned sour
and it was -30 that first week
so you're talking about individuals who
are looking to get to Coots who are in
there camped out in their vehicles in
extreme temperatures
they are seeing enforcement action and a
lot of these individuals were farmers
like they quit there was a lot of
equipment there these were neighbors
these were people we knew or were
acquaintances to others at Coots since
the 29th
so they see this happening on their
screens
and without us being aware we've seen
the video after they proceeded to
essentially hit the ditch or go around
the
the police barricade which was on I
believe it was parked on the pavement
and they had been civil in regards to an
uh obeying that that uh blockade but
once they've seen the RCMP enforcing in
Coots
um obviously it starts with one or two
and they're as follows but it most of
that blockade was able to
to
Traverse that most of sorry most of the
supporters were able to Traverse the
blockade and make their way down the
highway both lanes
um toward Coots and and there was I
don't know if there's videos as evidence
but there there was multiple videos
shared of that event as well when you
say the Milk River protesters could see
the enforcement action at the theater
CMP was doing in Coots which prompted
them to try and sort of go around the
barricade to join up you mean through
social media right they didn't have line
of sight themselves no no there was no
line of sight it would have been they
came to our assistance it's essentially
the term and that's because the Milk
River
um blockade was about 20 kilometers
north of the Coots Port of Entry is that
right correct
okay so I understand that then on
February 2nd this sort of all came to a
head and there was a bit of a standoff
you could call it between the protesters
and the RCMP is that right correct so as
I was in my truck uh driving around in
this this this area of the highway
that's that's heading east to west just
you know looking at the situation and
thinking you know this this will be over
in hours
and all sudden we see through and it was
it was a blizzard we see this these
trucks and these pickups and these
tractors come through the blizzard
from nowhere and
we were the protesters were able to
coordinate a barricade instead of trucks
on a highway that they could work one
two three we were able to form a
barricade essentially fence defense
ditch to ditch which now gave us
the ability
well which which gave us the ability to
form a line and
have have a standoff with the RCMP and
what did that look like
it was a peaceful standoff the RCMP and
the protesters never came within
um
I would say
50 meters of each other
so initially when the equipment rolled
in the RCMP retreated because it was it
was hectic you know tractors came in
um through the ditches on the highway
and out of nowhere was a surprise to
them as much as it was to us I imagine
they may have heard heard about it as it
blue as they blew the barricade in Milk
River they would have had 10 minutes
more notice than we did
through their official channels but when
it came in they retreated back to the
sheriff buses and a bit of the mobile
command they had set up on the highway
and I would say 20 minutes later they
commenced a second effort
um with either the same amount or
additional support
and
um
on the first attempt most people were in
the saloon it was cold and a few people
were just monitoring monitoring the
situation on the second attempt
the protesters
uh came outside and we formed we stood
in front of the equipment we formed a
line and we we sang Oh Canada and we
just held a we it was it was a Face-Off
it was at a point where
this was where we would all
um be arrested and and systematically
removed or
or the alternative which is what
happened and the RCMP retreated
on their second attempt and that's where
the enforcement action stopped right and
and part of the resolution of this I
understand is that two RCMP surgeons
I believe surgeons tullock and Switzer
who are ccmg officers came to The
Smuggler Saloon to speak with the
protesters and see if they could sort of
negotiate a resolution is that right
correct so so uh Greg and Troy sorry I'm
gonna I'm gonna that's that's their
first name that's that's I'll stick to
that because there was two groups and
just for clarity when you say Greg and
Troy you mean Greg tulloch and Troy
Switzer correct right they had been I
believe they were part of the initial
slow roll you know the RCMP was aware of
the Slow Roll so they had officers and
they had sent staff down to monitor the
situation so they had been there from
from the onset of of of the protest
um
initially the RCMP took the heavy-handed
approach regarding enforcement
um
the failure of that resulted in a
direction from RCMP to to
RT more of a negotiation stance and even
that they came in Fairly heavy they
showed up in this loan and they
essentially ordered us off off the
highway and that was met with a very
decisive no by everybody
involved
and but you were still able to resolve I
understand that you would keep one lane
open uh in the Northbound lanes and then
one traffic lane opened in the
southbound light is that right so due to
due to the situation on the ground and
the enforcement action we were aware the
RCMP
you know our fight was never the RCMP
that was the enforcement we were looking
to get the attention of our province of
the government we've been trying not
successfully to do that for two years
um
two years or 18 months at that time
and obviously we knew the RCMP would
respond and commence with enforcement
and possibly communication but the RCMP
was never that was never
when I say
the struggle that wasn't they were never
part of that they were automatically
involved
so they
um they came into the into the saloon
and we worked out an agreement which
also came from a position of
we we
have to
I wouldn't say Retreat we have to work
with the RCMP due to our position that
our position was based on how many
trucks and how many people do we have
right strength and numbers
um where you know if we're have two bold
of a position without the equipment and
the trucks and the people to back it up
the RCMP May enforce
um if if if we open up some Lanes we go
where we're we look like a leak then we
are a legal protest
um in the eyes of the Arts in the in the
view of the RCMP and they may
let us stay to fight and when I say
fights when you know I don't want to use
that in in a in a term other than we
were there
um to fight another day
um and that is what happened
I believe either late in the evening of
the first or the morning of the second
we through communication with the RCMP
and obviously the concerns of the
village of Coots by having most of their
access restricted
we actually there are three things there
was
something that happened before there was
unintended
truckers that were blockaded behind our
trucks that were looking to go south
reefers and they had spent the weekend
and we had let them go
because it was never you mean commercial
vehicles that were not protesters
correct they were they were held
um
on that Highway behind behind the the
trucks that were blockading
traffic right they were there it's not
like we gave
and it's not like there was a sign of
Lethbridge that said um future blockade
please don't proceed down this highway
so there was an unintended
um there was truckers that were
unintentionally stuck behind this and we
it was never Our intention so we let
them either turn around or go south
this would have been um
the Monday
this would have been before the
enforcement action we would have already
cleared out the trucks okay so like
January 31st exactly so that's I just
wanted to make that note it's not
necessarily relevant but it matters that
we were never there to
um
cause grief to unintended participants
back to the
Lanes opening up we were getting we were
in discussions with
residents School Board
Etc to allow the buses free flow to
allow traffic you know the residents in
and out
all of that plus we were in no position
to hold the highway shut so we opened up
a lane on each side okay and I
understand that from then that point
forward you sort of became the main
point of contact for the RCMP is that
right
um
that was never enough
that that was never officially
you know you're that you're the point of
contact
UM
I think that that comes back to
more who I am my character my position
as as a as a town counselor my ability
to articulate well all of that put me in
a position where I was
um most um
I would say skilled I've never been I've
never I've never been trained for this
but in this case most skilled to to deal
with uh the RCMP and any other conflict
and would you say you had a good
relationship with the RCMP officers that
you spoke to
the RCMP would attest to this but we had
a phenomenal working relationship we
agreed we agreed on many things and we
disagreed on others but we never stopped
communicating and you texted you called
was it through email how did you
communicate
um it would have been through text and
call
I understand that some officers also
came to The Smuggler Saloon which had
sort of been established as the
headquarters by that point to sort of do
check-ins with you is that right
um most of the most of the interaction
happened away from The Smuggler Saloon
um the in-person interaction the
in-person interactions
um I I do know they I would look for
them away from this Saloon but they
always look for me in the saloon which I
always knew it gave them the ability to
walk through the saloon and make notes
and check up on us without as a as a you
know hitting two birds with one stone
they're coming to talk to me but they're
also checking out the situation inside
the building which we never restricted
them we were never hiding anything uh
they said they stood around the fires
with us you know they were offered meals
Etc
I don't know what protocol is whether
they declined or whether they accepted
but um
there was no official
meeting point it was very organic and
the best conversations happened on the
side of the road
um in the vehicle when it was colder or
on the back of the tailgate when it was
warmer so
and so I understand we'll just touch on
this very briefly that there was only
one time where Communications between
you and the RCMP officers failed and
that was on February 12th when some you
were out of contact or you didn't have
cell service and some excavators were
damaged by the police by accident is
that right correct so now we're jumping
ahead to the second week the first week
was definitely a strong and we'll come
back to the first week but just for the
purpose of the excavator event if you
could just speak to that yeah so just a
little bit of beat up to the event
um
it was always a matter of position in
regards to us in regards to the RCMP
um we had to respond to the RCP in such
a manner that they wouldn't enforce or
felt the need that all ability to
resolve the situation through
communication had failed so they would
enforce but at the at the same time
maintain enough of a position
to stay that eventually we got we caught
the attention of of the Alberta of the
provincial government
and that was it was it was a tricky
business to
to to maintain that position where the
one side wants to want you off the
highway yesterday and and we have to
stay on that highway just long enough to
possibly enter in
um and they go not necessarily
negotiations but to to open up lines of
communication with the provincial
government
so
um
we we brought in trucks we we brought in
tractors and when we say we people
brought tractors it was very organic we
never said no to anybody that wanted to
come and support us we came from
anywhere in Southern Alberta or Southern
sorry western Canada
Ottawa was obviously the initial draw in
the event here was to support Ottawa
at the same time that Ottawa roll or
that the freedom Convoy rolled into
Ottawa we rolled into Coots
but
this was for most people a lot more
accessible than Ottawa for myself as
well
so the excavators were for us a very
symbolic thing
can you just for those who don't know
what an excavator is just describe what
that is briefly uh Ohio so it's a
construction it's a piece of equipment
that is used for earth work
um
uh it's it's called an excavator so I I
imagine most people
know what an excavator has ability to uh
to to dig trenches Etc
right and so there were a few and they
were Flying Flags is that right no that
was the intention so these excavators
were positioned
a couple miles away from Coots
um and all it was was a distraction and
and it definitely became a distraction
but the intent was to
to
to catch the eye of the RCMP
um
net we never could have imagined the
actual response we got so these these
pieces had to be hauled in individually
one at a time so we got permission from
the adjacent the the property adjacent
to the highway to to do this on their
property
and we slowly drove them in like they
got unloaded off the road and then they
had to get walked in and they probably
they probably go about two kilometers an
hour it's a very heavy piece of
equipment and over I believe on the so
the Friday would have been the um
sorry we're on the uh
12 11. I believe the 10th is that the
Friday
I believe so and and I think just for
the sake of time maybe if we could fast
forward a little bit right to the social
event we brought in three excavators one
by one and when the first one showed up
I'm pretty sure it was noted excavator
on the side of the highway when the
second one showed up the RCMP and the
province have notes that speak to no
construction activity being in the
vicinity and it being noted and they're
them being very aware of two excavators
on the side of the highway you know as
to what's what's going on here who's
doing this when the third one rolled in
it it resulted in a in a very
um
um
it resulted in a heavy response 40
officers descended on that field and on
those individuals operating those those
heils and
they were ordered to to retreat
I got the phone call at that time I was
actually in a meeting with uh with some
uh with individuals
in Milk River and I had
taken I took took the call and you know
they explained the situation and I had
said okay well
just pull them back it's never Our
intention there is no intentions here
other than to to you know positive
distraction fly some Flags
so they were treated over the hill there
was a misunderstanding that they would
be removed from the area fully
unfortunately it took three days to
bring them into the area and the trucker
he has 13 hours a day to legally operate
he was not he did not have the ability
to remove those
I had a family weekend planned for
months prior and I I had the ability to
sneak away for 10 hours and to get there
I went through it's called The Whiskey
Gap
um
without and it's without service so as I
was rolling into this part of the
country just outside the hot milk River
blockade
I got a call from I think I sent Greg
and Troy a text message because I knew
they were off like they had two two
different groups of ccmgs so Chris and
Chris and Mark were on on Sunday and
they Greg and Troy you know it was a
frustrating day and there was a lot of
tension regarding the excavators but it
was resolved in my mind and I said hey
have a good weekend and see you next
week is what I had said
and I got the call that um the
understanding was to move these
excavators out of the area and they are
not gone and I had said well we can move
them further
you know but we can't get them out of
the area right away it just isn't
possible
I I went into service the call was
dropped and I got out of service and my
message
I got a few messages sorry Mark of the
decision was made we've had to disable
these protests and that's because the
RCMP thought the excavators were
um it was too big of a liability in
their mind you know they looked at this
from a we're going to dig up the highway
perspective
brand
um I understand that those machines have
the ability to do that
but that was never our intentions right
okay and in in the course of your action
or your answer sorry you spoke
a few times about engagement from the
provincial government I thought
something that you were looking for is
that right I believe that's something
that that we were all everybody was
looking for you know
um if we if we look at the State of
Affairs and I'm going to speak to
Alberta
um because that's you know most of the
emergency measures and the mandates were
provincial
um and each province dealt with it
differently but um in my View Alberta
took a a fairly heavy-handed approach
uh for you know for Freedom loving
Alberta albertans and
um the the worst part was the
inconsistencies and the lies
the
the communication from the province that
we weren't going to lock down again or
open for summer open for good
or you know category Stampede 2021 Kenny
was on the record saying
we will never have a vaccine passport
one month later we have the rip program
which is essentially the same thing
um
the the worst part was was the lies the
lies to
to the UCP members to all Burns who
were were involved politically and now
you know we were being governed by a
emergency
committee we were being governed by the
health authority we had no direct
communication through the through our
Westminster parliamentary democracy
right so I I don't I don't mean to cut
you off but we do need to get to this
document so Mr Clark it's c-o-e-u-6016
and while
um Mr clerk is pulling that up this is a
text message exchange between the mayor
of Coots and Rajan Sani who's the
minister of transport of Alberta
and
we'll just wait for that to go up so if
we go to page nine
a little bit uh further down
all right so it says that
um MP mods and I understand that to be
Glenn moths Member of Parliament mayor
and then it's redacted and I being the
mayor of Coots so the blue bubble are
from the mayor of Coots met with RCMP
command
then paid a visit to the truckers for a
few minutes
and then he goes on to say moats met
with Marco up at The Milk River blockade
the message we are all pushing is clear
the road enough to be breaking the law
and protest all you want
consistent messaging is very important
still missing a provincial government
voice so did you meet with MP Glenn Motz
in Milk River at some point correct
and did you discuss Federal mandates
uh we discussed
absolutely we would have discussed
Federal mandates Glenn watts is the MP
for Medicine Hat in area
and I do I look at this message here I
think it says clear the road enough to
be breaking or probably meant to be
saying not breaking yeah I think that's
probably right I don't want to get Glenn
into any hot water here but
I I believe that's what he would have
meant yeah and so February 5th still
missing a provincial voice of government
voice then we have an answer by the
minister of Transportation Sani who says
hi Jim are there any mlas out there and
then Mr Clark free just scrolled down
haven't seen any although Grant says he
has been off and on all week so I take
this to mean Grant Hunter who's an MLA
in Alberta is that correct correct Grant
um Grant was there on the first Sunday
which is public knowledge
um I I don't I'm not aware of him
attending the protests on other
occasions and I'm not sit down with him
at all
I did sit down with them in Milk River
uh unofficially obviously because that's
what the previous text message speaks to
we had communication with individual
mlas individual MPS
um mainly opposition MPS right Alberta
is mainly um CPC and that was about the
mandates
that would have been about
on a provincial level the provincial
mandates in regards to the mlas and
obviously
um the federal mandate specifically the
travel mandates and the Border mandates
with the MPS
and so
I guess when I say you're talking about
mandates was the idea that you were
asking them whether they could do
anything to sort of lift the mandates
which would have resulted in the protest
resolving itself
uh yeah so we were we were looking for
lifting the mandates we were looking for
communication
um to I you know a lot of people said
we're looking for the madness to be
lifted you know it's uh 12 55 and the
mandates are not lifted and it's 12 56
and they're lifted I always knew that
was never a possibility I know how
government works and I understand that
it would be a process and that there has
to be a lot of things
to happen in a plan in place Etc you
know
communicated to the public and and
through through the health authorities
to put us on a track to lifting the
mandates
um unfortunately those conversations
never even got started
they never got started with with anybody
in an official capacity that represented
any level of government
so you spoke to it members of the
opposition mlas but not anyone who was
like for example in Premier Kenny's
cabinet no one liked that correct if you
were to scroll down further in this
um there is a conversation between the
mayor and Raj and Sanjay that speaks to
the mayor asking if she plans to come
down to Coots and
she she mentions I'm working on it I
have to get
um
uh permission from the RCMP which which
they would have got and the boss now
when we say the boss I'm pretty sure we
all know we're talking about Jason
Kenney right so that goes back to show
you the situation we were dealing with
in Alberta at this time we were no
longer we no longer have had a voice as
albertans we were dealing with with a
health authority that had emergency
powers and a premier who
was obviously operating his cabinet and
his caucus
in the aspect of
I'm the boss right and so the minister
of Transport never uh went down so we
know that but if we can scroll down to
to page 11
the bottom of page 11 so this on
February 6th which is the next day
and the mayor of Kutz says to the
minister of Transportation I'm trying to
find out who protesters spoke with and
said what Grant said it wasn't him very
clear he has no he means no mandate as
he clarifies in the next text that would
allow him to do that so it seems to
suggest that someone else from the
provincial government other than Grand
Hunters had spoken to the protesters in
an official capacity on February 6th so
you're saying that did not happen there
there were a lot of individuals there
that would have been involved in in in
politics more than somebody who votes
every four years you know they could
have been involved in their CA boards
Etc you know like myself local or
Municipal politician so
these individuals coming from different
constituencies
in the province would have direct
connections to their mlas I'm not aware
of all these conversations so but you
yourself did not have I myself did not
have any other conversations other than
one phone call with the transportation
Minister possibly two I can't remember
if there was one or two sorry so you're
saying you did speak on the phone to
Rajan Sani correct but that's not in
relation to this discussion right here
oh so what was that in relation to she
she had she looked in contact with me
um
me possibly others but I I ended up
taking the call in relation to the
protest in relation to the blockade and
what were your conversations about the
conversations were as to what it was and
and uh what could be done Etc and
um it was like I said it was not in any
official capacity obviously yes
Transportation Minister she she had the
ability to do that but we had I had
looked for a meeting with officials
through through the minister through the
minister and when I say I you know we as
as protesters but she reached out to you
I believe it was shared that she was
looking to get in contact with myself
and we connected
okay and I don't know who relayed that
that that message to me I might have
been through the mayor of Pharma Cloud
right like there's there's once it
became CBC made the connection that I
was a local uh Municipal counselor
obviously that that was something in and
of itself but um very quickly they were
looking to me as that
individual to connect with okay so you
said you spoke to her on the phone on
about two occasions do you recall the
dates of those I believe it was only one
I'm trying to trying to think which day
it was
um
I it would have been either the first or
the second day we were in the saloon and
I believe we got the saloon on the first
so it would have been either the first
or the second of February
and did you ever convey to her that you
wanted the provincial mandates lifted in
order for the protesters to then go home
I believe that message would have been
conveyed but that was obviously a very
that was a pretty obvious message
um
in general that that was why we were
there yeah so you conveyed that message
what was her response uh while she
didn't have the ability to speak to that
right that that still was a a pick or an
EMCC committee meeting did she say that
she would speak to Premier Kenny in an
unofficial capacitor through unofficial
channels or anything like that I don't
remember the details of the conversation
I I do remember it being more of an
introduction call and obviously
introduction you know there I don't
believe it was follow-up calls but
um sorry you said there were follow-up
no I I don't believe there were okay
like it just spoke to who she was who I
was uh details of of the blockade but um
and and the message we were looking to
to share with the province
demands all of that I wouldn't say
demands just frustrations in general and
how can we move forward but
that never went anywhere like I said I
might have had a follow-up conversation
but it would have never went anywhere
you say that it never went anywhere but
but Premier Kenny did make an
announcement on February 8th at the
provincial government was announcing a
plan for gradual easing of the pandemic
related Public Health measures is that
right correct and based on our response
to his message
um it was not the message we were
looking for and what was his message and
what was the message you were looking
for the message that Kenny gave was
um
it was a phased approach with a lot of
maybes
and there was no surety of anything in
that message
it spoke to a lot of different aspects
and there was a lot of different
methods to back out of that phased
approach but it really it was something
because they had to address you know
there was pressure even though we
weren't communicating there was pressure
did apply pressure to the provincial
government right and you said earlier
that you know you understand that
there's a process that has to you know
governmental process for
um Public Health measures like these to
be lifted and that it would maybe take
some time so in your view was it
realistic for Premier Kenny to announce
on February 8th for example that all
mandates would be lifted the next day
was that a realistic objective
and that that's not a realistic
objective but
that's that's on one side and then there
was his response which was completely on
the other side so somewhere in the
middle uh there was the ability and this
was not just exclusively Coots this was
you know you you all the evidence is
submitted to the slow rolls in Edmonton
to the protests of five to ten thousand
in Calgary the
the the inconveniences on highways all
over the province
obviously the focus is on Coots Ottawa
Emerson Ambassador Sarnia Etc but
albertans were frustrated and they were
making it very aware to their government
that they wanted to see change so we
were willing to to have those
discussions and to work on a realistic
plan like you know
I can't speak for everybody but
we wanted to to you know being involved
in government for
uh five going on six years
um
the the message we had was let's work
together to do what albertans want
unfortunately somewhere that somewhere
along the line that message never got
delivered or the message was delivered
and the
Egypt nothing ever came of it and that
in my in my mind that's worse obviously
so it's fair to say that you were
looking for a stronger commitment from
Jason Kenney and you Premier Kenny's
apologies and you didn't get one is that
right correct okay and we're almost out
of time here so I'm just going to ask
you some quick questions about the
events of February 13th and 14th so I
understand that an RCMP Tactical Unit
came in
on February 13th and there were also
some arrests on that day in relation to
uh guns and ammunition that were seized
at a house in Coots is that right
correct and they arrested many people in
relation to this did you know any of the
individuals who are arrested for
mischief and possession of a weapon I
know them in the capacity as attendees
of the protests you did not know them
before no and what about the individuals
that were arrested for conspiracy to
commit murder
I was I met them at Goods and would you
say that you spoke to them every day how
well did you know these individuals
um
one one of the individuals uh he he
would have been up early every day and
when I walked in he was
the biggest friendliest
giant are you talking about Chris lisak
correct
so did you know that Chris lysak was in
a group called or was a fan of a group
called diagonalon No had you ever heard
of that group before no
so you're not a fan or a follower of
Diagon no did you ever speak to Jeremy
McKenzie who's one of the founders of
diagonalon nope
and did you know that there were
Firearms amongst the protesters no
had you ever heard of this plot to shoot
RCMP officers that they're being alleged
to have
um
I guess planned no
where your Banks bank accounts Frozen
when the emergencies Act was invoked no
but I understand that you were recently
arrested no I've never been arrested
since Kutz or or during and since I I
was summoned to come in and have my
charges read off to me and a promise to
appear
so you've not you have been charged
though I've been charged but I've never
been arrested right and that's for Miss
Jeff Mischief yeah
so that was in relation to the uh Coots
protests but it was not
it was recent and so it wasn't like an
emergency to act
um measure I don't know
okay and I just have about one minute
left so I'll just ask you to tell the
commissioner quickly what happened on
the morning of February 15th so how did
the protests end after the arrest that
we just discussed were were uh finished
so the decision was made on the morning
of the 14th
to leave
I had contact with media and I received
a con a phone call from a uh a reporter
to touch base with me daily and she
called me to the events she called me in
regards to the events of the night of
the 13th
and the arrests Etc so we were talking
about what had happened and the The
Fairly heavy-handed approach the RCMP
initially took and how that was
de-escalated Etc and the question came
in so what about the guns and I and I
had responded and said what guns
immense later I knew what guns we were
talking about
for me it became very clear that this
was no longer that every objective we
were looking to achieve was no longer
possible and that our message had been
lost
and to distance ourselves from any uh
and this has this has to be determined
yet right these these charges have not
gone to uh to court for these
individuals charged with conspiracy to
commit or any related gun charges so I'm
not going to speak to that but to
distance ourselves from
that
um
even the the perception at that time and
uh anything to do with that we made the
decision to leave
um and I remember calling that meeting
and having that discussion
and obviously it was unfortunate it was
it was
it was not us it was obviously
individuals who were Among Us that had
different
um different uh
and like I said this is to be proven I I
can't speak to that but it alleged to
have different views than us
and I remember having that discussion
and
um there was pushback initially and I
had said I'm leaving and a majority of
the individuals will leave with me but I
would like to leave together
and I had I remember I had said Google
Coots you know I I was keeping an eye on
on mainstream media Etc I was I was
aware about it one such but I wasn't
aware of everything but I remember
saying Google Coots
and any of the messages any of the
videos any of the the positive
positivity around what we were doing in
in my my view was lost it was guns guns
guns and to be uh to not be associated
with that or even that Viewpoint we
arranged and we arranged to leave the
agreed upon I think by the 12th of noon
or sorry
noon on the 12th
15th
no the 15th is one no
we we had asked that we would we would
clear the blockade immediately but to
leave as if we were never there we had
to arrange you know we had mountains of
firewood for example
we had food we like we had you know the
food some the right home about but
um the food and and just to make sure
everything was clean up properly
um
we had negotiated
that we would leave at nine o'clock on
the 15th but the RCP can attest that
before noon or around noon on the 14th
right the highway was no longer impeded
okay and the timing of that is important
so I think absolutely clarifying that so
noon on the 14th you communicate to the
RCMP you agreed to leave those
discussions happened in the morning and
by noon right had but you told them
listen we need some more time to clean
everything up and to leave as a group
and we'll leave by tomorrow morning
right so we had gone to the RCMP after
we had talked to the um
uh doj like Department of Justice we had
we had a requested a zoom with them so
we had the discussion and then we had
gone to to the protest because it was
always
it was never my decision or and it was
always a group decision we were leaving
or we were we were going or we're
staying and I do remember having to to
address the group with that and based on
the situation and the information
flowing around it was a pretty you know
I didn't have to tell anybody to be
quiet when I started to address the
crowd and um
um there was some some opposition you
know we still had individuals coming in
that that were full of fight you know
like they wanted to be part of this and
they had showed up 15 minutes ago and we
were we were 18 days we were pretty
battered so it was also a way to end
this there was no plan so there was
never a plan to end this and this was
for us a
strategic Retreat Victory whatever you
want to call it it is what it is but we
negotiated
um
by noon we had we had talked to the RCP
as we'd like to leave
with supper's cooking we're going to
invite people over legally one more time
to
do what we did the tractors will be off
the highway immediately and we will
start we will commence cleanup efforts
um initially there are some peas they
phoned it in their response was very
happy they said you need to leave
immediately and we want you gone in an
hour and I remember thinking this is
just crazy and I just
I walked away essentially and they went
back in their vehicles and five minutes
later they came back and says okay
um nine o'clock tractor floss you know
it was just last little bit of a
you know
power struggle or whatever it was I
thought whatever we'll we'll we'll do
tractors last and
didn't matter to me it didn't matter to
us
but the decision to leave was made
before noon on the 14th and I believe at
9 45 on the 15th
we we were leaving
thank you so those are all my questions
is there anything that you'd like to
tell the commissioner that we haven't
covered together
uh well we've covered a lot
um
I just uh
I I want to speak to to what Coots was
it it was a gathering of of
truckers mainly Farmers eventually
Farmers bolstered bolstered the ranks
but it was a group of of um and
the
the perception around Coots
unfortunately
due to the the discovery of the guns and
such has tainted what Coots was
and
for me what's important is that we we
were there to demand
that our Representatives communicate
with us like they are obligated to do
and like what had not been happening and
there's lots of different events during
those days that
I almost think it was like a chess game
between the RCMP and the protesters but
unfortunately
we were never able to enter in official
communication with the government but
looking back at the political State of
Affairs in Alberta it might have been
better for the Canada government to
actually have done that
and
because at the end of the day we were
albertans and we're Canadians
and the coveted restrictions
and the mandates they they messed with
our lives like we see the
inconsistencies of of the experts and I
I don't necessarily blame them the
information provided was
was what they went off in that
information is is no is is at times is
now no longer factual either things you
know that the ball kept on getting
pushed further down the road two weeks
to flatten the curve and look at where
we are now
and
I'm not going to speak to to covet and
I'm no expert on it but even the experts
got it wrong
and
for public trust to be regained
for the for the trust of albertans to be
regained there has to be accountability
so thank you
thank you for your time for answering my
questions I'm going to pass it over to
my friends who will have questions
thank you
okay the first up is the government of
Alberta please
good afternoon for the record my name is
Stephanie Bose I'm appearing today on
behalf of the government of Alberta most
of my questions have already been
answered but I I would like to cover off
a few areas with you today
um you've talked a little bit about your
role as an unofficial spokesperson for
the protesters at Coots and
um were there any other unofficial
spokespeople at the same time that you
were acting in that role
there was individuals in the media
um in the beginning once there became
once there was some organization you
know the the event was organic but once
there was some organization established
in regards to food and Logistics and
things like that right you have 200 some
people in a place you got to establish
some kind of structure once that was
established and once it became
um
more or less uh once I got pushed into
the role of dealing with the media
um
I I dealt with the media and there was
certain media that had been chasing me
around
or chasing individuals around looking
for some kind of comment I remember one
particular reporter who had finally in
frustration said you you want us how can
we tell the world what's going on here
if you want to talk to us and I won't
speak to the organization but obviously
my view on that organization was was was
why we were in that situation and I had
turned around and responded and it says
okay
you're gonna get an interview and I'll
be watching tonight that will determine
whether you get another one tomorrow and
I actually was able to
to say that my views on the organization
may not have changed but I had a very
very positive relationship with this
reporter and that has
um that has since since then given me
the discretion with other reporters to
to hear them out but there we had
advised protesters to not speak to the
media and that we're trying to
orchestrate a a general communication a
general direction in regards to what
came from Coots but
individuals may have on their own accord
done interviews and stuff and I've seen
those and
you know like I said there was it's not
like the RCMP where there was such
structure that you didn't move left or
right unless you were told to we you
know we were there for Freedom so it
wasn't like it wasn't uh for us to go
and order people around and tell them
not to do this or not to do that
and I understand from your
um
participated statement
um that you would have described the
protest at Milk River as being somewhat
less organized than the protest at coops
is that fair to say correct yeah so the
RCMP had their uh their initial blockade
which was in
um
uh on the January 1st the protesters
went around it so they reinforced it to
the point where there was no longer any
way to uh to go through that other than
uh going through through the through the
barricade you know which was never which
would have resulted in violence which
was never any an intention
um but due to the numbers which
fluctuated
um on the weekends
and uh the first and the second weekend
being obviously quite quite phenomenal
due to the influx of people uh thousands
I believe we had over ten thousand on
the Saturday
uh Saturday the
I'm going to say the sixth I believe but
people had to take care of themselves
you know sleeping accommodations food
Etc there was individuals at the front
that maintained to make sure to make
sure we didn't have anybody come in and
cause problems right we were we were
wary of of uh
people looking to come in and make us
look you know start something and and
that it would be on us right so we were
aware of that and just there was fires
there so we made sure that the fires
were contained and
um
there was a general there's a few
individuals at The Milk River protest
that kept an eye on things and if things
you know went a certain way they would
coordinate with your fcmp to make sure
that was either resolved or de-escalated
but um the biggest thing was to make
sure that
um we didn't have and I remember the
thought and I'm not gonna you know that
antifa could show up and cause problems
and obviously for myself you know being
in in the public eye I had um
we had to fairly you know we had threats
to to myself and to my family and I
remember when I I would go down the Milk
River multiple times a day
or as needed and they came to a point
where I wasn't alone I would be
accompanied by an individual or two just
for my
to do the worries of the protesters
about my well-being so it was less
organized
um but you know I I I wouldn't they they
were there was a lot of structure there
too at the front but on the weekends it
was you took care of yourself you know
like we called them The Weekend Warriors
you know they showed up in in droves
you know it was the place to be in
Alberta at the time right so
[Music]
now if the um protests would change
um depending on what day of the week it
was and who was coming to the protest
site correct correct yeah
now in your um statement of anticipated
evidence and you've spoken about this a
little bit today you say that if the
government of liberta had agreed to
negotiate with spokespersons the Coots
protest could have been dispersed and
I'll take it that you still believe that
at this point in time correct absolutely
and just to be clear do you mean just
the protest at Coots or are you
including the protest that was occurring
at checkpoint 10 near Milk River well
you know the events right when we left
they left so they were there for us when
we were gone there their goal was no
longer achievable
you acknowledge though that you didn't
have control over any particular group
of people
um at the protest correct
there was less control over Milk River
but there was there were still
individuals who definitely kept an eye
on the situation and it was it was
mainly the weekends that uh were
um
just just the most concerning in regards
to Public Safety and that was something
I worked I spent hours working with the
RCMP I spent every day working with the
RCMP to maintain Public Safety that was
something neither of us wanted that that
somebody got hurt by accident
there were people who were at these
protests that were protesting provincial
Health restrictions correct
and there were certainly people there
that were protesting any federal health
restrictions correct
I believe the big I believe everybody
who who was there was protesting
provincial restrictions and some may
also have been protesting Federal
restrictions and I'll ask um the clerk
if you could please
document PB dot c a n dot four zeros133
sorry that's one three three
and I'll ask that you just um scroll
down to the second page
to an email from Lisa lorenzel piece on
January 30th 2022
I think you'll have to scroll a little
bit farther
ah there it is there
um and you'll see
um
cbsa intelligence provided the following
and a couple of points down there rumors
of another 800 protesters coming with
heavy equipment because they want
Trudeau there
do you agree that there were people
there who were looking to address prime
minister or sorry yes prime minister
Trudeau
um with these with this protest
I could I could see that being something
individuals wanted
um Trudeau is not popular in Alberta
and did you see any um and part of my
language here that [ __ ] Trudeau signs
about the protest
uh there would have been those signs at
the protest the the amount
um
no I'm not aware of that
okay
now I understand that you spoke to
Western Standard news during the protest
is that correct correct
and on February 3rd you told Western
Standard news that the protesters
involved in The Klutz blockade would
depart at 7 A.M on Friday February 4th
for a slow roll Convoy to Edmonton to
meet with Premier Kenny is that correct
coffee with Kenny yes correct
and that wasn't an agreement you had at
that time with with Premier Kenny the
plan was to to go to Edmonton
um to try to meet with him is that
correct
that that was that would have been that
would have been an ultimate success if
we would have actually been able to meet
with him it was just um it was a
headline you know you were going you
know there was a bit of sarcasm in that
headline that uh we're you know we're
going to Edmonton uh which was not
something I agreed with uh actually I
agreed with going to Edmonton I
disagreed with leaving Coots but
um the article spoke to to those events
and there were individuals that did and
I believe from all corners of the
province they came and and uh caused the
logistical challenges in the downtown
and on the Anthony Andy
did you tell the RCMP the same thing
that the coach protesters would be
leaving and Slow Rolling to Edmonton no
this was their party go ahead this media
publication
uh came out before
the
the Before we or before I went and
talked to to the to the protesters as a
whole like I said decision to leave
or to stay was a group decision and
um unfortunately this this article we
did have a plan uh through through
pressures that were applied on us by um
individuals businesses Cattlemen
Association and their their um their
representatives to leave Coots and uh I
had
sorry I I once once that decision was
made as a as a
a side group a smaller
um group involving these these
Representatives Etc
um the
the decision went to to the crowd
um the crowd
unanimously
I remember that moment uh unanimously
and with a lot of emotion was like no
and I remember thinking this is it but
unfortunately
um things
were able to be resolved very shortly
and those who wanted to go to Edmonton
were free to go
um we're free to leave at any time
but we we had decided that leaving Coots
was not the objective that was the
objective of of those representatives in
the Cattlemen's Association because we
were we were an inconvenience to them
and they had worked away and influenced
individuals who had reputation and who
were attending this protest who had then
called a meeting which I was not in
initially until I got the phone call
because I was
coordinating things in Milk River with
the RCMP and I remember getting the
phone call and and coming south coming
back to Coots very frustrated because
this had happened once before where we
were almost sabotaged in in my view of
you know leaving Coots
um by
you know individuals who who had no
bearing in Coots but who came in and
they were this and they were that
but it came to a decision
eventually regardless of My Views and um
because like I said this wasn't my my
thing it wasn't about me it was I was
playing a role as spokesman and
um
had to deliver that message to the crowd
and it was not well received and we did
not leave for Edmonton
okay so to understand or paraphrase your
your evidence there was a group that
um made a decision that this would
happen that the the protesters would
leave to go to Edmonton you spoke to
Western Standard news and told them the
same thing and then later you spoke to
the group of protesters on a larger
basis and the decision was no we're not
going to go to Edmonton is that correct
correct so my view of of a decision like
that was something that had to be so we
decided to bring it back to the crowd
that it even made its way there
the the majority of the individuals in
that initial discussion had decided it
was happening regardless of the crowd
which which was naive of them because
the crowd or the protesters and it was
their trucks and their their equipment
Etc
and
um
we had prepped a statement So eventually
I said okay well then this is what we're
doing but I first have to discuss it
with
with
with the protest with the group
and as I went to do that because it was
in another building
um
the press release was released prior to
speaking to the group so that resulted
in
a hectic hour or two for RCMP for us for
everybody
but confusion it was definitely it was
it was confusing because the statement
read that we were leaving and and had my
name all over it and I remember hearing
the crowd and somebody come up to me and
showed me the picture and I was like I
was like really
who who released this like I was I was
just shocked that
this individual had or these these
individuals had released it and I think
there was also part of their tactic to
pressure that now it was known to the
public that we were leaving
but we never did
now I'd like to talk to you about the
announcement by the government of
Alberta on February 8th and I'll ask the
clerk to please go to document alb401768
and you've talked a little bit about
this um with my friend already I'll just
um
scroll down to
the bottom of page two
and we'll see here starting at the word
beginning beginning Feb 8 at 11 59 PM
Alberta will move to step one which
includes the removal of the restrictions
exemption program and then there's other
some other liftings of exempt of
restrictions within that paragraph and
then the plan goes on to further
describe various times that
various covid-19 Health restrictions
will be removed
now you you talked about how um
the government didn't move fast enough
for you in terms of lifting restrictions
this was an announcement on February 8th
that later that night restrictions would
be lifted and then if we go to Alberta's
institutional report which is document
ALB
dot ir
seven zeros one
paragraph 19 on page seven of this
report
we see on February 8th Alberta announced
a plan for gradual easing of pandemic
related Public Health orders later that
day protesters resumed a complete
blockade at the Coots Poe which is Port
of Entry you acknowledge that despite
Alberta's announcement about easing
restrictions the blockade resumed that
day correct correct
and we're still looking at paragraph 19.
I'd also like to
um talk about
um
the legal protest site that was made
available by Alberta did you were you
aware of the alternate protest site that
was being provided yes I I viewed the
property
did you encourage protesters to use the
alternate protest site instead of
blocking the highway
the that was the the biggest discussion
I had with the RCMP that week the
longest uh that happened inside the
sheriff buses at The Milk River a
protest and I think the part that made
it very unappealing was the fact that
they had government Wi-Fi there
so you refused the protest site on the
basis of government Wi-Fi
that was the fight I believe that was
the part that was
completely
ridiculous in regards to we got
government Wi-Fi there
um the biggest issue was the intent was
to be on the highway
for for the military but this was not
this was not Coots this was 100 in
relation to the Milk River blockade
you're aware of that correct correct
because it's this and I think that was
just um sloppy language on my part okay
so that but in any event the um
protesters didn't shift over to
protesting at that site correct no the
the it was it was never
it was never communicated to the
protesters
um I I remember sitting in the bus with
both groups of ccmgs and I mean I think
even the the the officer in charge of
Milk River The Milk River protest and
and my
I I question them as to how I was
supposed to convince the protesters to
move off the highway
into this field
it just wasn't it wasn't realistic like
there was no way that was going to
happen
you didn't believe you could convince
them to to make that change correct
okay thank you those are all my
questions today
okay thank you uh next uh call on the
government of Canada
foreign
good afternoon Mr commissioner Mr even
boss for the record my name is Ryan
Atkins I'm part of the legal team for
the government of Canada
we heard that you're a town counselor
for the town of Fort McLeod in Southern
Alberta correct and on March 28 2022 you
were given a letter of reprimand from
the mayor of Fort McLeod is that right
correct that's in relation to the events
and your participation in the Convoy at
Coots correct uh we also heard about the
criminal charges that uh were laid
against you are those charges still
outstanding yes
now we've heard that there are two
distinct uh protest sites there was the
one in Coots itself near the way station
and another one uh just south of Milk
River by the checkpoint yes and I just
want to understand where you were at
various points of time I think you said
that you met uh Emily Motts at Milk
River did you mean the the protest site
or the the town glenmatz
um we met in front of the sheriff buses
at The Milk River blockade okay was that
on the southern side of the police
barricade or did you actually uh
Traverse the police barricade the north
side he was not
you know it was not allowed as a
individual or participating I would say
he was there to to commit to come talk
to me but he was not allowed on the
other side of those buses and that was
on Saturday the 5th I believe that was
on Saturday yeah it was it was it was a
pretty crazy place was that the same
weekend that you were able to get out of
the protest site for a family weekend no
that was the second weekend okay so on
two different weekends you were able to
get out
no so in regards to my ability to
Traverse
um I guess with with the the perk of
being the the
um media spokesperson allowed me to come
and go as I as I as I as I needed to so
the police were allowing you to go back
and forth sorry you have to articulate
yes sorry
and I think you said that you went down
to Milk River that is the protest site a
couple times a day
correct and you also spent time at the
saloon in Coots yes
uh you mentioned that you brought your
pickup truck to the protest and that
initially it was parked in the parking
lot by the saloon without your evidence
my my truck has probably been parked in
100 different locations in Milk River
and in Coots and during the the period
of time that we're talking about from
January 29th to February 15th it didn't
remain in that parking lot no was it
ever parked on the highway yes
uh and that's including during the time
when all Lanes of the highway were
blocked correct correct
now at the beginning of the blockade on
January 29th the RCMP asked that the
protesters not block all Lanes the
highway were you aware of that
I I can I didn't hear that that
communication but I was aware and I
could understand that request and the
reason you understand that request is
because blocking all Lanes uh could
create a dangerous situation for for
residents and Coots correct because
blocking all Lanes would restrict or
impede emergency response vehicles for
example that would be perceived we
actually did have an emergency response
and the lanes were cleared enough to
allow that to proceed eventually right
at that specific time when that
emergency vehicle showed up
okay uh and and you indicated that it
wasn't your intention to completely
block the highway you personally correct
and in fact I believe on January 31st uh
you made a statement to the media saying
that uh we had to shift gears because we
were hurting people who were supporting
us correct
January the 31st can you provide some
more context in regards that comment uh
so you're reported on January 31st as
saying that uh we need we want to stop
hurting those who are supporting us you
don't recall making that statement
uh I believe it
yes
I'm just asking the witness if he
recalls making that if he doesn't recall
making that statement he doesn't recall
I do recall
making that statement and
the
thought process behind that statement is
this was a border blockade to Southern
Alberta I live in Southern Alberta it
didn't affect Edmonton as much as it
would Southern Alberta it didn't affect
Ottawa as much as it affected Southern
Alberta so we were driven
as protesters as residents of Alberta to
a place where we were where we were
willing to sacrifice
our own livelihoods
um and and more
for the sake of
getting
in contact with with our governing body
you'd agree with me that not all of the
people who were being uh
uh who upon whom that sacrifice was
being imposed supported what you were
doing correct correct okay I'd like to
take you to
um a video if I can and the the number
is pb.can.401792
foreign
seconds please
a slice of the world's longest
undefended border at a standstill for
days cross-border traffic shut down by
about a hundred trucks on the Canadian
side
trucks and their drivers have been stuck
here near Coots since Saturday today
RCMP started guiding some away from the
border through back roads
I feel like I'm cold I want to go home
yeah this driver was headed north with a
load of potatoes when he ran into the
blockade stranded for 45 hours before
finally moving on unimpressed with the
delay or the protesters who caused it I
represent me I'm not representing any
truckers that I know this is something I
don't agree with at all like this is
health and safety and you can stop it
right there
you're aware that those have your the
Convoy you were participating in was
having that effect on Truckers
we were aware that that was the effect
on some truckers correct okay and it's a
foreseeable consequence of blocking that
Highway correct it was an unintended
consequence and after 45 hours those
truckers were on their way unintended
maybe but foreseeable yes
uh no no being as organic as it was it
was a direct unintended consequence
sorry it's your evidence that completely
blocking a highway all Lanes wouldn't
have uh consequences for truckers who
use that Highway it was specifically the
truckers that were stuck in the blockade
truckers that were backed up on either
side of the Border had the ability to
turn around and take different border
borders we we did not
it was an inconvenience to Coots
obviously being the main Port but Del
Benito had an increase of 917 percent
in commercial traffic flow during that
time we did not block all borders
I want to talk to you a little bit about
what you call an inconvenience on
January 31st and I can take you to it if
you like the Alberta minister of
Transport tweeted that there were 50 to
100 truckers stranded on the U.S side
since Saturday so for several days some
hadn't eaten and some had medical issues
were you aware of that tweet no okay
were you aware that some truckers were
facing those issues I was aware there
were truckers on the American side but
these truckers were hoping for a speedy
resolution which
could have been achievable
by the Alberta Transportation
Minister department and the government
in general unfortunately that never
happened and these truckers were
stranded longer and eventually they did
turn around and take other ports of
Entry but that was a decision they were
not forced to stay there of their own
accord
okay so so okay I'll leave that there
um
you also agree with me I think that
Highway 4 is an important Corridor for
the people of Coots
correct and they use it to access
essential services in Milk River correct
uh if we could just press play on the
video where we left off at six minutes
two seconds
Donna I can tell you that the situation
here looks a lot different than it did
earlier today protesters have moved
their vehicles to the shoulders opening
up a lane of traffic in both directions
though RCMP say that travel is still not
recommended quite yet still it is a very
hopeful sign here after a very tense few
days
this is what we're trying to get through
oh my God
cell phone video captures the moment of
impact Coots resident Tara chamber had
just left town to get groceries when she
was hit it was terrifying absolutely
terrifying the crash happened Tuesday
afternoon as RCMP moved in to try and
dismantle the illegal blockade at the
Coots border crossing
police warned protesters that if they
did not leave peacefully arrests would
follow a few did leave but then we had
a bunch of vehicles and farm machinery
that were to the north at a roadblock
that was set up on Highway 4 to the
north those Vehicles breached the
roadblock and they did that by driving
at quite high speeds it was one of those
vehicles that hit Tara chamber's car
police say her husband was then
assaulted before the driver left the
scene most we were doing was going to go
get groceries
and they're trying to say that this is a
peaceful protest
that very peaceful to me what's
happening as
so watching that video you would agree
with me I take it that the Convoy posed
a significant risk for the physical
safety of people and Coots
this interaction
was the only time that that there was
Vehicles between the Milk River blockade
and the Coots blockade and we addressed
that earlier in regards to them
circumventing the the initial RCMP
blockade on the February the 1st as a
result of that
both lanes and I wasn't there but as a
result of that both lanes were going
south Southbound
as the video stated the individual that
was
heading north bound
got into a motor vehicle accident with
an individual that was heading
Southbound
the individual heading southbound was a
resident of Coots I was actually a
previous
I think they were known to each other
um I believe there was an altercation at
the time which was very unfortunate
upon hearing this and the damages to the
vehicle Etc and the inconvenience
as protesters we leased them a vehicle
while their vehicle was repaired and we
paid for all the damages to that vehicle
but my question was you agree with me
that what we just saw in that video was
an unsafe situation absolutely that was
an unsafe situation can we tee up a
document
pb.can.401803 and just bring it to uh
three minutes 18 seconds and just kind
of freeze frame there please
so I want to talk about the RCMP
enforcement action on uh the in the
early morning hours of February 14th
um and I take it that this is a photo
that you've actually seen before correct
I've seen this photo before yeah you
were asked about this photo in a news
interview that you gave
possibly you don't recall I don't recall
if you can show me the interview I would
recall I've given many interviews but
you have seen this photo before yes uh
and uh you'll agree with me that it
shows a large quantity of guns uh body
armor uh ammunition including high
capacity uh magazines
a legal high capacity magazines if
that's what you you're referring to but
hi capacity magazines correct okay and
uh I I don't need to take you to it but
I I believe you may have indicated that
uh you thought there were more guns
seized at Coots than are depicted in
this photo do you recall saying that no
I don't recall that okay that's fine
um but uh were you aware that there were
weapons at Coots before the seizure of
this cache of weapons no
you told the media that the decision to
leave was made uh after the arrests on
the 14th correct correct and I believe
you also said that it was made after uh
the infiltration of extreme elements in
the protest group based on the
information I was presented at the time
that was my statement regarding that and
and the information that you were
presented at the time uh involved uh the
presence of diagonalon symbols or or
supporters correct
and I know you didn't know about Diagon
before but you learned about it at that
time that time I learned about it after
based on
I've never in person seen this based on
the information presented to me so and
you didn't want to stay after that
because you didn't want to be associated
with extremis correct uh were you at The
Smuggler Saloon on February 3rd when
Pastor Art palowski gave a speech he
walked in and I walked out
okay so you didn't stay for his speech
it was it wasn't a direct this I was
addressing
I was speaking to the crowd in regards
to that decision
to
um
by by that those individuals that had
come in to to to leave for Edmonton
coffee with Kenny that happened just
before uh Pastor Arthur plowski came in
and
he might have actually been in the
audience while I was
explaining the motive etc etc but the
the unanimous agreement was to stay
and
this has never been
um
Pastor Arthur has charges in regards to
this but uh his charge is that he
incited us to stay because coffee with
Kenny was
um
seen as I was leaving before Pastor
Arthur reached the podium or even
reached the building I'm not sure the
events the
protesters had decided we were staying
the decision to stay had nothing to do
with Pastor Arthur that was my question
my question was whether you heard the
speech no I did not hear the speech okay
you didn't hear about it on social media
no I might have listened to it after the
actual events or after his arrest just
as to what actually happened uh but but
before the Convoy ended
I don't believe I did I don't believe I
did and so you didn't hear anything
about the substance of the speech while
you were at Coots I would have heard
from from individuals
um in the protest who would who come and
talk to me after as to details of the
speech or what it was about
in in general and upon hearing the
details of the speech you didn't decide
to leave at that time
what specific details but no no we
didn't leave as to arth speech we
Arthur's speech had no relevance on us
staying or going
thank you those are my questions
okay next is the or the Convoy
organizers
good uh good evening rather Mr
commissioner Bathsheba Vandenberg
Council for Freedom Corps and protesters
we have no questions for Mr friend
haugenbos thank you thank you
next is uh Council for former Chief
slowly
thank you Mr commissioner we have no
questions for this Witness
okay uh so uh Mr Raymond and any uh
questions to follow up
Mr van hugenbos
um Council for Canada my friend she
showed you a clip where a vehicle was
struck now that wasn't the only accident
in Coots correct the RCMP were involved
with an in an accident because they
ignore the stop sign correct
um and as a consequence of that accent
do you know if anybody was arrested for
this alleged assault no
um
in in your opinion
and
the political decisions that were made
with response to the to the pandemic and
the covid virus the so the measures and
responses
um
what were they proportional or
unproportionate to to
the virus
the mandates and emergency measures yes
they were not proportional to the
response
and and so you would agree with me that
the response and the measures trampled
various protective rights correct
um they caused economic damage
absolutely uh there were social health
and psychological implications and and
issues still are
foreign
was there an injunction as far as you
are aware of was there an injunction
sought or granted with respect to the
kids protest I was never aware of that
um and then during the cruise protest um
was there any violence no
um was it a peaceful protest absolutely
uh were the families there yes
Did You observe any kids playing Road
hockey sure did so one could state that
it was a very Canadian protest it was
yeah
um now with respect to
this alleged security team
um to the best of your knowledge
was there an official security team
there was never any details or
discussions around security there was
never any individuals who had the role
of security other than you know my
security because of the threats made
against me while I
so while I was at the Milk River
blockade just as I would say in an
official capacity personal security
detail
um
uh
We There was
equipment and motor vehicles trucks and
and and trailers Etc parked on the
highway
but the RCMP and anybody who wanted to
had the ability to
mingle with us communicate with us
access us anywhere use our facilities
dine with us dine eat meals with us
there was no security needed
what threats against your family were
made
so
um
I wore the temperatures were extreme I
wore
a hat and and coats that had my company
logo on it
and we have a website where requests for
proposals can be submitted by
individuals and that was used by
individuals anonymously to put in a fake
number fake name fake email and then you
know have at her based on their views of
of something I was participating in
um but what really
um
topped it all was
um a phone call that came in at the end
of the first week to the admin
and it took her a little bit to
to to just connect the dots but they
rattled off sorry they rattled off my
address and said we're coming for your
family
so I received this message
probably half hour later at 5 30 on
Friday
and took me a bit to process it and
um
that's never happened before in my life
that's not something I I've ever been or
I've ever had to deal with I had already
been dealing with some pretty nasty
emails Etc
which I just you know just I get it
people had different views on different
different different things and um but
this was you know my address my family
so I I remember phoning my dad and my
father-in-law and we took it seriously
that was the right response and my
family
from that day on did not um did not stay
at our primary residence until I was
until the blockade was concluded
thank you
with respect to the timeline the kind of
the the time between February or January
29th and February 15th or so
um during the the protest we'll call it
um
there were two or there were some
arrests
on February 13th and then and then into
the early morning of February 14th there
were no were there any other arrests in
Coots or in around Milk River no you
were aware of not that I'm aware of I do
believe there was somebody who was
removed from the protest but not
arrested it was just we had requested
this individual be removed he was
causing a disturbance and um we were
as a as a
protest
um
we were very strict on some things and
that involved the in Coots where we had
the ability to do that right where we
had the influence where there was no
there was no drinking in public there
was no
uh you know
speeding or any of that we we try to
maintain a orderly
event
um in in those days
Mr clerk if we could pull up the
document
pb.nsc dot can
four zeros9207
great thank you uh Mr van hedenboss
right here it's it's an email
um
I'm not sure who John Ferguson is um but
it's regarding Coots
um at one point it says at approximately
2 200 hours a tractor tried to forcibly
push a RCMP police vehicle out of that
checkpoint with the assistance of a
pickup
um is that your Recollections of the
events no
what happened
uh
due to the cold weather and the
equipment if you're familiar with with
trucks and
equipment in general the batteries if if
they do not run on on a regular basis
the batteries will drain so to prevent
that uh sporadically and at different
times we would fire up all the equipment
and let the let the equipment run
um that was that occurred the night of
so that occurred Sunday night on the
13th
um
and then Kristen Chris and Mark where's
the mark two ccmgs I don't recall their
last names
um they were the second shift and
Greg and Troy were a team and Chris and
Mark were team they were
um
in front of the saloon standing around a
fire doing what their their role was uh
you know
Community conflict group like they were
there interacting and I'm pretty sure
they were meant taking mental notes as
to what we were up to but
um there was a I think there was a
gospel band playing in in the saloon and
people were
or mingling and families that are sorry
people that couldn't be there on the
week were there on a Sunday night and it
was a very quiet
um
quiet evening
and
um all the you know the decision or
whatever it was it was a minor thing to
fire up all the tractors you know
there's things happened on a daily and
that we tried to coordinate structure
and so all the tractors
fired up unfortunately
um
one of these tractors one of these
individuals decided to to go for a
little
um Joyride with one of these tractors
and
this
drew the attention of the RCMP
and I'm going to say specifically
looking back specifically
the SWAT or
ethical teams that were in place to
execute these warrants of that night
which we were not aware of
but they were in the vicinity so being
dark they must have been within a couple
minute response time just waiting for
the time to execute their warrants on
the location outside of the protests in
connection to the guns
this individual in this tractor
triggered a response by these tactical
teams
but prior to this this tractor the first
individual the first vehicle on site was
an administrative vehicle it was an
unmarked RCMP vehicle with a staff
member who
Works in administration so who may have
had received the training previously to
be in the field but
um
was was you know they were short
officers everybody was short officers
there was a lot of drop for for for
um
the for the RCMP across the country so
they had a lot of individuals that were
usually working desk jobs Etc Manning
checkpoints so this person must have
been in the nearest checkpoint
responding to this tractor driving
around and what's going on
and this tractor ended up
um I can't speak for for the individual
driving instructor but from what I've
seen this big tractor
um and if you're not familiar with
tractors they can be very intimidating
intimidating all on their own parked
um now this tractor was driving around
and
there was intention or sorry intention
there was an in unintended confrontation
in an intersection where you have a
little SUV manned by a RCMP officer who
who was
um obviously very very intimidated by
this piece of equipment
and it resulted in an altercation
that was eventually de-escalated but
resulted in this tractor being seized
but you in in what you witnessed there
was you didn't see any attempt to
forcibly push an RCMP vehicle no there
was no attempt if there was an attempt
it would have ended
very unset very unsat Factory for that
vehicle
um the issue with the premier's
announcements on February 8th um you
would agree with me that it the issue
was that it could have been uh
that the premier are
the governor could have gone back on it
it wasn't uh wasn't a solid Planet had
all kinds of avenues as to exit and do
u-turns and come back
correct so if I go back to the documents
that were presented to us
the difference between these documents
which are very
very solid and
provide a clear plan as to the phased
approach The Province was taking
we were never responding to this
document we were responding to the
premier speech
this document was not available to us at
that time the premier speech was a
speech that in no way
even mentioned the situation in Kutz and
we were not looking for recognition but
it nowhere mentioned and what it did
mention was a lot of maybes
which we if we had the speech we could
bring it up so we responded to the
Premiership
wording the tone and everything around
his address we did not respond to a
document that showed a phased approach
this document in and of itself is
actually a fairly reasonable document
but that was not what we were responding
to
so you're gonna have to wrap up okay
I've got two more questions
um truckers were labeled Heroes for
nearly two years
um and then with a stroke of uh well
because they were deemed to be risking
their lives for nearly two years with a
stroke of a pen
um those that were unvaccinated became
essentially persona non grata so that
the truckers became they weren't allowed
attention to some some of them couldn't
cost questions yes yes would you agree
with the with the statement that
um that suddenly they for many years
they were I mean for almost two years
they were labeled Heroes and then
suddenly they were
not allowed to work correct and that was
that was the frustration they were the
heroes of the of the pandemic the
truckers when the drive-throughs were
closed when they had no ability to use
washrooms when they had no access to
restaurants the truckers were the heroes
of the pandemic
and then
with the stroke of a pen and obviously
there was there was discussion around
that truckers had to make a decision
and my last question is
um sorry with with respect to the
implementation of the public uh the
emergency Act
um and and the measures taken by the
federal government
um
do you believe that it was because
they were embarrassed by the various
protests and various
basically the various protests
absolutely absolutely
um and and not specific uh specifically
quotes I do believe in regards to if
quotes were the only protest happening
we would have got the attention the full
attention of the federal government but
Ottawa and Ambassador Bridge
um were were the draw you know uh
Alberta and how that was affecting or
how Coots was affecting Alberta is
something the the Alberta Government was
aware of but in the evidence provided
um there is an exchange between Bill
Blair and Rick McIver and there's six or
seven days where there is no response to
a request by Rick McIver for assistance
by the federal government to removing or
assisting and removing the blockade
until
the minister
texts Rick McIver and essentially says
oh by the way we invoke the emergencies
act
um which obviously set off a pretty
heated exchange between the two so it
goes to show you that for six seven days
there was there there was no
communication between the federal and
the provincial governments So that
obviously put Coots on a
coach was of little concern to the
federal government as a whole it was a
concern like they were addressing it but
not in not on the same level as Ottawa
or as the Ambassador Bridge and I can
understand that but
um the the EMA was enacted as a you know
in my view as a as a as a political
tactic more than a actual enforcement
tactic
thank you thank you commissioner any
re-examination just one quick question
or
is this on yeah
wave cleanup I showed you at the
beginning your statement of anticipated
evidence that was for the record
s-a-e-703 and I forgot to ask you
whether you adopt that statement so Mr
van human boss do adopt that statement
yes otherwise okay thank you those are
all my questions
okay thank you well that completes the
business for today so we can adjourn
until uh tomorrow morning at 9 30. uh
I think tomorrow will be a longer day so
people should come prepared to uh stay
longer than normal so
look forward to seeing you all back
the commission is a journey